react is one of the most popular
javascript frameworks
in this comprehensive and well-made
course thomas weibenfalk will teach you
everything you need to know to start
using react
hello and welcome i'm thomas webenfart a
developer from sweden
and thank you for enrolling this course
i'm actually a little bit of extra proud
on this one because
i created a lot of courses during the
years now but this one
is the first ever course i created
because i love react
and i wanted to create courses so this
is the third iteration the third version
meaning that i've improved it a lot and
listened to you guys
on what stuff you want in the course so
i think it's actually really good
there's always room for improvements of
course but this one i really enjoyed
this one and it was fun making it
also so hopefully you'll find a lot of
basic stuff and intermediate stuff and
maybe some advanced stuff to learn in
this course
and i think we have to get started so
let's do that
let's take a look at the application
that we're building in this course
and it's a nice little move application
that is based on the movie database api
so you'll have to create an account at
the movie database
but we'll do that in the next video so i
thought i could show you the application
so that you have a little feeling about
what we're going to build in this course
and this one is always going to show the
most popular movie here we have this
hero image so we're going to create this
one
and we also have some text and we have a
header up here also
then we can search for movies for
example
star wars and we'll see all the movies
here
so that's how the basic functionality of
this application is
and if we click on the movie you can see
that we get all data from that movie
so that's nice we're going to show the
actress and also some information about
the movie itself
we can see the revenue the budget and
the running time for example and here
you may think that you can also click on
actress and yeah of course
we could do that but i have to limit
this tutorial somewhere
so this course is not going to go there
but it's a great
foundation if you want to build up on
this application
so you can add in the functionality of
showing information about the different
actors and stuff like that
we also have this little breadcrumb menu
up here so we can go back to the home
page
and in this version of the course this
is version three i'm going to show you
how to create
the styles also i'm going to be fairly
quick when i show the styles because i
still want to have the main focus
on react itself so that's something
that's new in this version 3
of this course and of course everything
is going to be responsive
we're going to create that one also as
you can see here the grid for example
with the movies
it changes depending on the viewport
size
so that's nice so it's a fully working
application and to be honest i'm
quite proud of this design i created a
design myself
because i'm both a developer and a
designer so that's why i
love doing design stuff also and i think
it looks
pretty neat actually i've updated it
slightly
since the previous versions to look a
little bit more modern
but i think it's mostly yeah i changed
some colors for example on the button
and stuff like that
all right so that's the application in
the next video i'm going to talk about
the movie database api
and how you can register to get your own
free api key that i'm going to use in
this course
okay so let's talk about the movie
database api
that's the api that we're going to use
in this course and the movie database
has a great api for fetching a lot of
movies tv shows and stuff like that
we are going to focus on the movies so
that's what we're gonna do here
and you can sign up for a free account
at the movie database
so just go to themoviedb.org
and click join tmdb and then you can
fill out your username and password and
email and create an account
and when you have created the account
you probably get an email where you have
to verify yourself
before you can log in but when you have
created your account
make sure that you go back to the
moviedb and click on login
and then you enter your username and
password just as a regular site that you
log into
all right and then you presented with
this dashboard kind of thing
i think it's a dashboard and the only
thing you have to do is go up here to
your profile and click on this
round button up here and then you have
the settings here so choose settings
and then at the left menu here you can
see that you have something that's
called
api so click on api i guess i probably
have to blur this once out
because i don't want to show you my own
api key
this is the one that we're using api key
version 3
auth so this is the one that we're going
to use so make sure to
save this somewhere for now because we
are going to add it to our application
in a little while so you make sure that
you have easy access to this one
as we're going to paste this in into our
application in a little while
when we have bootstrapped our
application with something that's called
create react app and i'm going to talk
more about that in a little while
before we start creating our application
i just want to talk a little bit about
react and what it is
so if you go to the react js.org you can
read more about react and this is a
great starting point
if you just started out with react they
have a different documentation they have
tutorials and a blog and stuff like that
and you can read
everything that you need to know to get
started with react
so i tried to make this course kind of
beginner friendly
but react is kind of at least
intermediate
in its own nature so it's hard to make
it
really really beginner friendly it also
depends a lot on
how you learn stuff i love to learn
stuff in this project oriented way
where i just build some project and
learn along the way
so i only create courses on how i want
to learn stuff myself
but it's very individual so some may
think that
it's not beginner friendly at all and
some may think that it is
that's why i also recommend to check out
react.js.org
to read about the very very basic stuff
at least
in react so what is react yeah react is
a javascript library for building user
interfaces as they tell you here
i think actually that this sentence is a
little bit misleading because
you're using react for so much more than
to just build a user in the face
for example i i build a lot of stuff i
build small games
i build a pac-man game for example and i
build
all the logic in react also so it's not
only the view layer so it can be a
little bit
misleading here i think um just thinking
about that you create the components for
the view
but that's not the case you can use
react for so much more
if you want to do that and in this
application we're building everything in
react so we have
all the api calls and everything it's
done from react so that's how we're
going to use it in this course
and react uses the declarative paradigm
i don't even know if i pronounce that
correctly but hopefully
you know what i mean so react is
declarative but for example
jquery is imperative and when something
is declarative
you explain in this case the user
interface how it will look
you don't have to tell it exactly how
you want to achieve that look
you just tell it that we want our ui to
look in a certain
way and then react takes care of the
rest for example in jquery we have to
grab the dom elements
and we have to modify the dom elements
and we have to create them
row by row and then attach the element
to the dom
itself so there can be a lot of code
involved in doing something
simple actually but in react for example
we have
as they say here it's component based so
we create a component
and then we just tell react to use that
component and it will render out that to
the dom for us and this will
be more clear as we go along in the
course and create our own components
and create the application itself so
don't worry if you don't understand
everything right now so it's declarative
it's component based and learn ones
right then
where yeah as they tell you here they
don't care about the rest of the
technology stack
so that's great you can use a lot of
stuff in combination with react
so what is the react component yeah we
can take a look here
for example here they create this is a
class and this is kind of
i like to call it the old way the
classes still exist
i don't use them anymore and in this
course we're going to focus on
creating functional components and i'm
going to tell you more about that later
and in the end of the tutorial when we
have finished the application i also
going to show you how to convert some of
the components
the stateful components to class
components
just in case you need to know how to
create class components also because
the reality is if you start working for
a company or a client
there may probably be some components
that are still class components because
there's a lot of applications made in
react
that's made before we had state in
functional components
so that's why you had to had a class
before to have stated in them
and we're going to talk about that later
also so this is a component they create
with a class and they call it a hello
message
and as you can see here they're using
something that's very much like
a regular html they have this tag here
with a hello message and this
name is a so-called prop they're sending
in
and we're going to talk more about props
also later so don't worry about that
but this is actually not html it's
something that's called
jsx and that's something that we're also
going to learn
in this course so we create the
component here
so we tell it to use this component and
react will take care of the rest
and create this div with our text hello
and in this case it's going to be the
name
that we send in with the prop so the
name is going to be taylor
it's going to type out hello taylor as
you can see here
so this is very very neat with react we
can reuse these components in our
application
so that's short on what react is and as
i told you we're going to learn
a lot more stuff in the course itself
when we create application
and hopefully at the end of the course
you'll have more
understanding of react and how awesome
it is because i really love react
i'm really passionate about using react
and
actually this course is also something
that i'm very passionate about
because this is my first ever course i
created and this is the third version
meaning that i have listened to people
that have enrolled this course before
and changed stuff and added stuff to
make it
more optimal and more perfect and
hopefully
you'll enjoy this course
for this course i provided you with a
zip file that you should download before
you start the course
and this zip file contains a few folders
here as you can see
and it may look maybe a little bit
different when
i end the recording of this course
because i haven't really recorded it yet
but i think it will look this way but if
it looks a little bit different
it's okay hopefully you can read the
folder names and understand what they
for
so i'm going to provide you with a
folder that's called files to be copied
to the project folder
these are files that we're going to use
for the course so i have
created a file for us that set up the
api so we don't have to write
our own functions for fetching the data
so i'm going to show you that when we
fetch data from the api
i have a config file and a helpers file
and i'm going to talk more about those
later also
and then i have a few images that we
also need for the course so that's why i
have this
folder that we're going to copy over to
a project when we have created it
and the public folder the index.html
file
i have this here because i'm using a
google font for this one
so i've already provided that one in the
index.html so we don't have to do that
ourselves
so that's the one that we have to copy
later and i'm going to show you that
when
that time comes and you're also going to
have two options
if you don't want to create everything
from scratch when i set up the
application
you can just ignore that and start from
a project
without the styles and this is if you
want to create the styles also i
structure this course
so you should be able to fairly easy
just skip the parts where
i create the styling for the components
some
people of you don't want to create the
css and the styling so that's
why i made it in this way so this is the
one you should use
if you want to create the styles
otherwise you use
the one that's called with styles that
one will provide you
with all the styling so you don't have
to type in the styles
and you can skip those videos so if you
want to start from one of those projects
you navigate inside of that one and in
your terminal you type npm install
and that's going to install all the
dependencies for you
and then every time you start up the
application you can type in
npm start and that's also something that
i'm going to show you so don't worry
about that
then you have a folder with a finished
app if you want to check out the result
but please be aware here you have to put
your own
api key in a file
that's hidden here now it's called dot
end inside of that one you have to paste
in your own api key
otherwise it won't work
and that goes for the stepped solutions
also i have provided you with step
solutions that corresponds to each video
and if you want to run
an example from a particular step
solution you also have to paste in your
api
key in the dot n file and i'm also going
to talk more about the dot
n file but this is the starter files so
you have to think about
if you want to create the styling in
this course and you also have to think
about
now if you want to set everything up
from scratch or if you don't want to do
that you can just start from one of
these folders here
navigate inside of them type npm install
or if you're using yarn you should be
able to use that one also
and then mpm start or yarn start to
start up the application
all right let's move on in the next
video i'm just
shortly going to talk about the tooling
that i'm using for this course
just a short short little video about
what tooling i'm using for this course
i think you already should know this
tooling and have it installed
to be able to fully take advantage of
this course otherwise
it can be a little bit hard if you for
example
haven't used npm that i'm going to use
to install dependencies
i suggest that you learn about that
first because this is a beginner
slash intermediate course in react it's
not a beginner course in coding
you should know some javascript and
especially es6 syntax we're going to use
a lot of es6 syntax in this course so it
should be a good idea to to shape up
your knowledge in javascript before
starting to learn react
but that's only my opinion but of course
you should do it your own way
if you want to learn react before
vanilla javascript it's totally up to
you
i shouldn't tell anyone on how they want
to take on their coding
journey all right so i'm using mpm
and that means that i have to have node
installed we're not
using node.js per se but node.js
includes the mpm package manager so
that's why we have to install that one
so if you don't have that installed
make sure to grab the latest version and
install it
then i use visual studio code as my id
so that's what i'm using in this course
and then i'm going to use
create direct app and bootstrap our
react application really fast and easy
so that's what we're gonna do and i'm
actually gonna do that in the next video
so let's get started with our
application
[Music]
i'm happy to see that you're going to
create this project from scratch
and we're going to use create direct app
to bootstrap our application
so let's get started if we look at the
home page for create react app you can
find it at crate
dash rack react-app.dev
and then they have something here in the
menu that's called get started
and the only thing that we have to do is
remember this
row here npx create dash react dash app
and then you have the name of your
application that you want to create
and mpx is something that's provided
with mpm in the latest versions
so you don't have to globally install
create react app to use it
this will make sure that we grab the
latest version so i always use
npx instead of first globally installing
create react app
so this is really great because then i
know that i'm using the latest version
and you don't have to install it
globally but if you want to do that you
can of course install
create react app globally first but this
is the command that i'm going to use so
make sure that you navigate inside of
your terminal
i'm using a terminal that's called hyper
i get a lot of questions about that
what terminal i'm using i actually don't
remember the
name of the theme but i styled it a
little bit to my likings
so that's sweet so hyper is a great
terminal if you want to have a
customized terminal
you also have a built-in terminal in
visual studio code of course
so let's get started make sure that you
navigate inside of a folder where you
want to create your application
and then we type in mpx and then create
dash react dash app
and then we have the name of our
application and i'm going to
name it react rmdb
and rmdb stands for react movie database
so that's the best i could come up with
you can use whatever name you want
and then we can hit enter and then wait
for it
it will install everything for us so it
will take a little while
all right hopefully they're installed
correctly for you and create react app
has now hopefully bootstrapped or
application you could set up this
yourself and not use
create direct app but create react app
is actually used in
in many production applications and it's
actually used
right now for a client that i work with
and it's a fairly large application so
you can do a lot of stuff with create
direct app
and it's using babel and webpack in the
background to set up the react
environment for you so that's what you
could do yourself if you don't want to
use create direct app but i'm not going
to show that in this course because i
think it's a little bit advanced for a
beginner course
and actually we're going to be fine with
create direct app that's all that we
need
so we're also going to make sure that it
works so make sure that you navigate
inside of the project folder
i'm going to clear this and then type in
cd
react dash rmdb or whatever you named it
and then we're inside of that folder and
then we can type mpm start
and it should start up our environment
this is the finished one that's here now
so it's going to
be replaced by this application here so
it's working
and we have successfully bootstrapped
our application and that's sweet
in the next video we're going to install
a few dependencies that we're going to
use for this project
we have bootstrapped our application and
now we're going to install some
dependencies that we're going to use for
this project
and the first one is going to be
something that's called react
router and react router is the standard
in a react application
for handling routes because this is a
single page application and we need
something to handle our routing
because we are going to have different
pages and the one that we're going to
use is called react router there is
another library that's called
reach router and i'm actually using that
one in version 2 of this course
but the team that created reach router
and react router
is the same team so they're going to
kind of merge them together
into react router version six
and this one is still in beta mode but
i've talked to them and i think that i
should have this one in this course
because it will soon be out and the api
won't likely change because we're not
going to use the most advanced stuff in
this router library
so we will be fine and we have some
instructions down here
i'm at github.com forward slash react
training forward slash react router
forward slash releases and down below
here
we can see that we have some
instructions on on how to install it
so i'm going to bring up my terminal
i'm going to do something like this and
we could of course just copy this one
and paste it in
but in my courses i wanted to learn as
much as possible
and it's always a great idea to not copy
paste too much
and type stuff in because that will make
you remember stuff
much easier so that's what we're going
to do now so
i'm going to type in mpmi or if you're
using yarn you can of course use that
instead i'm going to use mpm for this
whole course
and i'm typing in i instead of typing
out the complete word
install that's a shorthand for install
so mpmi and then we need to install
something that's called history also
that's another library that's used
in combination with react router and we
can install them in one go
if i type history here then i have a
blank space and then i can type in the
other library that i want to install and
in this case it's going to be
react-router-dom
and then we have an at sign and next and
this will grab the beta version of
react-router
so press enter and wait for it
hopefully that installed for you
correctly so i'm going to clear my
console again
and we're going to move on to something
that's called style components
style components is a super great
library to use in combination with react
with style components we can create our
css in isolated and scoped components
so that's really really great and we
have a lot of features that we have for
example in sas
we can do nesting and stuff like that
and we can send in props
and change our styling dynamically and
i'm going to talk more about
style components as we go along in this
course because we are going to create
the styling
if you choose that path that i really
think you should
if you want to have some css practice
but it's up to you i've provided you
with different alternatives for this
course
so we're going to install style
components and you can read more about
it at styledashcomponents.com
so go back to the terminal and we type
in mpmi
style dash components and we press enter
all right that went smoothly so i clear
the console yet again and we move on to
the last dependency that we need
and that is something that's called prop
types prop types
is a great tool in react where you can
type check your props that you send into
your components
so as they say here it's runtime type
checking for react props and similar
objects
so that's great today a lot of people
use typescript instead then you don't
need to use prop types and i actually
use typescript a lot myself i
started to like it actually but in our
case we're not using typescript
right now i'm going to show you that at
the end of this course in a special
module that i created
where we refactor everything to use
typescript instead
but for now we're not using typescript
so that's why we're going to use prop
types
and i'm going to talk more about this
later in the course and i've
placed it kind of at the end of the
course because i don't want
too much stuff going on when we learn
react so that's why
so i'm going to talk about it at the end
of the course and when you create a
component that has some props
you should use prop types to to do type
checking on your props
but i'm not going to do that first i'm
going to add it in later
in the course so we don't get distracted
of too much
stuff going on all right so go back to
the terminal
type in mpmi prop dash types
and press enter so that's it that's our
dependencies
and of course i didn't mention it at the
start of this video you should of course
be
in the folder that we created the
application that we bootstrapped with
create react app it's very important
you have to navigate inside of that
folder otherwise it won't work because
we are installing the dependencies
in that project folder all right in the
next video we're going to copy some
files from the starter file zip file
to this product that we're going to need
to make this work
if we look inside of our product folder
react r db
we can see that we have some different
folders and files here
and for example if we look in the public
folder we can see that we have some
image files on the index.html file and
this is the folder that
the dev environment is going to build
for us so the public folder is the
finished files that we're using for
running the application
so that's everything inside of there and
the source folder the src folder is
going to be the folder
where we created all our stuff for the
application
so you can see we have some css file and
we have an app file
an index file and an index css file we
also have a test file
we're not going to do any tests in this
course so this one
we're not going to use and we have a
service worker we're not going to use
this one either
and we have the setup test that we're
not going to use
if we take a look inside of our zip file
the starter files that you should have
downloaded for this
course and we take a look inside of the
first folder here
one files to be copied to product folder
alright so that's the files that are
going to be copied
to the project so make sure that you
mark them here
copy them move back to your folder your
project folder
and paste them in and then you're going
to choose to replace the old folders
this one is in swedish here so you
probably don't understand it if you're
not
from sweden but what it says here is to
replace it so i'm going to click that
button
and then it going to ask me if i want to
merge the source folder or
if i want to replace it so if it asks
you to merge it or replace it
always choose replace
all right so we successfully copy the
files and if we take a look inside of
the public folder here we're going to
have exactly the same
files the only difference is that i've
added in
a google import of a font that's called
able or
able i don't really know if i pronounce
it correctly
it sounds better to pronounce it able so
i think that's the correct one
that's the only thing i've changed here
and that's in the index.html file the
other files
remain the same so that's the public
folder and if we look inside of the src
folder you can see that
it's lesser files now and that's because
i removed all the files
that has something to do with tests or
the service worker and all the css files
that we don't need
because we're going to use style
components and i also added in some
files
and a folder we have the images folder
and this one
of course contains the images that we're
going to use for this course
and then i have a file that's called
api.js and
inside of this file there's some
functions that are going to handle the
api calls to the movie database api and
in the previous versions we actually
created these ones ourselves in the
course but i think that
was just a distraction from react and
react syntax
because this is a course about learning
react and the thing is that this is
regular javascript inside of this one it
has nothing to do with
react per se so that's why i created
this one for you instead and place them
in a file
and of course i'm going to talk more
about these functions when we reach that
point
in the course and then i have a config
file and this config file
contains everything that has to be set
up with the movie database api
and i have a helpers file also and the
helpers file contains a couple of
functions that will help us to convert
some numbers
into to money and also to convert our
time
and i'm going to talk more about these
two files also later in this course
so these are the files hopefully this
one will work so if we go back to our
terminal
and this one is running now so just to
be sure i'm going to break it and run
mpm start
just to see that it works
it's always a great idea to see that
stuff works when you change something
and then i go to my browser and reload
the page and you can see i'm at
localhost
3000 just as before but now this
nice little rotating react logo is
removed and it says start here
and that is because i remove that one
and i've modified this file so that we
can start from here now
in this application so if it says start
here you know that you successfully
copied all the files
hopefully and it should work for you in
the next video we're going to move on
and actually use that api key that you
got
when you're registered for the movie
database api
okay we got one more thing to do and
then we finished with the setup of our
project
and that is that we're going to create a
dot and file
and paste in our api key so in our
application folder at the root we're
going to create a new file
i'm going to call it dot e n v
dot m and create react app has
built-in support for environmental
variables
the only thing that you have to do is to
name them with react
first so react
underscore and that's important
otherwise it won't recognize it and this
one is going to be called
app underscore api underscore key
all capital letters and then we have an
equal sign
and then you can paste in your api key
here and that's everything you have to
do
so just paste it in just after the equal
sign
and you're good to go and save the file
this api key
is then used in the source folder in my
config.js file
you can see that i get it here process
process.n
dot react app api key
and this is all managed inside the
create react app when it's startup or
dev environment
and creates all the files for us and
stuff it will take care of this but it's
really important to market with react
underscore before the actual name of the
environmental variable
and all this stuff here is something
that i created for you so you don't have
to
care about this so i create the
different resources from the endpoint on
the movie database here and we're going
to use these resources
in the course later and then i'm going
to talk about them more
so i have different endpoints for the
search for example and to get the
popular movies
and these ones are for the bonus videos
at the end where i create the login
and voting that also provided with the
movie database api you can log in with
your account
and cast a vote on a movie or on all
movies if you want to do that
then we have the image base url this one
is also from the movie database
so these ones are provided from the api
so i just
use them according to their instructions
and we have a backdrop size we can set
the size
of the backdrop and the poster size on
the images we can set different sizes
here and i marked them here
for you if you want to try to change
them and see what it does
so we don't have to think more about
these as i set them up for you
and there's also a file that's called
api.js
and inside of this one i created the
actual code that is going to fetch the
data
we can call these functions later when
we fetch the data and we don't have to
type
in all of this ourselves and of course
i'm also going to talk more about these
functions
later when we fetch the movies so this
one is for fetching all the movies
and this one is for fetching one movie
and then we have
this one here that will fetch the
credits and below here these are all for
the bonus material also so you don't
have to care about those
in the kind of main part of the course
so we have three functions here that is
going to fetch data for us
so that's one thing i change actually in
this version of the course before this
we created these ones ourselves in the
course but i think it's a little bit
advanced for a beginner course and i
also think that it takes the focus on
react itself because this is javascript
it's not the react specific code
so that's why and i want this experience
i want this course to be a fun course
also
so you don't get tired and stop the
course and won't finish it
so that's why i created these ones for
us
all right so that's the config and the
api file and then i have one more file
that's called helpers.js
and this one contains two functions
that's going to help us to calculate the
time
and also convert to money because the
numbers that we get from the api has to
be converted
both the time and the money so i'm going
to use these ones
later in the course also all right
so create the dot n file create a
variable
react underscore app underscore api
underscore key
capital letters equals and then you
paste in your api key
otherwise it won't work because you
can't access the api
one really important thing to notice
here is that this
environmental variable won't be safe
because it will be visible in the client
so don't think that this one won't show
up in the browser
of course you have to look for it but if
you're good at looking through code you
will be able to find this api key
so this is not a safe way to provide an
api key if you want to hide it from the
browser
in our case it's not that kind of a
secret key
so it doesn't matter and for the sake of
the course it would be too advanced
to create a system that will hide this
for us completely
so notice this one won't be safe in the
client
before we move on i want to talk about a
really important aspect of react that i
think
a lot of people actually forget and that
is when we create
stuff with react we are also using
something that's called jsx
and it stands for javascript xml and if
we look here
i'm at the react.js.org page now and
they show us here how to create the
component and this is a class component
and as i told you before we are going to
create functional components
so we're not going to create class
components for this application
but they are using jsx here and this is
jsx you may think that this is
html but it's actually not it's jsx
and jsx is something that is really
great to use
in combination with react because we can
render out our different components like
this
by using html ish syntax
i think a lot of people actually forget
it's because i don't know exactly the
percentage but i think at least 99
of the applications use jsx in
combination with react
some people don't use it and that's what
i'm going to talk about here
because you can create components
without jsx in react
and that is if we scroll down here you
use something that's called create
element on the react object so
react.createelement
we specify if we want some props and
then we specify the child elements for
this element and you can see
up here react.createelement we have the
component that we want to create we have
the props
and also we have the children and this
is the spread syntax in javascript es6
that's why they use three dots here to
explain this so this one here is
actually the same as this
this one here will transpile down to
react.createelement
but it wouldn't be practical to use
react.createelement for every component
and everything you do in react
you can see that it's not that readable
and it will get kind of messy and i
actually think that
react wouldn't be that fun to use if you
use it this way
so i'm just going to show you how to
create an element with react.create
element also
and in the next video i'm going to talk
more about jsx but
now i'm going to show you just a small
example on how you can create an element
with react.createelement so let's move
back to our terminal and make sure that
our dev environment is running
so mpm start always use mpem start when
you start up your dev server
and you can see that we have it running
here now then i go back to visual studio
code
and i'm going to be in the app.js file
for this one it's inside the src folder
and this is kind of the heart of our
application
we have the index.js that is the start
file for the application
and you can see that that i import the
app component here
these imports are es6 syntax for import
so we can import a model
and in this case the model is a
component and it's called app so i
import that one here and then it's used
here and this one is jsx
so this is the heart of our application
we have both the library that's called
react
and we have react dom because react can
be used for other stuff than the dom
for example you can create native apps
with react
but we are going to use the library
react dom and this one is all set up
with create react app for us
so you can see that from the react dom
that we import here
we call the render method and we give it
the component that we want to render
and we tell it where we want to render
it so from the document.getelement
we get the root element so if we look
inside of our public
and the index.html you can see that we
have a div here
that's called root and it's inside of
this div
that we're going to render out our
complete application
we can close the public folder node and
go back to the index.js file
so we telling react to render
application to a div
that's called root and it's also in
something that's called react strict
mode
it wasn't that before but this is a
default now with create dragged app and
strict mode is actually great
it's gonna do a few more checks if you
do some stuff that you shouldn't be
doing
when you code your application so it's
always a good idea to using the strict
mode in
react all right so let's move back to
the app.js file
and as you can see here we have this
element here we have the div that's
called app
and i render out start here and that's
the one that we saw before
when we started up the application you
don't have to type this in if you don't
want because i want to show you this
this has nothing to do with the
application that we're going to build so
i'm going to
create a little component now and then
i'm going to remove it and we can
continue on
creating our application i'm going to do
it with an
arrow function i like to use arrow
function they don't do it here
but you can change this one if you want
to an arrow function const app
equals and then we create an arrow here
instead like that
i'm used to using arrow functions so i
use them for components also
so const i'm going to create the
component that's called star
and i have an arrow function and then
from react
we import react here you always have to
import react at the top
and then i call create element
i have a parenthesis i'm going to create
a div
and then we're not going to have any
props because we haven't talked about
props yet
so i set that one to null and then i'm
going to render out the string
this is a little star
like that and i'm going to remove the
sidebar so we can see
the component here so this is instead of
using jsx
and if we want to render this one out
instead of returning this one here
i'm going to return the store
and as this is a function now i also
have to call it like this
save it and then i'm going to go back to
the application and you can see
this is a little star so it renders out
perfectly
and this is just a small example and i
wanted just
for you to notice that you don't need to
use jsx and this is actually the react
functionality at its core so you don't
have to use jsx
but we are gonna use jsx because it's
sweet
and it's fun to work with and i think
actually that it would be
a small hell creating applications
without jsx
at least i think so so i remove
everything i created here and save the
file again just make sure that it works
start here and it works and that's great
so that's a little bit about react dot
create element
and using react without jsx just a small
small
note on that one i'm not gonna go any
deeper into it
because i don't think it's actually
relevant to use react without jsx so
that's why
okay i talked a little about using react
without jsx but i actually don't think
that's a great idea
so that's why i also want to talk a
little about jsx
before we move on with this application
so jsx stands for javascript
xml and it's pretty similar to regular
html
so if we take a look here you can see
that they create an h1 tag here that
says hello world and this looks
just like plain html but as they say
here this fun attack syntax is neither a
string nor
html and i actually don't think if it's
a fun attack as to say here but all
right
you get the id why jsx we can read here
more about why we are using jsx
and the main thing here thing is that
they don't want to
put markup in one file and logic in
another file
they want to have them combined in one
file and that may sound
scary for some because a couple of years
ago you shouldn't ever mix them together
but
in react it works really great and as
they say here react components contain
both markup and logic so jsx is
something that is created to look
pretty similar to html there are a few
differences and i wanted to talk about
those here
because in this case we create an h1
element and that looks
exactly the same but there are some
stuff that differ from
regular html and for example here you
can see you can embed javascript those
expressions here
for the source area in the image tag for
example you can use curly brackets and
then you
embed a javascript expression and that's
super great that you can combine them
this way
and also as you look here tab index it's
camel cased
that differs from html and they say it
here also since jsx is closest to
javascript
then to html react dom user's camel case
property naming convention
instead of html attribute names
so remember that that you have to use
camel case in jsx
and there are some few differences for
example when you set a class on an
element
you don't use the class keyword you use
class
name camel case and they also mention it
here
and it took a little bit of time for me
to get used to this one
and now i actually type in class name
when i type out regular html
and also it's good to know that jsx is
quite safe it prevents
injection attacks and stuff like that so
i think you learn a lot about jsx as we
go along in this course
because we are going to use practical
examples in this course
but the most important part is to
remember that jsx is not
html and it's also used camel casing
when you create an attribute
before we dive in and create our
components with state and props and all
these vital things in react
you can sit down relax have a drink have
a beer have a
cup of tea or whatever you're drinking
and just listen to me in this video
where i'm gonna talk a little about
props and stayed in react
the first thing you can do is to imagine
that this is a room
seen from above and the great circle
here is a lamp
that's not turned on and the orange one
is a lamp that's turned on
each of these lamps has a light switch
that is off and on so if i click this
one here i can turn this light on
and the light switch is going to change
to on and this one i can turn it off so
both lamps are off and i turn this one
on
and i turn this one on and this is made
possible because i can use staid in
react
so i have two states for the lamps i
have one state for the first dump and
one for the second lamp
that is the boolean that is telling if
the lamp is on and off
but if we think about this we actually
have a state of the room also
because we need this state also for the
light switch to change
from off to on because these are kind of
tied together
so you can look at the state in
different perspectives
in this case i will look at the state
from the room perspective
so i haven't placed the states in the
lamps or
in the light switches i have placed the
states in the room itself because we
have a room state
and for the room it's going to be if the
lamps and the light switches are on or
off
so we have a state for the room itself
and this is what i
talked about in the for example the
react documentation
they tell you that you can lift up the
state to apparent component if you want
to use that state
in multiple shell components because if
we place the state in the lamp itself
for example
we could only access that state in the
lamp and to its child components
of course we could place the light
switches as a shield to the lamp
but that wouldn't be the most effective
way of doing it and it would
complicate things if you want to reuse
your code so what i've done here instead
is that i have this room here and i've
placed the components in the room
and i'm also going to have the state in
the room so we can use that state both
for the lamps and the light switches
and i'm going to show you how i did this
now and also talk a little bit more
about state and props
so if we take a look inside of the code
here this is the application
that i created for you you can also open
it up from the starter files in this
course i provided it there
so i have the index file the standard
index file that shows the app component
and f component is actually going to be
the room so i could also name this room
because this is actually the room
component
and as you can see here in the room
component i'm creating two states
in react when you create a state with
hooks you use something that's called
use state hook before we had hooks we
had to use classes to have state in them
so you couldn't ever create a functional
component that had state in them
but now we have hooks and that means
that we can have stateful
functional components and that's sweet
so when we call this use
state hook we can initialize it with an
initial value
so in this case i'm giving it false
because i want this lamp to be turned
off initially
then i do something that's called es6
destruction here
i'm destruction of this array that i get
back from the used state hook
so we can name our state here to
whatever we want in this case i name it
islam one on and then we have the setter
for the state
set is lamp one on and there's a few
things you should know about state in
react and the first one is that
you should look at the state as
immutable you should never mutate the
state
then that means that you always should
use the state setter that you get back
to set the state in react if you're
modifying the state directly for example
try to change this one
this means that your component won't
re-render and that's no good and it can
also cause a lot of trouble in the
future for you in the application
but if you use the setter and change the
state and don't mutate the state
your component will re-render and update
the dom
and this is how stuff works in react you
update to dom when your components
re-render
and one more thing with functional
components is that we can have as many
states as we want with
the used state hook in the class
components you can only have one state
so you have to
kind of create an object with different
properties to hold your state
this is super sweet we can divide the
states up now
depending on how we want to structure
the state so in this case i created two
states i have one for the lamp one
and i have one for the lamp two so they
are doing the exact same thing the only
difference here is when i initialize it
i set this one to true and this will
turn lamp two on
all right now i have two functions and
these ones are going to be called when
we click the light switch so i have one
for the light switch one
and one for the light switch two you
could have one
function instead but i want to make it
really really clear on how stuff works
so that's why i created two of them
so we have one function for the switch
one and one for the switch two
and this one will set its lamp one
that's the setter for the state one for
the lamp one
and what i do here is that i provide it
with an inline function and when you
provide the state setter with a function
it will get called with a previous state
so in this case i'm going to flip that
boolean value
so when i click the button the first
time this value is going to get be
true instead because it's false
initially and this one for the button 2
is going to be false because it's true
all right so these are the functions for
the light switches so if we look at the
jsx here what we return to the dom
this one is a room component and if i go
up here you can see that this is the
style component
that we're also going to talk a lot
about in this course i create a style
component
that's a div here so i set some styling
on that one on the room itself i
i make it 500 pixel width and 500 pixels
in height
and i set a border on it and the morgan
zero in order is going to center it on
the screen
so everything is wrapped in this room
component then i have a component that's
a lamp i'm going to talk about that in a
second and i also have the light switch
so we have the state in this app
component that's the room
so this is where i kind of gather all
the states for this little simple
application
and this way i can use this state in
both the lamp component and the light
switch
because as you can see here for the lamp
component i created something that's
called props
props is something that you can create
and that will get sent along into your
component that you create
props is an object so you can create as
many properties on that object as you
want
in this case i created a lamp on prop so
this one will be sent into the lamp
component
in the prop object i also created a prop
that's called position
and this is how i can make the lamp
appear on the left or on the right
in the room and the lamp on is going to
be the state for the lamps so this one
is going to be a boolean
and that way this component will know if
the lamp is on and off
and i'm going to show you that in a
second and i do the same with the light
switch
and for this one i have the callback as
i showed you up here i give this one a
prop that i call callback
it doesn't have to be called callback
that's a name that i choose
and the switch on i'm going to give it
the lamp state for this one so you can
see that i use the lamp states
for both the lamp and the light switches
and this is what i talked about before
if we created the state for the lamp in
the lamp itself we wouldn't be able to
access this state for the light switch
then we have to create the light switch
as a child of the lamp
and that's no good as you probably can
see now because now we can place as many
lamps and light switches
we want in our room so it would be much
harder to do it if we
place the staid in the lamp itself and i
also have a position prop for the light
switch
so let's go inside of the lamp component
that i created here
i also have a rapid div for this one
that's a style component so i wrap
everything in that div
and the interesting thing with the style
components is that i also can have props
because they are also valid react
components so we can use
props in our style components to modify
our css
and that's one of the super strengths
with style components i think
because as you can see here this is a
this is something that's called a
template literal and in this template
literal
we can grab the props that are sent into
this component
so in this case i create dollar sign and
curly brackets and i can use a
javascript expression
and i have this inline function here
that gets the props so if we look at the
wrapper component down here you can see
that i also stand in a prop
lamp on and the position so i'm just
sending along these props that i
initially sent
into the lamp component so i get them in
the lamp component and then i also send
them along to the wrapper component
that's a style component and by doing
this i can for example check here if the
props dot position
equals to the left then i'm going to set
the left value to 20 pixels
otherwise i set it to 380 pixels and
that will place it to the right
in the room so this way i can modify my
css and make it very very dynamic so
that's really sweet that you also can
use props
in the style components all right that's
how style component and props works
so if we look at the lamp component here
i'm sending in these props here
and what i'm doing here is i'm using es6
destructuring
so from the object that we get that you
usually call props
i'm just structuring out these values
that i sent in
if i didn't do the destructuring here
and i just do it like this you can see
that it warms me here now then i have to
type in props dot
and props dot because the props is an
object so i have to grab those specific
properties from that object
but if i destructure it out as i do here
i don't have to type that in every time
so i just structure out the properties
here instead
and there's a few things you should know
about props because they differ from
state and the main difference is that
the props are passed into the components
and you should never
ever change the props in the component
that gets the props
the props values are changed from the
parent that is sending in the props to
the component
so if the props change in the parent
it's also going to
render this component here so never ever
change the props values in this
component
you can change the state in a component
with a state setter
and that's how you for example can
trigger a rerender when you change the
state in a component
so that's fine you should change the
state in the component with the setters
but a prop should never be changed
in a component that receives the props
when the prop value changes
this component will render and it will
have the new value in the props
so that's how props works all right we
can check out the light switch also i'm
doing the same here
i i'm the structuring out the props here
and i have this button component that's
the style component and i modify it with
the props here also
so i'm doing the exact same thing here
and you can see here that i send in the
callback that's the function that i have
in the app component here so that's the
one i'm sending in with a callback prop
into the light switch and then i have my
button
and the button has an on click handler
and onclick handler
will trigger this callback function and
this makes this component very dynamic
because by using props
you can make your component dynamic and
you can use it in different situations
in this case
i can send in whatever callback function
i want to be triggered when i click on
the button so that means that i can use
this button in different situations
in this case i'm also showing the switch
on and off because ascending in the prop
switch on
so it probably won't be useful too much
less than this
use case specifically but if you want
you can use this button for something
else than to trigger
a lamp to be turned on or off you can
turn something else on and off
and have another callback function and
that will work
so that's what you use props for also
you can make your components dynamic and
reusable
by giving them some props and by using
these props inside of the component you
can adapt your component
and change the logic you can change the
jsx and what it should render
and stuff like that so that is really
useful
to use props for that all right so
that's short on state and props i hope
this one
give you some insight before we start
creating our own
so let's move on in the next video i'm
going to talk more about style
components and what they are
there's one last thing i want to talk
about before we start creating some code
for real
and that is style components because in
the next video we're going to create a
global styles
for our application and we're going to
do that with style components
so just a short talk about style
components and why it's
so great and i think the biggest benefit
is
one that you get scoped css and that
means that you can have the same class
names
for different components it doesn't
matter because it's scoped to that
component
and number two is that you can use
syntax
kind of like sass for example you can
nest stuff and you don't need to have
polyfills and stuff like that
it will create all that automatically
for you and
number three is that you can have props
inside of it and props is something that
we're going to talk a lot about in this
course
because it's an essential part in react
and that means that you can modify the
css by sending in different props to
your styles
you don't need to know exactly now how
props work
because we're going to talk about that
later in the course and also you can use
just plain regular css and that's super
great
also so that is some benefits that style
components
will provide to you when using it in
your application so we already installed
this library and when you use it
you have to import something that's
called style i think they have an
example down here
yeah here import style from styled
components
and style is an object that holds
different properties for example in this
case they want to style a button
so these properties corresponds to what
they are called in the html
so if you want to style a button if you
want to create the style component that
is a button
you use style dot button and then you
have a template literal so this is
something that's called a tagged
template literal and that is a function
that you call with the template literal
so this is es6 syntax in javascript and
it's super great because if we move up
here again
you can see we have this template
literal here
you have the starting backtick and you
have the end backtick here
and inside of here we can write our css
in this case they're using style.a
because they want to style an a tag
and then they do some stuff here plain
regular css
but here is something that's happening
that's not plain css
and this is because we're using a
template literal here we can use
javascript expressions inside of this
template literal
and when you want to use an expression
inside of a template literal you do that
with a dollar sign
and you wrap it inside of curly brackets
and then you can have any javascript
expression that you want inside of here
and it will
interpolate it into the string
and in this case you can see that they
have their props and they have an inline
arrow function and from the props they
grab
a prop that's called primary and they
can set this css conditionally
depending on this primary prop and we're
going to talk more about this later
as i told you so don't get intimidated
if you don't understand this syntax
right now hopefully you will understand
it fully when this course is over
this is just a short introduction before
we create the global styling and we're
gonna do that in the next
video it's time to start coding
and we're gonna start by creating some
global styles
the first thing you have to do is to
start up your dev environment and you do
that by navigating inside of the folder
of your application and then you type
npm start and that will start everything
up for you
and hopefully it looks something like
this it should say start here
and it's always a good idea to have your
console open i'm on chrome now so it
looks something like this
and also i can recommend an extension
that's called react developer tools
and then you will have access to
something that's called components here
and if we open that up we can see our
application here but in this case we
don't have any components yet
so it will just show the app component
here but this is a great tool when you
develop stuff in react
so highly recommended install react
developer tools
okay so let's move back to our
application inside of visual studio code
or whatever id you're using and inside
src folder we're going to create a new
file
that i'm going to call that i'm going to
call global style
capital g and capital s dot
js so this is going to hold all the
global styles for our application
and we're going to create a global
styles with style components
so that's why we have to import a
special thing from the star components
that's called create global style so we
start by doing that
import curly brackets create
global style camel case that means that
there's a capital d
and a capital s and we import it from
style dash components
and this is how you import the module
with es6 syntax
in this case it's not what's called a
default export from this library
so that's why we're grabbing it inside
of the curly brackets
we are going to create default exports
from our different components
and then we don't need to use the curly
brackets but i'm going to show you that
later when we create our first component
okay so we have this create global style
method that we imported here
we are going to use our global styles
inside of our app component later
meaning that we
want to import it here and use it down
here in the jsx
so that also means that we have to
export this style component
from this file so export and this is a
const
also es6 syntax it stands for constant
so that's what we have in javascript now
we have let's we have
const and we have verse i'm always using
cons
before i know if this one is going to
change and then i change it to a let
if it's going to change in the
application but usually const will do
at least when you do functional
programming as we're mostly going to do
in this course so const means that this
one
is not going to change as with
everything there are special cases
when it can change for example if you
create an object with a const
you can change the properties in that
object but you can't change the object
itself
all right enough about that this one is
going to be called global style
and this is a component and every
component that you create in react
is going to have a capital letter to
begin with
so capital g and capital s in this case
and it's going to equal and then we call
this method that we imported up here
create global style and in this case
we're not going to have a dot
on something here because this is the
global style so we're gonna have
double back ticks creating our template
literal
and then i do like this and then we can
write our css inside of this template
literal
and the rest here is going to be regular
plain css so first i want to set up some
css
variables so colon root we do that on
the root
and when you create a css variable you
do that with double dash
and then you have your variable name so
max width
this is camel cased as you can see here
i'm going to set the max width to 1280
pixels
and then i have another variable double
dash white
and then i set my white color another
variable
double dash light gray
this one is going to be ee
double dash matte gray or medium gray
and this one is going to be
three three five three five three five
double dash dark gray
and this one is one c 1 c 1 c
double dash font super big
that's a funny name i had forgot that i
called it that
all right you can call it whatever you
want
this one is going to be 2.5 rem
and the next one is double dash and font
big
1.5 rem double dash
font med or medium 1.2
rem and the last one is going to be
double dash
font small 1 rem and that's our css
variables that we're going to use for
this application
then i'm going to set the font for the
whole application and also do some
resetting here so i have an asterisk
like that i set the box sizing
to border dash box and then i set the
font family
to able and that's the google font
that is imported from the index.html
file
and then i have the backup font of sans
serif
all right that's the resetting then on
the body
i'm gonna set a few things also so i'm
gonna set the margin
to zero the padding is gonna be zero
like that and then as i told you with
style components you can nest
stuff so inside of the body we can nest
the h1 tag
like this and set the font size
to 2rm font weight
is going to be 600
and the color and i'm going to grab this
from my variables that i created up here
and when you grab a variable in css
you do that by typing out var
parenthesis and then the variable name
in this case it's going to be
double dash white so that's the h1
then i'm going to set the h3
the font size is going to be 1.1 rm
and the font weight is going to be 600
on that one also
and then one more thing to do here and
that's the p tag
so font size one rem for the p
tag and the color is also going to be
white so there
double dash white and then i also do
some oral formatting
and sometimes when i do this
create global styling the order
formatting doesn't work i don't know why
so i do it manually instead and save the
file always remember to save your files
it's very easy to forget to save the
file
and then it doesn't work so this is
everything that we need for our global
styles
now we're going to move inside of the
app.js file
and up here where we import react we can
mark it with styles
and then we import global style
from dot forward slash
global style so this means that we're
importing this one that we created here
this cons that's called
global style we can import it because we
export it inside of this file
we don't do a default export as i'm
gonna show you when we create components
that's why we use curly brackets and
import this as a named import
and we're importing it from the file
that's called global style
you don't have to type out dot js it's
enough with just typing out global style
it will figure the file extension out
itself
all right so there we have our global
style component but how do we use it in
our application
we should place this at the top level of
our application
and as we're going to have a component
that wraps or complete the application
in this case it's the div
that's called app it has a class name of
app we're going to change this out later
when we have the routing setup but for
now that's a wrapping div
so inside of that one
we can use a global style and we
self-close it like this we don't have
any props to send into this one
and we're not setting any class name or
stuff like that so when you use a plain
component without class name and props
in react you do it like this
and this is very similar to an html tag
so we save the file go back to our
browser
the only thing we can see now is that
the morgan some padding have changed
here it's just right at the edges here
now and it wasn't that before
so we know that our global styles are
working
and we can actually just comment this
one out save the file
go back to our browser and you can see
that the margin
is there now that way we know that it's
working
and hopefully we didn't do any mistake
in the css itself
so it should work otherwise we have to
adjust that later
all right in the next video we're going
to start creating the header component
for the application
so we're going to create our first real
component in this application and it's
going to be the header component
so the first thing we do when we create
a new component is to create a file for
that component
and you can see that we have our src
folder here and we have an images folder
but we don't have a folder
that's going to hold our components i
usually create a folder that's called
components
that's what i'm going to do now
components
all lowercase letters and inside of this
folder we're going to create all of our
components
and the thing is that the structuring of
an application
is something that's highly subjective so
you can have your own opinions on how
you want to structure it and if you want
to structure it in a different way you
can of course do that
but please be aware that this course
will have this full
structure and you have to think about it
if you change stuff yourself
if you just want to focus on learning
react i highly recommend that you use
this folder structure
that i created for the course i also
gonna have a folder for each component
because i want to separate out my styles
and have the styles in a separate file
and have the component itself in a
separate file i've created this course
so you don't have to create the styles
if you want
so that's easier for me to handle it
that way by separating
the mouth so therefore i also think it's
nice to have everything related to
component
in its own folder so we're going to
create a new folder inside of the
components folder
that's called header capital h
so we inside a header folder and this is
something in visual studio code
it won't show a complete tree structure
here when you just have one folder
but this will change later but we're
inside a header folder
and inside a header folder i'm going to
create a new file
that's called index.js
and this is also something that's highly
subjective actually because i'm going to
create my component in the index.js file
so we're going to have one folder for
each component
and each folder is going to have an
index.js file
and this is great when you import stuff
as i'm going to show you later
but it's not that great if you for
example have 10 components open up here
they all going to be named index.js so
that's a downside
by doing it like this but this is a
fairly small application so i don't
think it matters
i can actually show this if we have a
component that's named
test component we import it like this
and from dot forward slash we have our
folder
that's called test component
like this of course we don't have this
one now this is just an example
it's exported as a default export so we
import
like test component without the curly
brackets we can name it to whatever we
want
but i like to name them just exactly as
they are in the files
and we import it from the test component
folder
and then if we have a file that's called
index.js we don't have to type out
anything more here
it will automatically grab that index.js
file but if we name this file
for example test component also we have
to specify it like this
have to type it out two times and i
don't like to have to type it in two
times
so that's why i'm using an index.js file
instead
as this is a fairly small application so
we don't get confused up here when we
have a lot of components open
so that's my explanation to why i'm
using this structure
and that's also why i name my files like
this
all right so delete this one here we're
also going to create placeholder
components for the styles
because we're going to use these style
components inside of this component
itself
so that's what we're going to do and we
do that by creating another file
that's called header.styles.js
and this is how i like to name my style
component files
so i have the component name and then i
have a dot and then i
mark it with styles and then i have a
dot on the file extension
all right so from the style components
we
import styled
like this import style from style
components
components it should be an s then i'm
just going to create placeholder
components because i am going to create
the styles in the next video
so if you have shoes to skip the styles
you don't have to do them
just as before you always have to export
these ones because they are in a
separate file and we are going to import
them
in the index.js file soon export const
i have a component that i like to name
wrapper
and it's going to be a style dot div so
this is a div that i'm going to style
and i just have the double ticks and i
end it there because this is just a
placeholder now
so we could just copy this one but as i
told you i want to repeat stuff and type
it in many times when you learn things
so we export const i have another
component that is going to be called
content
and it equals from the start we have
another div
double back ticks and end it
then we export const logo
imd and it equals a style and this is an
image it's the logo that we're gonna
style
double back ticks and end it and then we
export
const tmdb
logo imd be careful with the capital
letters here
this is the movie database logo so
capital tmdb
capital l and capital i
and from the style we're gonna style
another image
like this so this is the four style
components that we're going to use for
this
react component so save the file and i'm
going to show you in the next video
how to create the styles the actual css
but move
inside of the index.js we're going to
create our header component
now the first thing you do when you
create a react component is to import
react capital r from react
and that will make sure that we are
using react in this component
then i have some images for the logo so
if we look inside of the image folder i
have the
tmdb logo this is an svd so we just see
some code here
and then we also have the react movie
logo and that's also an svg so move back
to the index.js we're going to import
this once now
so import rmdb
logo you can name it to whatever you
want here but i choose to name it rmdb
logo you could just name it logo
of course if you want to do that but i
want to separate them out because we're
going to have the tmdb logo also
and we're going to import it from dot
dot forward slash
that's in the header folder then we want
to go up one more folder so dot dot
forward slash again
and then we have our images folder and
then we grab
the react dash movie dash logo dot
svg in this case it's really important
that you also type out the svg extension
otherwise it won't work when it's an
image
so that's the rmdb logo then we import
the tmdb logo from
dot dot forward slash dot dot forward
slash images
forward slash tmdb underscore logo
dot svg like this
and as you can see this can be a really
long file path here and that's no good
in some cases of course
you could set up this with create react
app so you use absolute import instead
but i choose to not do this in this
course as i want this to be
kind of beginner friendly and to be
honest we're not going to have that long
file path
so that's why okay so that's our logos
that's our images for the logos
then we're going to import the styles
that we created in header.styles.js
because we export them here as i told
you so we're going to import them in
this component
so import curly brackets we have a
wrapper
we have our content we have our logo imd
we have our tmdb logo
no logo img tmdb logo imd
and we're going to import these once
from
dot forward slash header dot styles
and we end it with a c my colon i'm
going to remove the sidebar here so we
can see what we're doing
that's it we have everything we need to
assemble this component for now
so we're going to create a component
that's named header and we're going to
use just functional components in our
application because
now you can have state in your
functional components
a couple of years ago you had to create
a class if you want to have some state
but now we have hooks and we can use
just functional components
so i like to create my components with
an arrow function
so const header equals parenthesis
and a fat arrow and that's an arrow
function you can have
a regular function if you want to have
that also and then of course you just do
it like this instead
function header and you have your curly
brackets
but i like to have the error function
and that's because you can make an
implicit return like this
if we're just returning jsx we can have
parentheses and you don't need to type
out return
and in our case we're going to have the
wrapper that's the style component that
we created
and inside of the wrapper we're gonna
have the content
that's also a style component that we
created
and then i'm gonna have the logo imd
and we can set the source on this one
because this is an image tag that we
styled so we can use the same attribute
the src is going to equal and we have
imported our rmdb logo
rmdb logo like this
we set an alt and we can name it
rmdb-logo
and then we can self-close it like this
so that's a logo for this application
then we have the movie database
logo tmdb logo
img we have the src
it's going to be the tmdb logo img
and we set the alt
to tmdb dash logo
and we self close it do some auto
formatting
and now you can see yeah
okay i just named it tmdb logo of course
that's
style component we shouldn't use that so
tmdb logo
of course and now you can see that it
complains here because we're not
exporting this one
it says it's never used and that's
because we don't export it
you should always export it and i like
to do the export here at the bottom
so export default header
and this is also es6 syntax for
exporting something so in this case we
don't have a named export
we export it as a default some people
like to have their export here
instead i don't like that so that's why
i have it at the bottom here
but you can do however you want and this
is
our header component for now but we're
not actually using it if we go back to
our application here you can see that
nothing has happened because we have
created a component
but we're not actually using it yet so
we have to do something about that
so let's go back to our app.js file
and inside of this div here the wrapping
div
this is also something that you have to
know because in react you can
always just return one component you
have to wrap the components if you have
multiple of them
in another component or in something
that's called a fragment
that i'm going to talk about later in
this course so inside of here we're
going to have our header component but
first we have to import it of course
so what i like to do i like to mark it
with components
like this and then i import header from
dot forward slash components forward
slash
header like this
when you want to use a component in
react you have to import it first like
this
this is a module that we import our
component is a model that we import with
es6 syntax like this
right and then we can use the component
here for now we don't have any props for
this one
so just as we did with the global style
we can insert the component here
down in the jsx and we have our header
so do some order formatting and save it
and if we go back to our browser
you can see that we can't really see the
images now and that's because we haven't
set the styling for the images now
so that's what we're going to do in the
next video or if you choose to not
create the styles
you probably will see the header up here
now if you're using the styles
that you copied over to your project
folder but in the next video we're going
to create the styles and that will make
the header show up
with the logos
we have created our header component but
we can't really see anything
so we have to create the styles for it
all so you can see it
yeah it looks like crap here so we have
to
give this some styling also so we see
the nice little logos and
our header so inside our file that's
called header.styles.js
we're going to start by creating the
wrapper style component
we're going to set a background on that
one background
and from our variables we're going to
grab the one that's called
dark gray like this
and then i'm gonna give it some padding
0 and 20 pixels and that will give it
some padding
on the sides save it go back to
our browser and now you can see that we
see our
gigantic logos here and our gigantic
header
so we have to do something about this
one also
so we have our content div
this one is going to be displayed as a
flex because i want to place the logos
on the left and the right and we can do
that with flex
so first we align items to center
and this will align them vertically
and then we justify the content and we
set it to space between
and this will create space between them
and push them to the side
one is going to be pushed to the right
and one is going to be pushed to the
left
and i'm also going to set the max width
of this one and that's why i also have
a container that's called content
because the wrapper is going to have
this background of dark gray
but i don't want the content itself to
have the full width
the max width is going to be from our
variable
dash dash max width like this
and i'm going to set some padding at the
top and bottom of 20 pixels
and zero on the sides and i set the
margin to zero
auro and this will center the content
div itself
save it go back and see what we've got
so far you can see
that they are pushed to the size and
that's great
flexbox is really neat to do stuff like
this
but the size isn't correct on the logo
so we have to modify this
so we have our logo imd
that's the main logo and that's a style
image we set the width
to 200 pixels on this one save it go
back to the application you can see that
we have the correct size here
but we also want to change this size on
the logo
when we are on smaller devices so we
create a media query
at media screen and
max dash with i don't really know if you
need to
actually use screen today i think it's
not necessary but i'm used to that so
i will do that i set the max width to
500 pixels
this means that when the screen size is
lesser than 500 pixels
this one will kick in so we set the
width to 150 pixels on that one
save it go back to our application and
see what we got
so i can make this smaller and you can
see that there
the logo gets smaller also so we know
that the media query is working
and this is also something that's super
great with start components because you
can nest the media queries as i did
inside of this component
i think this is very readable to do it
like this because you know that this
specific media query belongs to this
component
all right so that's the main logo then
we just have to style
the tmdb logo also so i'm going to set
the width
to 100 pixels on this one and then i set
the media query on this one also
at media screen and
max with 500 pixels
so it may seem redundant to have two of
them here but actually as i told you i
think this is very readable
if you want to change the media query
for just that component you can do that
inside
of the nested media query here and i
like that a lot
so for this one i'm going to set the
width to 80 pixels
and save it go back to the application
and there you have it this is our header
and you can see that it's working on
both of the logos
when we make the viewport smaller
sweet that's the styles for the header
in the next video we're going to
scaffold out
our homepage
all right we're going to start building
the home page for our nice little
application
and we're going to have all this stuff
here on our homepage the homepage is
going to be what's called a
container component and then we're going
to create different components for
example for the hero image for the
search bar
for the thumbnails for the grid and for
the load more button
let's go back to our code editor
and inside the components folder we
create a new file that we call
home
dot js capital h and this one i don't
have a folder for this one because
this is kind of more a container
component
so we don't have any styling in this one
we're going to apply the styling on the
individual components instead
all right so the first thing we always
do when we create a component in react
is to import react import react from
react then i'm going to create a little
comment here
and call it config because i'm going to
import some stuff from the file that's
called config.js
and inside of this file i've set
everything up for you
that's needed for the movie database api
and i export them here
in an object so we're going to import a
few things from this file
in the home component so go back to the
home.js
and we import curly brackets
we're going to import the poster
underscore size
all capital letters we're going to
import the backdrop
underscore size and the
image underscore base underscore url
i'll remove this sidebar here we're
going to import them from
dot forward slash config
like this and be very careful here with
the spelling
all capital letters and underscore all
right
then later we're going to import a lot
of components here
so for now i just mark it like this
we're also going to import a hook
so i mark that one also and we're also
going to import
an image so if we go back and look here
in the images folder i have this image
that's called no underscore image and
this one is a fallback image
if we don't get an image back from the
movie database api
so we have this funny little smiley
balloon here that we'll fall back to if
we don't have an image
so go back to the home.js and we import
i'm going to call it no image and when
you do an import like this you can call
it whatever you want
so it doesn't need to be named like this
i'm going to import from dot dot forward
slash
images and i grab the no underscore
image dot
jpg very important to have the file
extension when you're importing images
like this
all right then i'm going to create the
component itself
and as i told you i like to create it
with an arrow function you can have a
regular function if you want to do that
i have a const home i have a capital h
all react components always have a
capital first
letter very important always name your
components
with a capital first letter
so home capital h and then we don't have
any props for this one so i just
leave it empty here the parenthesis and
then i have an arrow function
and i have curly brackets because this
one is going to
have some logic inside of it so we have
to have a return statement
and make an explicit return so return
and for now we can just return a div
that says home page
like this all right
then we can also actually scaffold out
our states that we're going to have in
this component
and for that one we're going to need a
hook that's called
use state so make sure to import that
one up here you type in a coma and then
you have curly brackets
and we import use state from the react
library
and the use state hook is the hook that
you use in functional components in
react
to create a state so when we call the
use state hook we'll get an array back
the first value is going to be the state
value itself and the second value
is going to be the setter for the state
and the standard for grabbing and using
these values is to use the es6 syntax
for the structuring
so i create a const add the structure
out the state and the setter for the
state set state
and you can call it whatever you want
here but i want to call this state
you could call it cool like this but i
don't actually think it's that cool so
i'm going to stick with state
like this and then we have an equal sign
and we call the use statehook
for now we leave it empty but you could
provide it with an initial state
in here but we don't do that for now
so as you can see here i'm calling you
state and this one will give us an array
back so from that array i the structure
out the state and the center for the
state
otherwise we could do it like this but
you shouldn't do that
we have a const state
you stayed like this and this state
would be an array with the first value
date value here and then we have the the
setter
for the state as the second value and
then as we didn't destructure this one
out here we just put it in this const
that's called state
if we want to grab the state we have to
type it in like this
to use the index 0 because that's the
first value in the array and if we want
to set the state
we have to grab the setter like this
with the second value in the array that
is the index one
so that's no good actually it's much
better to do it like this instead we
just structure it out and we can also
name them
individually by doing it like this
all right so this is the way to go this
is the way you should do it
so that's the state wheel that will hold
all the movies
then we're going to have a state for the
loading so loading and
set loading equals use state and this
one i'm going to give an initial state
i'm going to set it to false
and this is also great with the use
state hook you can have as many of these
ones as you want so you can split the
state up into multiple ones
and you couldn't do that in the class
components in react because before we
had to use state hook we
needed to create a class to have state
in react
and then we just had one state and you
have to have a state object with all the
stuff in it but now we can separate them
out
into different states and that's super
great
so i'm going to create the third one
that i call error and set error
and this one is going to be used if we
receive an error from the api
we can have this as a flag and we set
this one to false
also right so that's the states
we have to do one more thing because we
have created this component and we also
have to export it
so export default home
like this see if we can get some order
formatting now it looks great
anyways all right save the file but if
we go back to our application you can
see that we don't see anything yet it
just says start here
that's because we have created a
component but we're not actually using
it
so in the app.js file
up here where we import the header we're
going to import
home from dot forward slash components
and home like that and then we can use
that component down here
so we remove start here and use our
component and we self-close it because
we're not sending in any props
so we just type out the name in a tag
like this
save the file go back to the application
and you can see that it says home page
and that's great we know that it's
working and you may
wonder why we have all these warnings
here but they are just warnings because
we're not
using these values now so they will
disappear later when we use them in the
component
so nothing to worry about there in the
next video i'm just going to do a short
talk on the standard
hooks that's indirect library and then
we'll move on and actually fetch some
data
from the movie database api
okay before we move on i just want to
make a brief talk about the
built-in hooks that's in the react
library we can also create our custom
hooks and we're going to do that in this
course also but we have some
hooks that's built in that you're
probably going to use most of the time
when you create react applications so
i'm on there
js.org and i'm in this chapter here
that's called hooks this is great if you
want to know more about hooks because
honestly hooks can be a little bit hard
to grasp in the beginning
so i highly recommend that you actually
read this
chapter here if you're completely new to
hooks and if you're new to react
this is a great way to start doing some
reading
before you do any course or create
anything with react it's always a good
idea to have some basic
theoretical knowledge before you start
with something but of course it depends
on how you like to learn stuff so i
shouldn't tell you how to do it
all right so they have an introduction
to hooks they have different chapters
here we're actually going to look at
this one number seven
hooks api reference and i'm going to
talk about the hooks that's
built in the library so they separated
in basic hooks and additional hooks
and the basic hooks are probably the
ones that you're going to use
not maybe 99 but perhaps 95
of the time and then you're going to
create some own custom hooks and use
some special hooks sometimes so we
already
talked a little about the used state
hook that's the one that you use for
creating state in a functional component
in react so that one we imported in the
last video and we initialized it
and set it up in the home component
we're also going to use a hook that's
called
use effect and use effect is a hook that
you can use for side effects
so in our case we're going to grab data
from an api and that's a side effect so
we're going to use the use effect hook
for grabbing that data
and we're going to use the state to keep
that data in our application
then you have a hook that's called use
context we're not going to use that hook
in the main part of this course
but i am going to use the use context
hook in the extra chapter at the end
where i create a movie database login in
the application
and make it possible for you to cast a
vote on the movies
then i'm going to set up a global state
that holds the login information of the
user
by using the use context so that's the
basic hooks
and then you have some additional hooks
use reducer that's something that's very
similar to
if you for example have used redux the
use reducer
is very similar to that one and it can
be used instead of the use state hook if
you want a more
i don't know if it's a more complex
state but yeah
yeah maybe a more complex state than the
use date we won't use it in this course
and you use callback and use memo hooks
or hooks that you can use to memorize
stuff
if you don't want to recreate for
example a function on each render
they very handy if you for example run
into something that's called an infinity
loop
with the use effect that's very common
actually in react that you can do that
because if you set the state in a use
effect that will trigger a re-render
and if you have a dependency in the use
effect for example a function
that recreates on each render that will
trigger that effect again
and that will set the state again and it
will trigger the effect again and yeah
you get the point here it will create an
infinity loop then you can use the use
callback
to wrap that function inside the use
callback hook
and that won't recreate the function on
each render because by default if you
create just a regular function
react will recreate that function on
each render
and the use effect if you specify that
one in
what in something that's called a
dependency array that we're going to
talk about
then that use effect will trigger again
because it will think it's a new
function
because that function has been recreated
on the next render
so use callback and use memo or hooks
you can use to memorize stuff in
react but i think there are a little bit
more advanced so i won't use them in
this course
the use ref hooked we're actually going
to use that one because i'm going to
show you a little trick in this
application and a
neat little use case to use this one use
ref is basically a hook you can use to
create a mutable value that won't
trigger a re-render you can see it just
maybe like a
kind of a regular variable that won't
trigger or re-render
so we can use this one to create a
mutable value because if we have it in a
state it will always trigger a re-render
when we change that value but if we
change the value with the use ref hook
it won't trigger a re-render use
imperative handle i've never used this
one so i actually don't know what is for
use layout effect it's very similar to
use effect they only differ in
when they trigger so there's no use case
for the use layout effect in this
course so i won't go into detail and use
debug value i haven't used this one
either
these are the built-in hooks in react
but i think the strength about hook is
that you actually can create custom
hooks
and we're going to do that in this
course also that was a brief
introduction to hooks in react
so in the next video we're going to
fetch some data from the movie database
api
we're going to use the use effect hook
and the use state hook for that
all right let the fun begin because now
we're actually gonna fetch some data
from the movie database api
and that's super exciting because it's
always great when you
see the magic happens when you have that
nice little
json object with all the data that we
fetched from an
external source i like that i love it
all right so we're going to be in the
home.js file
for this one now then later we're going
to kind of break this one out and
place it in its own custom hook but for
now we're going to be in the home
component
and create it inside of here so we're
already importing
use state but we're also going to import
use
effect because we're going to use this
one for fetching the data
then i have this file here that's called
api.js and inside of this file i created
all the functions for fetching data from
the api
and i will also say that this will
probably one of the most
advanced videos in this course and also
one of the longest
so you can care a little extra about
this video because it's
a kind of advanced stuff in this one all
right in this file api.js i have this
object here where i export a couple of
functions
the three first ones are the ones that
we actually need to care about the other
ones
is for the bonus material for this
course so you don't have to care about
that
now so this one is the one that we're
going to use now
fetch movies and this will fetch a lot
of movies multiple movies then i have
this
fetch movie without the s and this one
will fetch
an individual movie and then i have
fetch credits and that's the credits for
the movie itself so these ones are going
to be used for the individual movie page
and if we take a quick look at these
fetch movies here you can see that
this one has the parameters of search
term and page so we're going to give it
the search term and the page that we
want fetch
and i have a ternary operator here
that's es6 syntax
for kind of a shortcut for if and else
so i do a check here i check if i have a
search term and then i have a question
mark
and if this one is true if i have a
search term it will run this one to the
right of the question mark
and if this one is false i have a colon
here
it will run this one to the right of the
colon it's a shorthand for if and else
and i have to do this because we have
different resources from the endpoint
depending on if we're doing a search
or if we're grabbing the most popular
movies so that's why i have this turner
operator here
so if we're in the search we're going to
use this resource from the endpoint here
and also attach the search term
and then we also grab the correct page
so we add this as a parameter to the url
and then i return on the wait and i
actually weight this two times and
that's because i first await the fetch
from the endpoint
and then i await when i actually convert
it with json because this one is also
async so that's why i have two awaits
and as i have an await i have marked
this one with an async so i'm using the
async await syntax for this one you
could also use the good old
then but i think that's not as readable
i actually
like this a lot more so that's why i'm
using the async await
syntax for this one all right and i
think that's it for this file
we don't have to care about this because
we're going to import this function
so go back to home.js and just below
here
i'm also going to remove the sidebar i
mark it with api
and then i import api from dot forward
slash
api and this will give us this object
where we can access those functions i
talked about
all right so that's the api then down in
the actual component here
just above the return statement we can
create the new function that we're going
to call the
fetch movies
and as we're fetching from the api and
we're going to use a weight
we have to mark this with async
and then it's going to have two
parameters it's going to have the page
and the search term
and we can set the default value on the
search term to an empty
string like this then i have an arrow
and i have curly brackets so we create
this function here it's an async
function because we're going to fetch
from the api and await that data
this one is going to get the page we can
send in what page we want to grab
and then we can also send in the search
term we haven't actually created this
one yet because this one is going to be
another state
when we create the search bar so we're
going to add in more states here later
and also have a state for a search term
and if we don't send
in a search term we're going to fall
back to an empty string
so we set this one as default so that's
the fetch movies function
we're going to wrap this in a try
and catch block try and catch
and we can get the error in this case
i'm not actually going to set the error
i'm just going to have a flag that's
setting if it's true or false
but of course you can have a state where
you can store the message from there or
also if you want to do that
so in the catch we're just going to have
set error and we set it to true
and here you can see how i use this
setter for this state so we destructure
it out here and to set a new state for
that one
we call this one and we give it the
value so i call
set error and i give it the value true
and this will change that state to true
inside our try block we're first going
to set the error to false
because now we're grabbing new data so
we have to make sure that this one
isn't set to true because we don't have
an error before we have fetched anything
and we're going to set the loading to
true because now we're fetching so we
set this flag to true
and this is how we can keep track on
when we're actually fetching and we can
show the loading spinner and stuff like
that
all right then i create a cons that i
call movies and this const is going to
hold all the movies
so i'm going to wait and from the api
that we imported up here
we have that function that i showed you
that's called
fetch movies with an s really important
and then we're going to give it the
search term and the page
so this will hopefully grab the movies
for us and we can try this out with
console.log
movies but if we go back to our
application you can see that we don't
actually get anything here because we
haven't triggered this function
and we have to do that in a use effect
so we have the function now but we
haven't triggered it do some order
formatting
and go below the function here and we
call the use effect
and the use effect is called with an
inline function like this
and then we can do what we want inside
of this use effect
so what we want now is to trigger this
only on mount only when we mount
this home component on the initial run
of this one
so we can do this by specifying a coma
here
and an empty array this is what's called
a dependency array
for the use effect and we can specify
different dependencies
on when we want this use effect to
trigger in our case we just want it
for now to trigger when we start up the
application
and when the home component mounts so i
specify this as an
empty array for now and when we specify
it as an
empty array it will just run once so
that's
really neat in this case we can just
call fetch movies
we're going to send in one because we
want to fetch the first
page we can also mark this one actually
with
initial render
so we have specified an empty dependency
array meaning that it will only run
once on the initial render and inside
the use effect we call our fetch movies
function
and hopefully we will get the console
log of all the movies if we save this
one and go back to our browser and yes
you can see here we have the movie
object here
so in this object we have the page one
and this is all from the movie database
api so it's nothing that we have set up
here
we have a total pages of 500 total
results of 10 000
and we have the actual movies in a
property that's called results and this
is an array
and we get 20 movies at a time from the
api
so that's sweet we know that we're
grabbing data and we know that it just
triggers once
and that's super great so now
when we have the data here we can
actually set our state because we have
our state up here and we want to put our
movies in the state
so i'm going to call set state
and for this one i'm going to provide it
with an inline function
it's a callback function that's going to
be called with the previous state
by the state setter if you provide a
state setter
with a function it's going to be called
with the previous state
and that's great because we need a
previous state when we set the state
and i'm going to show you why in a
second so we have a parameter that i
call
prev you can call it whatever you want
in the state
we want to set an object so we want to
return an object
so i have a parenthesis and curly
brackets if we didn't have the
parenthesis it would think that these
curly brackets
marks the scope of the function itself
and that's no good
we want to return an object and an
object also is marked
with the curly brackets so we have this
parenthesis before and this parenthesis
after
and this will make sure that we return
an object
and this parenthesis here is for the
setter of course so we have two
parentheses here at the end
so i have this little neat little plugin
also in visual studio code where you can
see i get these different
colors of the parenthesis so it's really
easy to see the parenthesis
i think it's called rainbow brackets
that plug-in
so we're going to set the state we have
the movies inside of this const
so i'm going to use the es6 syntax
that's called spread
i use three dots and spread the movies
and this is because i'm going to take
this object here and spread it out here
that means that we're creating a new
object it's going to take all the
properties from these movies
and spread them out inside of this
object here when you set the state in
react you should always provide it with
a new value
you should never mutate the state in
react because if you mutate the state
directly
it won't trigger a re-render and there
can be a lot of trouble
you should always use a cell like this
to modify the state
and you should always provide it with a
new value and not
mutate the state really really important
never mutate the state in react okay
so we have the movies and then if you
remember we have this property here
that's called results
so this is holding all the movies but in
our case
we need to decide on how this new stage
should look because
if we load more movies we want to append
the new movies to the old state
to the old movies and not wipe them out
so we have to do some check here for
that on the results so we have the
results property
colon and then i'm gonna put it on a new
row
i'm gonna check if the page is greater
than one
then i have a question mark this is a
turner operator here again
i'm gonna return a new array i spread
out
from the previous state prev that's the
one here
as i told you this one is getting called
with the previous state
so from the previous state i spread out
the old
results three dots prev dot results
with an s at the end all right so that's
the old movies that we already have in
the state
then i have a coma and i'm going to
attach the new movies so from the new
movies
dot dot dot movies dot results
and this one is going to append the new
movies to this array
so we get an array with the old movies
and the new movies and that's great
then we have a colon because if we're
not loading more we can wipe out the old
movies and just give it the new movies
that we got in this const called movies
so
dot dot dot movies dot
results like this do some order
formatting
and this will hopefully work we don't
know if it works because we haven't
created a load more button yet so we'll
see that later in the course
and there's one more thing we have to do
because we're setting the loading to
true here
and we have to set it to false when we
have grabbed all the movies so just
below
the try and catch block here at the end
of this function
we're going to set loading the false
like this save the file go back to see
that it works
reload it and yes it works and that's
super great but
we're console logging it out here we
don't know if it works with the state so
we remove this console.log
and go down here somewhere just above
the return statement and we can
console.log
out the state instead save the file
and we hope for the best go back to the
browser and yes you can see we have the
state here
and you may wonder why is it showing
this many times and that's because
if we look in the home component we have
three different states here
so it will re-render each time we change
one of these states
and some may say and go crazy oh we have
a lot of rerenders that's crazy
it will make this application so slow
but yeah you shouldn't worry about that
actually because
react will diff those things and only
update things in the dom that has
changed
so it doesn't matter if it re-rendered
this many times
and to be honest react is fast so even
if you had a lot of rear enders
you won't have any performance issue in
an application of this scale
don't worry it's completely okay that it
re-renders all these times
because it won't re-render the complete
page it will only re-render the stuff
that has changed
all right that's how you fetch data from
the movie database api with a use effect
hooked and then you put it in the state
with the used state hook in the next
video we're going to
take all this logic here and create our
own custom hook and place that data
inside of there
and then we can get rid of this one in
the home component so it will look a lot
cleaner
okay we're grabbing data from the movie
database api with a use effect hook and
we place it in the state
with the use state hook we're going to
move all this logic inside of a custom
hook instead because that will make this
component a lot cleaner and it's always
great to separate
out this logic if we want to reuse it
somewhere else in the application
in our case we don't need to do that so
we do it just because we want to clean
up this component
and to separate out this logic so that's
why you create custom hooks
either you do it because you want to
reuse some logic somewhere in your
application
or you want to clean it out and have
that separated out
so inside of the src folder not in the
components folder this time
inside of the src folder create a new
folder
that's called hooks and inside of that
folder create a new file that's called
use home fetch camel casing
dot js capital h capital f
and why do i name it like this well
react
wants you to name all your custom hooks
with use
and then your name that way react knows
that this is a custom hook
you could skip to use use but you
shouldn't do that you should always
name them with use before the name
always do it like that
otherwise it can give you trouble in the
future
so inside of this file i'm going to
create a new function
i'm going to export it also because
we're going to import this one in our
home component and use this custom hook
export const
use home fetch and i create
a regular arrow function like this
all right so that's our function then we
go back to our home component inside of
the components folder
and we're going to grab all this logic
here all the states
the fetch movies function and the use
effect we can keep the console log for
now
it's going to give us an error but
that's okay we're going to fix that soon
go back to the use home fetch custom
hook paste
the logic in here and it complains now
because we haven't imported these ones
here
so we could actually just copy them from
the home component but just as before i
want us to
type in stuff a lot here because we're
learning stuff
so we're going to import from the react
library we're going to need
the use state so import curly brackets
use state coma use effect
and we're also going to use a hook
that's called use ref later so we can
import that one also
and we import it from react
and you can see that i don't import
react in this one because we not
need the actual react library we just
need this stuff from that library
so that's why we don't have any jsx or
anything here so that's why we don't
need to import react itself
we also need to import the api and that
one we can actually just
copy this one from the home so go back
to the home
cut this one out here the import api
like this go back to the use home fetch
hooked
and paste it in here and this one should
be it
all right do some order formatting and
we only have this function now we're not
actually returning something
so we have to return something in our
custom hook also so go down to the
bottom of the function
and there we're going to return our
states for now we're going to return
more stuff in this one later when we
create more stuff but now we return
an object and we have the state
we have the loading and the error like
this
and this is also es6 syntax as we return
this object
this one is automatically going to get
the property stayed
because it has the same name and all of
these ones has the same name so we don't
have to specify them
explicitly it will figure this out
itself
all right there's one more thing i want
to do inside of this one before we
finished for this video and that is i
want to create
an initial state so up here i create a
const
initial state it's always a great idea
to have an initial state if you want to
reset stuff
and we want to do that later so i'm
going to structure this state
just as the one that we got back from
the movie database api
so we have the page it's gonna be zero
initially
then we have the results that's the
property that holds all the movies
are gonna provide it with an empty array
initially
we have the total underscore pages
is going to be zero and the total
underscore results it's going to be zero
also
so this is the initial state and now we
can give this initial state to the used
state here where we create a state
so i provide it with initial state and
this will make sure that it gets this
state
all right so that's our custom hook for
now we go back to the home component
and now we have to use this custom hook
i already created this comment here
where we're going to import it
so we import curly brackets use
movie fetch like this
from dot dot forward slash hooks
and use home fetch then inside our sad
little empty home component
we're going to use this one and yet
again i'm going to use es6 the structure
syntax
to get those properties from the object
that we exported here
we export an object with all these
values here
so i'm going to structure them out here
curly brackets
stayed loading and error
equal sign and i call my custom hook use
moviefetch
so this will hopefully work we're
console logging out the state so we save
this file make sure that you also save
the hook itself and go back to the
browser
reload it yeah i have some error here
use movie fetch is not
exported didn't i export it export const
yeah it should be used home fetch of
course not
use movie fetch
so i change this one to use home fetch
use home fetch like this save the file
go back to the browser
and you can see that we have or stayed
here and that's great you can see
there's a lot of rerenders and a lot of
people will say
oh crazy there's too many rirenders this
is a performance issue
but it's actually not so this is totally
fine but you can see that
we have our initial state here first and
it's zero everything is zeroed out
and then we get the data here and we
have all the movies inside here
so that's sweet and i promise you it
won't be any performance issue in this
application
because of these rerenders so this is
how you create a custom hook in react
always name your custom hooks with use
before you have your name
that's really important you should
always name them like this
in the next video we're going to start
creating the components for the home
page and we're going to start with a
hero image
in this video we're going to create this
hero image here in the application
so we're going to grab a background
image and all the text here from the
movie database api
or actually we have already grabbed them
so we're going to use that data
inside of the hero image component let's
go back to our
code editor and inside the components
folder create a new folder
that we call hero image
capital h capital i and inside a hero
image
folder create a new file that we call
index.js
and also file that we call
hero image dot styles
dot js just as before i'm just going to
scale out the styles so we can use them
in the component but i'm going to create
the actual styles in the next video
instead
so if you already have this file here
and choose to not create the styling for
this course
you already have this file here and
don't need to do this so in the hero
image.styles.js
import styled from style components
like this then i'm going to export a
const that i call wrapper
and it's going to equal from style.div
i'm going to create a div
i have backticks like this
then i'm going to export const
content equals styled.div
exactly the same and double backticks
and i'm going to have one that's called
export
construct text equals styled
dot div
double back ticks and that's it
that's three of them save this file and
go inside the index.js file
we import react from react
then we're going to import the styles so
i mark it with styles
import wrapper
content and text
from dot forward slash hero image styles
right then i create the component itself
const hero image capital letters h
and i equals and this one is actually
going to receive some props
and a prop is something that you can
send into component
so that component can change dynamically
depending on the props
a prop should never be changed inside a
component
that receives the props so they can only
change
if something re-renders and they get a
new prop so that's how that works
and the props is sent into component on
a prop
object like this so we have the prop i
have an arrow function and for this one
i'm just going to return jsx so i can
make an implicit return
so i have parenthesis so i can skip the
return statement
and then i have my wrapper and this is a
style component
we scaffold it out just recently this
one can also receive a prop
so when you're sending a prop to
component you do it by naming the prop
and then you give it the value in this
case it's going to be
from the prop that this component get
prop
there's going to be a prop that's called
image so we send it along to this style
component
that's named wrapper and in the next
video i'm going to show you
how we can set the background image in
this component
by sending in the image url to the style
component that's named wrapper
so that's what i'm doing here so i'm
sending this url along
to the style component on a prop that's
called image
inside this wrapper we're gonna have the
content
and inside the content we're gonna have
the text
like this and inside the text we're
gonna have a regular h1 tag
and in jsx when you want to use a
javascript expression
you create curly brackets and then you
type in your expression in our case we
want to show the title
and this hero image is going to receive
the title from the prop
that's called title like this and you
end it with a curly bracket
you can have any javascript expression
inside of here that you want
so you can do some calculations and map
through stuff and things like that that
we're going to do later also
i'm going to show you that then we have
a p
tag and yet again i have curly brackets
i have the text and and curly brackets
and that one is from the prop dot text
do some order formatting
and then i export default
hero image and this looks fine actually
but i want to show you
a little trick here now that you should
use when you create your components
because now we have to type out prop dot
image prop dot title prop dot text
so instead you can use es6 syntax up
here and the structure out
these props from the prop object
so we have parentheses and then we have
curly brackets
so we are destruction out this object
and then we have the image
title and the text and then we can
remove
prop here on all of these
so i think you should get used to always
doing it like this because it will look
a lot more cleaner
with the structural mode up here so we
don't have to type in prop every time
all right save the component and just as
usual we can't see anything
now if we go back to our application
because we haven't used the component
yet
save it go back to home and up here
where i marked it with components we
import
hero image from dot forward slash
hero image and now we can use this
component
so below here instead of home page and
this div
we can just return the hero image like
this
but we want to send along some props to
this one also
because this one needs the title and
stuff like that
and we also need to check that we
actually have any movies in the state
so we can't actually do it like this
because it will throw an error if we
don't have any movies
in that array so what we can do here
instead it
we return something here inside of the
parenthesis because we're going to need
multiple rows
so we move this one inside of here
instead
and as i told you before we can only
return one parent element
in jsx so we have to wrap this once
because we're gonna have more components
here later
so we can create something that's called
a fragment in react we could of course
create a div like this and move this one
inside but sometimes we don't actually
want to create a div
we just want to return this without
creating a div and you can do that by
creating a fragment
and this is the shorthand for fragments
you just create these angle brackets
and an end angle bracket and this will
work
so inside of here we also want to check
if we actually have some result in the
state
so just as before as i did in the hero
image itself
in the you can see here in the jsx where
i have a javascript expression i can do
the same in the home
so go back to the home i have a curly
bracket and now i can use
any javascript expression that i want so
i want to check
if state results
the hero image is going to be the first
movie it's going to be the most popular
movie
so i grab the first element in the array
i check if that one exists
and then i do something that's called a
short circuit
so i have double ampersands and i'm
going to
move this curly bracket to the end or
here
because i want this one to be nested
inside of this one
so this means that if this one is true
it will run this code here if it's false
it will just fall back
and sometimes some argue that you
shouldn't do it like this because it
will return
the actual value false here but jsx
won't show it
but if you want you could instead do a
ternary operator like this
so if this one is true we return the
hero image and then we have colon
otherwise we return null
we can put it on its own row and this
will also work
and we want to give this hero image some
props
so we have a prop of image and that one
is going to equal
and this one i have to construct because
the image url is constructed by
the image base url that we we that we
get here
and also the backdrop size so i have
backticks
dollar sign curly brackets i'm going to
grab the image
base url like this and this one is going
to be long so i'm going to remove the
sidebar
so this is a template literal and you
can interpolate expressions like this in
a string literal
all right then i'm going to add the
backdrop size
like this and then i'm going to add you
can see i have
dollar sign and curly brackets for all
of them here dollar sign and curly
brackets again
from the state dot results
i grab the first element again and then
we have something that's called backdrop
underscore path be very careful about
the spelling here so you get that
correctly it's really really easy
to make a typo here and then it won't
work this will get us the image url
and these ones are all set up in this
file here that's called config
they are set up as per instructions from
the movie database api
you can see the image base url is this
url here
so that's the one and then i set the
backdrop size you can change this size
if you want and try it here
you can make them smaller and you can
set them to the original size
i set them to width 1280 in this case
so that's what i'm grabbing here and i'm
generating this string here
by merging them together in this
template literal here
all right then we have the title
and we get that one from state.results
the first element and we have a property
that's called original
underscore title like this
and then we have the text yet again from
state
results from the first element you could
also break this out in its own variable
if you don't want to type this in every
time so there's probably a lot of things
you can optimize in this application
but as this is a beginner slash
intermediate course i don't want to
do a lot of stuff like this because it
will only take time
and it will be confusing with all the
other stuff going on so we have a
property here that's called overview
and these are of course all from the
movie database api it's nothing that i
have created
these are named like this from the movie
database api
all right do some order formatting so
you can see here i send in three props
image title and text and these are the
ones that i
destruction out in this component itself
so when you want to give a prop
to a component you do it like this you
name the prop and then you give it the
value
and then you can grab those props inside
of this component
so save the file go back to the browser
and you can see
that we can't see anything yet but if i
mark it here you can see that we have
the text
but we don't actually have set any
styling for this one yet so that's what
we're going to do in the next video
and then we'll hopefully see this nice
little hero image
in our application
it's time to create the styles for the
hero component so move back inside of
the code editor
and the file that's called
heroimage.styles.js that we created in
the last video
so we have all these components here and
just give it some space here
and we're going to start with a wrapper
and to the wrapper we send in a prop
if you remember this one here you can
see we have this image prop here so just
as
we do with regular component we can send
in props to a style component
and this is something that is super
great with style components because this
way
we can do some stuff with a css and in
our case we're going to set a background
image
the usual way you did that back in the
days was that you had to create some
inline css
when you had a dynamic image and you
didn't know from the beginning where it
came from
or what what its name was you had to set
it with an inline styling on the element
itself in the html
but in this case we can do it much much
cleaner and send in
a prop to this component and we set the
image here and also we're going to
create if you look here at the finished
application
i don't know if you see it now but
there's a slight little gradient down
here also
because i want this text to be able to
be seen on
any different background that's why i
have a dark little gradient
below this text here so that's what
we're also going to create
so in the wrap component we have this
div that we're styling here with style
components
so we have the background and we're
going to set a linear gradient
first linear gradient
parenthesis
and it's going to go to bottom
rgba and i use this because i want to
set the alpha value
0 0 0 0 and these values are
order generated from somewhere on the
internet
i i usually do that when i create
gradients it's so easy
to just go there and type in your
gradient and it will give you the code
so that's why
all these values may seem a little bit
odd this one is 39
and the rgba is going to be 0 0
0 0 again and 41
rgba 0
0 0 and 0.65 that's the alpha value and
i see now that this one
shouldn't even need to have two of these
ones here
i think actually i can remove this one
here we don't need that one
and then we set hundred percent and just
after the parenthesis the end
parenthesis we have a comma
and then we specify the url and now we
can grab that prop that we send in here
and you do that as this is a template
literal
just as before we use dollar sign
encoded brackets
and we can grab those props you create
an inline function and this one
will get called with the props and from
the props we grab the image and if you
wanted to structure them out you can do
that also here
then you have a parenthesis and then you
hold the object
and then we just structure out the image
and we do it like this
right and then we have a coma and
from the variable we grab dark gray
and hopefully this will work do some
order formatting and save it go back to
the browser and you can see that we
actually have the image here but we
haven't set any other properties so
that's why
it will look like this so let's go back
here
and we're going to set the background
size
100 and cover we're going to set the
background
position
the center
the height is going to be 6 600 pixels
position is going to be relative because
we're going to absolute position
our text so that's why we have to set
this to relative and i'm also going to
have a slight animation on this one
so i set an animation that i'm going to
call animate
hero image and it's going to be for one
second
if we look at the finished here you can
see that
it kind of fades up so that's the
animation that i'm going to create
and i do that below here i nest it
inside of here so at
keyframes and the name is animate hero
image
and i go from opacity
it's going to be zero to
opacity is gonna be one
save it go back and see what we've got
and there you have it there's some
little
border up here i don't know why let's
see if we sort itself
out when i create the other styles
but you can see that it it
animates in here quite smoothly so
that's great
all right let's fix the other components
so we have the content
padding is going to be 20 pixels on that
one we set a max width
and we grab from our variable the max
width
and morgan it's going to be zero and
auto
save it let's check it out you can see
that it's
in the center now that's great
and that one remove that nasty little
border up there also
that's sweet
then we have the text
let's create that one also
i set the set index to 100 just to place
it on top
i set the max width to 700 pixels on
this text
position is going to be absolute
from bottom i'm going to set it to 40
pixels and morgan
right is going to be 20 pixels
the min height is going to be 100 pixels
and the color is going to be from the
variables
we have the white
all right so that's our text and inside
we have the h1 tag
so for that one i set the font size and
from our variables
we have fonts
big camel casing
and then i'm going to have a media query
on this one media screen
and max of course i have to end this
with a c my colon
max width 720 pixels
and i set the font size to variable
dash dash font big so i'm making it
slightly
smaller
right that's the h1 then we have the p
tag it's gonna have a font size
from the variables we grab font med
that's the medium size and then we have
a media query
media screen and we set the max width
720 pixels
and for that one the font size
is going to be variable font small
so this means of course that up until
720 pixels
we will use the font small otherwise it
will use the font medium
and the same goes here we use the font
big
up until 720 pixels otherwise we use the
font
super big all right then we're going to
have a media query
on the text itself so media screen
and max with
720 pixels and we set the max width
to 100 percent and there may be
room for optimization in the css because
i haven't
put the most focus in the css for this
course
as this is a course in react but i
wanted to show you how to create the css
also so that's why i included it but
there are
room for optimization i'm sure of that
go back and see what we've got and it
seems to be working
let's see what happens yeah you can see
it gets smaller
and that's great
and now it's actually starting to get
fun because now we see different stuff
happening here
things are displaying on the screen and
that's what i like with front-end
development to actually see it put
together like this
all right in the next video we're going
to create the logic for the grid
component
so we have our hero component and the
next component would be
the actual search bar but i'm going to
say that one for later so we're going to
create this grid now instead
in this video so let's start by creating
a logic
just as usual and in the next video we
create the styles
go back to the code editor and inside
the components create a new folder
that's called grid
and inside the grid create a new file
that's called index.js
and another file that's called
grid.styles.js
and capital g on the grid of course and
just as before
we're going to be in the grid.styles.js
first to create the placeholders for the
start components so import styled from
style components then we export the
const that we call
wrapper and as you can see here this is
great with star components because i
named them the same
but it doesn't matter they will be
scoped to that component
so we can have this exact same name
that's super sweet
so the styles won't interfere with each
other so
star dot div double back ticks
and then we export const content
and that equals the styled.div also
and double backticks save it
and go inside of the index.js file
so we import react from react
hopefully you're starting to learn is
now so this will be in your muscle
memory
later then we have the styles
we import the wrapper
and the content from dot forward slash
grid styles then we create a component
itself
const grid equals and i'm gonna
destructure our two props that we're
gonna send into this one
so header and children
i have an arrow function and i'm gonna
do an implicit return
and you may wonder what children is and
that is a default prop that we can use
in react
when we nest stuff inside a component
they will be accessible
in the children prop so that's great i'm
going to show you how that works in a
second
we're going to have a wrapper
then we have an h1 tag and then i have
curly brackets because i'm going to grab
the header prop
and display that here then we have the
content
and for that one i create another curly
bracket
and i grab the children so that means
that whatever i
wrap inside of this component when i use
it i can display it here
by displaying the children then we need
to export default
grid like this
and save it so this is pretty much it
for the grid component
if we go back to the home.js file
we can import it up here import grid
from dot forward slash grid
and then just below here below the hero
image
i'm going to use the grid here and this
one is going to get one prop
it's the header equals popular movies
so inside the grid i'm going to map
through all of the movies in the state
so i have curly brackets and state dot
results
i map that's also es6 syntax
we have a movie in this inline function
i can make an implicit return so i have
parenthesis
and i use a lot of es6 syntax here as
you can see and hopefully you know a bit
about it before you
start this course because it will be too
long of a course if i explain every
little syntax in detail but i try to
explain some stuff for you
and hopefully you'll learn a lot also
from it
but the map method is something you can
use instead of a for loop so you use the
map on the array the results array and
it will map through each item in the
array
we haven't created a thumbnail yet so
i'm going to create a div
and i think we have a property
that's called title so i map through
every movie and now i'm just going to
show a div in the grid that shows us the
movie title
auto format it save it go back to the
application
and you can see that we have all the
movies here so it's displaying the title
and you can see that it also warns us
now each child in a list
should have a unique key prop and that's
when we map through things we have to
mark it with a key also otherwise react
will complain
react is using this internally to diff
stuff and to
optimize itself so we can set a key
on this one and we're going to give it
the movie
dot id so this is a unique id that we
get from the movie database api
it sometimes return two of the same
movie and this one will actually give a
warning done
so it's some bug in the api i think
because it should only return one
of each movie so if it gives you a
warning it's
it's probably that because it has
probably returned more than one
of the same movie so you could actually
add something else here you could add a
random number
also to the movie id if you have that
problem so let's go back to the
application and you can see that it
doesn't complain now so now it's happy
we have provided a unique key and that's
super great and we have the titles
but it looks like crap now because we
haven't styled it and we haven't created
the
thumbnails yet in the next video we're
going to style the grid itself and then
we're going to create the thumbnails
so we have our grid but we have to style
it also and that's what we're going to
do
in this video move back to the code
editor and in the file that's called
grid.styles.js
in the grid folder we have already
created this once here so we're just
going to fill them up with
css and also i can tell you if you don't
have that plugin installed in visual
studio code
i have a plugin that's called vs code
dash style dash
components so that's the one that
creates this nice syntax highlighting
inside of these
style components so that's a little tip
if you haven't installed that one
all right so let's create the styles for
the wrapper first we're going to set the
max width
from our variable that's called max
width
then we set the margin to zero auto that
will center the div
and we give it some padding 0 and 20
pixels that's padding on the sides
and then we have the h1 tag i'm going to
set the color
from the variable mid gray on that one
and then also i'm going to have a media
query
so at media screen
and max dash with
768 pixels
and this one is going to change the font
size
from the variable font big
all right save it go back to the browser
and you can see that we have these nice
margins here but we haven't actually
created a grid yet so that's what we're
going to do
next inside the content component
we're going to display as a grid
then we set something that's called grid
template columns
grid dash template dash columns
we're going to set this one to repeat
and this is a little trick you can use
if you want to create a responsive grid
so we repeat these columns
we set it to autofill a coma
and then we use the min max
200 pixels that's the minimum width that
those
little thumbnails can have
and then we set it to one fragment so we
don't specify an exact pixel
width on the max value
and this is css grid syntax and the css
grid
would probably require a complete course
on its own
so i'm not going to go there
grid gap we're going to set that one to
2 rm so that will give it some spacing
between the rows and the columns
save it go back to the browser and you
can see that we have our grid
so now it's showing us five items on
each row
if we do like this you can see that it
it is responsive and that's super great
that's a neat trick you can use if you
have a grid like this
just with one row in css grid you can
make it fully responsive
so that is really really cool actually
and it works because we set this one to
repeat the columns
and we set it to order fill and then we
set the min
and max value so we're telling it when
it's 200 pixels wide
it can't go lower so then it removes one
column instead
and it's going to do that all the way
down to the mobile devices
all right that's the styling for the
grid it was pretty fast i think
in the next video we're going to start
creating the thumbnails
we have the grid now but we haven't
created the thumbnails for the movies so
that's what we're going to do next
move back inside of the code editor and
inside the components folder create a
new folder that you call
thumb capital t and inside of that
folder you create a new file that's
called index.js
and then you create another file that's
called thumb.styles.js
i hope you're beginning to see the
pattern here on how i structure the
components
so first we're going to start in the
thumb.styles.js just as before
so we import style from styled
components
and for this one we're only going to
have one component so export const
image capital i and this one is going to
be styled.imd
because we're styling the image here
all right save it
and go back to the index.js file
for the thumb so first we import react
from react then we mark it with styles
and import
image from dot forward slash thumb
styles
we're gonna import some more stuff here
later because these thumbnails are gonna
be clickable
we're gonna create that later when we
have set up the routing and also started
to create our movie page
so for now we create our thumb component
const thumb equals i'm going to
structure out
an image prop a movie id
and clickable i make an implicit return
on this one because i'm only going to
return jsx
for this one i'm going to have a
wrapping div like this
and then we're going to use this prop to
tell if it's clickable or not and then
we're going to have a turner operator
here but for
now we're just going to return an image
so that's the image that we created here
the source is going to be from the image
prop
and we can set an alt
movie thump on that one
we self close it and then down below
here we export default
thumb save the file then we're going to
go back to the home component and also
import this one
so up here import thumb from
dot forward slash thumb
all right and below here where we map
through
all of the movies we're gonna use our
thumb instead of this div
so remove this one here and we use the
thumb
then we're going to have a key for this
one also because we always need to have
a key
when we are mapping through components
like this and display them
so the key is going to be just as before
the movie dot id
we're going to set it to clickable
that's going to be true it's always
defaulted true so you don't have to do
this
if you want to set it to true for now
that one isn't working because we
didn't utilize it in the component
itself but we're going to fix that later
then we have the image prop
and we're going to give it the url to
the image and for this one we're also
going to use that fallback image if we
don't have an image
for the movie so we're going to have a
turner operator here
movie dot poster underscore path so
we're checking if we have a poster path
if we don't have that we're going to
display the fallback image but if we
have this path
we know that we can grab that image so
we have a question mark
i'm typing it on another row here but
it's a regular toner operator
then we have the image base url and i'm
actually going to show you the other way
now
and not do it like this here you can do
it the old way with plus
instead we have the poster size and then
we have the movie
dot poster path
movie dot poster underscore path be very
careful with the spelling
it's very easy to make a little typo
here and that will break everything
all right so that is when we have a
poster path then we have the colon
and we're going to display the no image
if we don't have a poster path
so that's the image then we're going to
send in the movie id
and that is because when we click on a
thumbnail we need to have the movie id
for that thumbnail so we
know what movie to grab and display on
the individual movie page
so movie dot id and then we're gonna
close
the thumb component so be very careful
here it's a little bit
nested and and it's very easy to type
something wrong here
but this should be right i think i
really hope so so i save it
go back to the browser and as you can
see we have the thumbnail
but it doesn't look right and that's
because i haven't styled them yet
but at least we're displaying something
so in the next video we're going to
style the thumbnails
so to make it look something like this
instead
really pretty and modern i hope
okay we soon have a grid with nice
little thumbnails
we just have to style the thumb
component itself so inside the
thumbnail.styles.js we already created
this one
we're going to style it inside of the
image style component
so we're going to set the width to 100
percent
the max width is going to be 720 pixels
transition all
0.3 seconds and that is because i want
some nice transition
on hover object dash
fit is going to be cover
border dash radius it's going to be 20
pixels and the cover here will center
the image
and make it fit nicely into the
thumbnail so that's a really
handy little row you can use in css for
stuff like that
i also gonna have an animation on this
one because i want it to fade up
we can actually look at that in the
finished application you know you can
see here that
these thumbnails are also fading up just
as the hero image
that's what i want that animation for
so i call it animate thumb
0.5 seconds
so i'm going to create that animation so
add keyframes
and animate thumb
right from
i set the opacity to zero
to it's gonna be
opacity one that's the animation
and then i also want to set the hover
effect so colon
hover like this
and i set the opacity to 0.8
do some order formatting and save it go
back to the application
and as you can see it's looking great
so that's nice it's working it's
starting to look like something
we can compare it to this one here and
it looks exactly the same without the
search bar
so we have a few things left to do we
have to create the spinner also when
we're loading and the search bar
and the button for loading more in the
next video we're actually going to
create the spinner component so we have
that
ready when we want to show it when we're
fetching more
okay we have our hero image and our grid
so we're going to create the spinner in
this video
back inside of the code editor and the
components folder
and inside a components folder create a
new folder that we call spinner
and then we create a file that's called
index.js
and another file that's called
spinner.styles.js
it's beginning to be a little bit
repetitive here but as i said
so many times before now it's always
great to repeat stuff when you learn it
so even if it's boring it's better to
repeat it because then it will be in
your muscle memory later
so that's why i repeat a lot of stuff
also in this course
and this one is a little bit special
actually because we have the component
itself in the index.js file but the
component
is really just going to be a style
component so in this index.js file
we're just going to import the style
component in this file so we can create
this
actually in this video and then we
import it and then it will be finished
so in the spinner.styles.js file we
import styled from style components
we export a const that we named spinner
and it equals styled.div
double backticks and inside the
backticks we write our css we set the
border to five pixels solid
and we have the variable of light gray
we set the border dash top
to five pixels solid with a variable
dash dash matte gray
we set the border dash radius
to 50 because this one is going to be a
circle
so that's why the width is going to be
50 pixels and the height is also going
to be 50 pixels
we have an animation on this one also we
call it spin
0.8 seconds it's going to be a linear
animation and it's going to be infinite
now we set the morgan to 20 pixels auto
right then we create an animation add
keyframes
spin we go from zero percent
transform we rotate it
zero degree here i'm using percent
instead so you can use whatever you want
we didn't do that
in the thumb styles i'm using from two
in that one instead
so i like to change stuff a little bit
when i create courses like this so that
you see that you can create it
in many different ways so here i'm using
percent instead
and you should say transform not
transfor transform
and rotate zero degrees end it with a c
my colon and then we go to 100
and the transform is going to be rotate
360 degrees
do some order formatting and save it
then we go back to the index.js file in
the spinner folder
and for this one we just import the
spinner that we created as a style
component
so from dot forward slash spinner dot
styles
and then we export it export default
spinner
so that's it for this component we can
actually see if it works also so go back
to the home page
home.js we import it first here
import spinner from dot forward slash
spinner all right and then here just
below
the grid
we can place the spinner and also here
we don't actually
need to use state and the use effect
here more so we can
delete those ones also save the file
go back to the browser and as you can
see just below here
it's spinning like crazy and of course
it's only going to be shown when we
fetch data from the api
but for now we're showing it all the
time but we're going to fix that later
so that's how you create a really simple
spinner with some css and style
components in react
in the next video we're going to start
creating the search bar
so we created a grid with our thumbs and
we have our hero image and we want to
create our search bar
next if we look at the search bar in the
finished application we can see that we
have this
nice little icon here i created this
myself first i had
an icon from font awesome but then i
thought
maybe shouldn't import the whole font
awesome library just to have one icon
so that's why i created an svg image
instead and then it says search movie
and then we can type in something to
search for
in here so this is how it works so let's
go back to our code
and inside the components folder create
a new folder that's called
search bar capital s
capital b and inside of that folder you
probably guessed it we create a file
that's called
index.js and a file that's called
searchbar.styles.js
and we do as we always do we're going to
be in the searchbar.styles.js and we're
going to scaffold out
the star components import styled
from style components
then we export the const called wrapper
and it's going to equal a styled.div
and we have double back ticks and we
export
not triple back ticks double back ticks
and i see my colon
then we export the cons that's called
content
it's gonna equal styled
dot div double back ticks and i see my
colon
save it go back to the index.js in the
search bar folder
we import react coma we're also going to
import a few other stuff here
we're going to need a used state
we're going to need a use effect
and we're also going to need to use ref
for this one
now we import it from react
so why do i need these things well the
state we're going to use to create
what's called a control component
and that means that we're going to have
our input field but it's going to be
controlled by react
the input field is going to be based on
the value in the state
we're going to use the use effect to
trigger when this local state changes
and then we're going to update the
search term
so that it will fetch new movies from
the api and the use riff is going to be
used
to show you a little trick that we can
use if we don't want to do something
in the use effect on the initial render
so then we're going to import the image
that's going to be that little
icon i showed you so import search icon
camel casing from dot dot forward slash
dot dot forward slash again images
and we have something that's called
search dash icon dot
svg don't miss the file extension here
and then we have the styles
the import
curly brackets wrapper and content
from dot forward slash search bar dot
styles
all right so that's our imports
and then we create a component const
search bar capital s
capital b equals and we're gonna
destructure out the prop that's going to
be
set search term camel cased
like an error and then for this one
we're going to make an
explicit return because we want to have
some logic in it
so we have a return statement
parenthesis
then we have a wrapper
and inside the wrapper we're going to
have our content
like this so the first thing we need is
the icon and it's going to be an image
so image src is going to be the search
icon
we can set an alt on that one also
search dash icon we self-close it
like this just a regular img
tag then we're going to have an input
field
and it's going to be of type text
we're going to have a placeholder
it's going to be search movie and then
we're going to have an
unchanged handler and a value but for
now i'm just gonna self-close this
i'm gonna do some order formatting and
export this component
export default search bar
and then we're gonna import it in the
home component just to see that we got
something here
so go back to the home i can close all
this
go back to the home and just below the
hero image
we're going to place that component but
first we need to import it so import
search bar from dot forward slash
search bar right go down
below the hero image just above the grid
we can place our search bar save it go
back to the browser
and you can see that we have our input
field here but we haven't styled it yet
of course
so hopefully it's going to look
something like this when we're finished
so go back to the code and the search
bar in the index.js
file we're going to make this what's
called a controlled component
a control component in react is a
component that react control
so the input value is going to be based
on a state that we create
and when that state changes it also
changes the value in the input box
and this is great because then we know
that our state is in sync
with the actual value in the input field
we create a state up here const we can
call it state
and set state
equals use date and it's going to be an
empty string
for starters
on our input field
ah it order formatted them like this i
want to have them like this instead
we're gonna have an on change handler
equals
and for this one i'm going to create an
inline function you could also create a
function up here
for that one if you want to do that
instead but i want to show you how to do
things differently so in this case i
create an inline function
we have the event or you can just type
in e for example you can name it
whatever you want then we set the state
with the event dot current target dot
value and this will give us the value in
the input field
and we need to have this inline function
as we are actually
invoking this function here with that
value otherwise it won't work
so by having this inline function we can
provide this one with the value so
that's why we have this inline function
otherwise it will run this function
instantly and that's no good
so if we for example had a function that
we didn't want to send in some
arguments to that we just want to
trigger on change we can have it like
this instead
and that will work but in this case we
want to send in the argument of the
current value
so that's why we have this inline
function
all right so that's the unchanged and
then we set the value
to the state and there we have
successfully created a control component
we can see if it works go back to the
browser
type something in and you can see the
value here now is controlled by react
as soon as we set this value to some
state value here
we are making this a control component
and every time it
changes it's going to trigger the set
state and it gets the value here
and we place the value from the text
input in the state
and then the value is displayed in the
text box itself so it's kind of a
closed circle here on how things work it
goes
around in this way now we have our input
field but we want something to happen
also we want
to set the search term that we're going
to create in our hook
that we created before so we're actually
going to create
a new state inside or use home fetch
so up here in the use home fetch hook
we're going to create a const
call it search term capital t and set
search term then it's going to equal
use state and we set it as an empty
string
initially then we also need to export
this one
to export it down here and we only need
a setter for this one so we can export
the set search term
like this save the file go back to the
home dot js
and up here where we where we use our
use home fetch hooked
we can destructure out the set search
search
term the set search term all right
and this one is going to be the prop for
our search bar
so i'm going to call this prop set
search term also
you can call it whatever you want and
then i give it a set search term so this
way we pass this along down to our
component
the search bar so that we can use it in
the search bar so when this one triggers
when we set the search term it's going
to trigger here
so it's actually changing the state in
our hook here
that's exactly what we want because then
we can use it in our hook when we fetch
stuff
but in this case we want to have a
slight delay when the user
types something in before it tries to
fetch the data we can look here in the
finished application
you can see when i type something in
here that i
have a slight delay otherwise it
wouldn't be a good user experience
if it just instantly started to fetch
data so that's why i do it this way
instead otherwise we could have used
this state
to actually fetch the data but in our
case we want a slight delay
and then we set the search term that
we're going to use for fetching so
that's why i have
dual states for this one so let's create
a use effect in the search bar
use effect we have an inline arrow
function just as before
and we have the dependency array and
we're going to fill that out in a second
and i'm going to show you how to create
a timeout in react now and you can how
you can use it in a use effect
so first we create a timer we use the
set
timeout that's built in javascript
we have an inline function for that one
and then we're going to call the set
search term that's the one that we
created
and we're going to give it the state
like this
and i'm going to set it to half a second
that's 500 milliseconds so this one
will trigger after 500 milliseconds if
you want some other value you can of
course type that in instead
and you can see here now that it
instantly complains because we haven't
specified this as a dependency
so we specified search term
as a dependency and it also complains
because it needs the state that's also
dependency to this use effect
so these linting rules are actually
really good it tells us stuff so that it
is so that we actually do this correctly
and we should always specify the
dependencies and handle it inside of the
use effect if we need to
all right but there's one more important
thing we have to do with the timer and
that is to clear that timer
on each render because otherwise it will
just create a lot of timers and that's
no good
and there's a handy little thing with
the use effect that we can use for this
because if we return a function in the
use effect
so every time before a new render it
will trigger this function
so we can clear our timeout inside of
that function
and this will take care of that we clean
up this timer so we don't have a lot of
timers that just
ticks in the background and you can
imagine you have a lot of stuff that you
want to do maybe to clean up stuff
so you can always do that in a return
function with the use effect
this one doesn't trigger until this
render has finished and it's going to
render again
so that is sweet we can save this one
and we can actually go back to the use
home fetch
and up here we can console.log
the search term so we can see that
something is happening
so go back to the application again
yeah i have a typo somewhere maybe i
didn't save the home
save go back to the browser yeah and now
it works you can see
it's really important to save your files
because it will break otherwise
be sure to save all the files so if i
type in test
and you can see here after 500
millisecond it will trigger
so that's sweet we know that that is
working and we can use this to fetch
data from the api
but there are one more thing i want to
do and i promised you to show you a
little trick with the use ref
and that is because the use effect
always trigger on the initial render and
we don't want to trigger a fetch
when this component mounts we only want
it to trigger when the user has typed
something in
so that's why i'm going to create a
const that's called initial
up here and i'm going to use ref
and i set it to true
so when we call the use ref hook this
one will
create a mutable value for us that you
can compare to something similar
as a mutable variable so we have this
initial const and the actual value is
going to be in the initial dot current
that property will hold the value true
right now
so i set this to true and inside the use
effect i'm going to check if
initial dot current that's going to be
the true value
right now if it is true in it it should
say
initial like this right
then i instantly going to set the
initial dot current
the false and you can see here i can
mutate this variable
directly i don't have to have a seller
for this one because this one
won't trigger a re-render that's the
biggest difference from a state
that when you use ref it won't trigger a
re-render
and then if this one is true we know
that this is the initial render and then
i just return
we don't do anything more inside of the
use effect and we set this to false so
next time this one triggers this one is
going to be false and it's going to run
our logic
so this is how you can create a neat
little code snippet here
to to skip the initial render in the use
effect
save the file just make sure that it
works
yeah and it seems to be working
we've learned how to create a control
component in react
and the component controls the input
field with the state so the input field
always has the same value as the state
and that's a control component our state
is synced with the input field and then
we created a timer that will trigger
each half a second and call this set
search term
to set the stay there and the state is
going to be the value from the input
field
and we also pass this one along from the
use home fetch
so that's how you pass data down to your
components that's what props are for you
can pass data down to your component
and we can use it in that component and
that means that we also have this value
in our use home fetch hook to use the
fetch data later
so i can remove this console.log for now
save the file
and this will be it actually for the
search bar in the next video we're going
to style the search bar and then we're
going to create the logic for fetching
the data
we have created our search input field
but it doesn't look good so we have to
style it also
and that's what we're going to do now so
in our search bar dot styles file we're
going to create the wrapper first
and i'm going to display it as a flex
i'm going to align the items to sender
not aligned a line
i set the height to 100 pixels
the background is going to be from the
variables
we have the dark gray
and i'm going to give it some padding on
the sides 0 and 20 pixels
do some more formatting save it go back
to the browser
and you can see that we have the search
bar here and now we have to style
kind of the inner part of the search bar
and we do that in the content
inside the content i'm going to set the
position to relative because we want to
place
the icon with an absolute position
the max width is going to be from the
variables
we have our max width
the width is going to be 100 the height
is going to be 55 pixels the background
is going to be from the variables mad
gray
the margin is gonna be zero and auto
and the border dash radius is gonna be
40 pixels and the color
from the variables we have our white
save it go back and see what we've got
so far so we have this
inner part now of the of the search bar
so we have the style icon and the search
bar input field itself
so inside the content we're going to
nest some stuff here we have our icon
that's the imd
i set the position to absolute
and this is why i used relative up here
otherwise it won't work
so it needs to be relative to the actual
content div
it's going to be left 15 pixels
top 14 pixels and with it's going to be
30 pixels
save it go back and now it seems to
align correctly and it also has the
correct size
great then we have the input field
itself
so down below the imd type in input
we set the font size to 28 pixels
in this one position
[Music]
is going to be absolute left
is zero margin is eight pixels
and zero padding is gonna be zero zero
zero and sixty pixels
the border is zero the width is going to
be ninety five percent
the background is going to be
transparent
the height is going to be 40 pixels
and the color is from the variables and
it's going to be white
so go back to the browser and you can
see that it works now but we have this
nasty little outline you shouldn't
remove the outlines
actually but in this case i think it's
fair to do it because it doesn't look
good
so i'm going to remove them so inside
the input i'm going to nest
focus and i'm going to remove the
outline
i set it to none and hopefully that
will remove it yeah you can see that
it's removed now
one thing you can do also if you want is
to style
this for mobile devices maybe make it a
little bit
less insane font size and stuff like
that
if you want to really fine tune it here
but it seems to be working now
all right and that's it for the search
bar that's the styles for the search bar
in the next video we're actually going
to hook this up to the api and fetch
some data
we have created our search functionality
and our search bar
but we can't really search for anything
yet
so if we type something in we just get
this console log here
so we're going to implement the actual
functionality where we fetch the search
data from the api
let's go back inside of the code editor
and we're going to be in the use home
fetch hook and down here where we say
initial render
we're going to change this one to
initial
and search like this because we're going
to use this use effect both for the
initial render and the search
and it's actually pretty easy because
now we just have this empty dependency
array
meaning that we only trigger this use
effect once on mount
but we also want to trigger this one
each time the user search for something
and up here we have our search term and
in this one we're going to store what
the user typed in in the search bar
and that means that we want to trigger
the use effect when the search term
changes
down here in the dependency array we
specify search term
meaning that this use effect will
trigger each time the search term
changes
and it will also trigger one time on
mount so we can actually use this one
for the initial fetching also
because when we search for something we
always want to fetch the first page
just as we do on the initial mount so
that's fine we're fetching the page one
but we also want to provide the search
term and that's also fine for the
initial fetching because the search term
is going to be an empty string so we
know that we're fetching the most
popular movies because we're not
specifying any search term
there's one more thing though that we
have to do and that is to wipe out the
old state before we make
a new search because we want to wipe it
out and then make a search
show the loading spinner and then show
the new movies that we grabbed from the
search so we can set
state to the initial state here and that
will wipe out the state
and that's really all there is to it so
we save this file
go back to our application we try to
search for something
and you can see that it works now this
one changes because this one will always
grab
the first element in the array of movies
and that's fine actually you can have it
like this if you want
but i want to remove this hero image
when we're in a search so we can do that
also
so go back to our code and then inside
of the home
tortillas down below here where we show
the hero image
we can also specify that we don't want
to show this one if we have a search
term so not search term
double ampersand so now we're checking
that we don't have a search term
and also that we actually have a first
element in the array of movies
but you can see that it runs here now
and that's because we haven't exported
this one from our hooked
so go back to the hooked and down below
here
we can export this one also search term
like this save the hook go back to the
dot js and up here where we just
structure out everything from the hooked
we can also just structure out the
search term like this
save the file go back to our application
we tried to search
again and now you can see that it
disappears
this is exactly what i want if you want
to keep the hero image you don't have to
do this
and then it reappears when we don't have
anything in the search bar
all right there's one small thing that i
also want to do
and that is in the home.js and if we
look down below here where we have the
grid
i'm going to create a turner operator
now because now it says popular movies
even when we're in a search
so this one i'm going to create a curly
bracket and also
curly bracket here at the end
and then i check if i have a search term
i have a question mark
and if we have a search term i create a
string i want it to say
search result and if we're not in a
search
it's going to say popular movies so if
we have a search term
it's going to return what's to the right
of the question mark and that search
result
otherwise it's going to return popular
movies save the file
go back to the application this time i'm
going to search for
indiana jones and now you can see that
the
header on the grid changes so that's
great it says search results
and i remove this and it says popular
movies so that's our search we have
implemented all the logic for the search
bar
and in the next video we're going to
start creating the load more button
okay let's start creating our button
that will go at the bottom here
and this spinner will not show all the
time it will only show when we're
loading stuff
back in the code and inside the
components create a new folder that's
called
button capital b and you guessed it we
create a new file that's called index.js
and we create another file that's called
baron.styles.js and we're going to be in
that file
an import styled bomb
style components and for this one we're
only going to have one star component so
we export const
and it's going to be a wrapper equals a
style
dot button in this case and double back
takes
auto format it and save it and then we
go back to the index.js file
and we're going to create our button so
we import react
from react then we have our styles
so we import the wrapper that we created
wrapper
from dot forward slash button dot styles
all right then we have our component
const
button then i just structure out two
props one is called text and one is
called callback
and i create an error and i make an
implicit return on this one
so i'm gonna have the wrapper it's gonna
be type
baron and it's gonna have an on click
handler and it's going to be the
callback that we send in as a prop
and then i'm going to display the text
inside of the button
so this is a button that we created as a
style component and call it wrapper
and it's going to trigger a callback
function when the user clicks on the
button and then we show the text
we can send in what text we want to this
button if we want to reuse it
then we export default
button save it then we go back inside of
the home component
and at the top we're going to import
button from dot forward slash
button and then
at the end of our jsx we're going to
show the bottom
and we have to think about this because
we don't want to show the bottom if we
reach
the last page of movies so we have to
take that one into consideration so just
below the spinner here
i'm going to use a curly bracket and
create a javascript expression
we're going to check from the state dot
page
if that one is less than state dot total
underscore pages we know that we're
still not on the last page
and i have a double ampersand and make a
short circuit here
i also gonna check so that with not
loading anything so if not
loading and then i have another pair of
ampersands
and i have a parenthesis i put it on a
new road just to make it a little bit
more readable
and then i'm gonna show my bottom so the
text
is gonna be load more and for now i'm
not giving it the callback
so this is it for now so this statement
will check if the page we're currently
on
is less than the total pages and then we
know that we still want to show the load
more button
and it will also check that we're not
loading anything because when we're
loading something we want to show the
spinner instead
and we have the spinner here we can
actually create another statement here
to create a curly bracket and type in
loading
and double ampersand and we end it with
another curly bracket like this
so this will show the spinner if the
loading is set to true
and if it's set to false it will not
display the spinner
but then it will display the button
instead if we go back to the application
we can see the button down below here
in the corner but it doesn't look right
we have to start it also to look like
this here
and that's what we're going to do in the
next video
we have our ugly little button here down
at the corner so it's time to style it
go back to the code and inside the
button.styles.js file and we have the
wrapper here
we're going to give it some nice little
style here we start by displaying it as
a blocked
display block we set the background
from our variables we have the dark gray
we set the width to 25
the min width is going to be 200 pixels
the height is going to be 60 pixels
the border dash radius is going to be
30 pixels and the color is from the
variables
the dash dash white the border
is going to be set to zero the font size
is going to be from the variables font
big
margin is going to be 20 pixels and auto
the transition it's going to be all
0.3 seconds i'm lazy here i can set it
just on
that property that i want to have a
transition but i set it to all
outline is going to be none
and the cursor
is going to be pointer then i want a
little hover effect also so hover
i set the opacity to 0.8
that's why i had this transition here
also i just want to check also
the font sizes here
want big maybe we can use this one
instead
on the styles for the search bar because
i think i have
yeah i have the font size
of 28 pixels we can use the variable
instead
variable font big and see how it looks
yeah i think that looks nice actually we
can use that one instead
but let's check out the button yeah you
can see it works
it looks great now we only have to
create the logic for the button now so
we
so that we actually can load more movies
so that's what we're going to do in the
next
video this is actually the last video
for the home page
so we're going to create the fetching
logic for loading more movies
and we're going to start in the use home
fetch hook that we have in our hooks
folder
and we're going to start by creating a
new state so this is going to work in a
way that we have a state with a kind of
a flag that we set the true or false
and we set that one to true when we
click on the button
and then we're going to trigger a use
effect because as i said before i think
this is
great practice with the use effect hook
and also the state hooks
so you could do this in other ways also
but
this is a quite neat way of doing it we
have this
state that we set the true or false and
when it changes we trigger that use
effect and then we can trigger to load
more movies
we first create a state const is loading
more camel casing as always
and then we have the setter set is
loading
more it's going to equal and we call the
use state hooked we set it to false
initially and this one is going to be
triggered from the button itself so we
have to export it down here also
so after the set search term we can
export set is
loading more so there you have it i
removed the sidebar so we can see the
complete row here
now we're exporting six of those so
that's our state so we can go back to
the home.js file
and here we have our button but we first
need to destructure out
the set is loading more set is loading
more
there's some order formatting and it
will clean it up for us a little bit
so we just structure out that one also
and that means that we can use it in
this component
and one thing that we also didn't do is
to actually check if we have an error so
we can do that
before the return statement here if
error
we can return a div
that says something went wrong
like that and that will make sure that
if we get an arrow we won't display
everything here we will display this
error message instead so you can
create a more sophisticated stuff here
if you want to do that
in our case i think it's enough for this
course
all right so let's move on to this set
is loading more so we have our button
down below here
and we already created a callback prop
so we give it the callback prop
curly brackets and this one is going to
have an inline arrow function
because i want to call this one with an
argument the set is
loading more
yeah i'm going to remove the sidebar set
is slowing more and we're going to set
it to true
like this so this will change this state
when we click the button
and if we check out the application we
won't actually be able to see anything
now
you can see that it re-renders when we
click the button because it console logs
this out so we know that it's working
and one great thing to know that is that
if i click a few more times here you can
see that it don't re-render anymore and
that is because
we're giving it the same value so react
won't update the state if it gets the
same value
so it's good to know that with react if
you give it the same state value it
won't re-render it
so react is kind of smart it already
knows that it has
the same value so it won't do anything a
quick
little pro tip in react all right
so we know that the button is working so
we move back to the use home
fetch hook and we're going to create
another use effect down here
below the search use effect i'm going to
mark it with
load more so just as before i create
another use effect
an inline arrow function and we have the
dependency array
and we want this to trigger
when the is load more is changing so
it's load
loading more like this
and the thing is that we only want this
use effector trigger
when we actually is loading more so if
not is loading more if this one is false
we're just going to return we don't want
to do anything else in this use effect
this one should only do something when
we load more movies
and what we want to do now is to call
our fetch movies function again
in this time we want to give it the
state dot page
plus one because we want to load the
next page and we also give it a search
term if
we're in a search and now you can see
that it warns us here
because it wants a few other
dependencies it tells us that we need to
specify the search term and the state
dot page
that's what we're going to do the search
term
and the state dot page and now it will
be happy at us
and that is because these ones are
outside of the use effect
so we should always specify dependencies
in the dependency array
and we should handle them inside of the
use effect hook if there's something we
don't want to do when something change
we should account for that inside of
this use effect
so we're fetching movies and then we set
is loading more
to false do some auto formatting
and save it and hopefully this should
work
so we have the use effect that triggers
when we change the is loading more
boolean if we're not loading more we
will just return
we don't do anything else in this effect
otherwise we call the fetch movies
function
and we give it the next page that we
want to fetch and we also give it a
search term
and then we set its loading more to
force again so that we go back
to what it was before and then we can do
it all over again if we want to click
the load more button again
save it and go back to the browser and
see if this works
we click the load more and as you can
see it works and i
love when stuff just works and you can
see that our loading spinner is show
showing up also it's
fast so we can't hardly see it but it's
there
so it's working and we can also see in
the console here we are at page 11 and
we have 220 results now
so that's great we know that loadmore is
working we can also try it out so that
it works when we search for something
and it does so that's sweet i'm happy
with this
hope you like it too you can see also
that those images some of them has
some strange proportions so if you want
you can tweak the css to take that
into account also in the next video
we're going to start creating our routes
for the application
we're going to start creating the
routing for our application and before
we do that i just want to talk
shortly about react router and
especially the version 6 that we're
using
it's not officially released when i
record this tutorial so hopefully it's
released now
when you watch this tutorial because it
is as they say here it's around the
corner and
i actually talked to this guy michael
jackson here on twitter
and he said that i should use this
version in my course because
it's that stable now and it's not going
to change that much and we're not going
to use all the advanced functionality
in the router itself so that's why we
installed
the next version of react router when we
install the dependencies for this
application
and there are a few changes in it if you
compare it to
version 5 and i actually don't want to
talk about version 5 because that will
soon be deprecated
so i just wanted to mention why i choose
to use the version 6 of the react router
because this is the future version and
it has the api that is going to be used
for a long time hopefully in the future
so that's why i use it in this tutorial
i want to make sure that this tutorial
uses the latest stuff
so that you know that you're up to date
on the things that you learn
so that's why so just a few
words here you can compare for example
they brag here with a react router
version 5 that the bundle size is 28.4
kilobytes minified
and the version 6 is only going to be
8.5 kilobytes minified
so if you care a lot about size on your
packages this one is drastically
smaller than the version 5. and then
they also show you some stuff here
on how you use the router but that's
what i'm going to show you in the next
video
but if you want to read more about this
one here you can go to reacttraining.com
forward slash blog forward slash react
dash router
version 6 dash pre forward slash
and then you can read more about it or
just google react router version 6 and
you will probably find
a lot of information about it if you
want to read more about
it so let's get started we're going to
create the routing in the next video
we have finished the home page and we
have our application here and
we have this nice little grid with all
the movies but we can't actually click
on them
to view a movie and we can't click on
the logo up here so we have to fix that
and we're going to do that by creating
some routes for our application
so the first thing we're going to do is
if we go back to the code
we're going to create two more
components so inside the components
folder we're going to create a new file
that's called
not found.js and also another file
that's called
movie.js capital m on movie and capital
n
and capital f are not found so we're
just going to scaffold these ones out so
we have something to route to
if we're in the movie.js file we import
react
from react then i create a component
that i call
movie and it's going to be an arrow
function and i'm just going to return a
div
that says movie
and then i export default movie
do some order formatting and save it
always save your files
all right then i copy this one
and i go inside of the not found file
that we just created
i paste it in and i change this one
i'm gonna change them in one go not
found
like this and save it and there you have
it we have two components to play with
and this one the movie.js is going to be
the individual movie component for
showing the movie so we're going to be
working a lot in this component
later this one is going to be as it is
i'm not going to create a fancy not
found component
so you can do some stuff on your own in
this one if you want to do that
so we scaffold our two components and
then we can move inside the app.js file
that you find in the src folder not in
the components folder so app.js
and the first thing we have to do is to
actually import all the components we
need from the router library from react
router
we can mark it here with routing if we
want to do that
then we import we have curly brackets
we're going to import something that's
called browser
router capital b capital r
and this name is a little bit long so if
you want to rename this module
you can do that by typing s and router
so we import it as
router i think i'm going to remove this
sidebar also
all right so that's the first one we
import browser router but we import it
as
router so we can use it with the name
router instead
then we import another component that's
called routes
and then we import another component
that's called route
very similar names here so be careful
when you import these ones
and we import them from something that's
called
react dash router so be very careful
here we're not importing it from
just react dash router we're importing
it from react
router dom so this one is using
react router in the background but this
one is specifically created
for using in the dom all right so that's
all the imports that we're going to do
so let's create our components down
below here
and i'm actually going to change this
one to an implicit return so i delete
the return
and the curly bracket
and i want to create an arrow function
instead const
app equals because it's only with arrow
functions you can do an implicit return
and i remove the curly bracket there
do some water formatting to me it looks
a little bit cleaner
and this div is going to be replaced
this repetitive that has a class name of
app
gonna be replaced with the router
so we wrap our complete application with
the router so it's really important
where you want to put your routes you
should wrap it with the router
and that is the browser router that we
imported here but we renamed it to
router
so that's why i use it as router here
then the header is going to be shown on
both the home page and the individual
movie page
so the header is going to be left out of
the route so i leave that one here and
then i use the routes component
and inside of the routes component we
can create our routes
and the first route we're gonna use the
component that's called
route so we have three different
components here from the router library
router gonna wrap or complete the
application in this case
and then we have routes that's gonna
wrap our routes because you can have
routes
in different components if you want to
do that so let's say that you have a
component
deep down in your app tree and then you
want to create some routes for just that
component
you can wrap them in this route
component and then you create your
routes
so you don't need to have them here in
the top of your application
and then you use the route component to
actually create your route
and this route component has a prop
that's called path
so we can specify the path where we want
to show a specific component and in this
case it's a forward slash because it's
the home page
and then we have another prop that's
called element it's going to equal
and here we can give it our component
and we want to give it the home
component
like this and then we also have to
self-close the route component
that means that we can remove this home
component here
so that's the first road if we want we
can save this to see that it still works
go back to the application reload it and
you can see that it works
so that's nice then we're going to
create another route
so we use the route component again we
set the path
and this one is going to be forward
slash and then
we're going to do something special here
because when we're going to fetch
an individual movie we need the movie id
and we can send along route params for
that
and we create a route param for the
route by specifying a colon and then we
name it
so movie id so this means when we create
a link on the thumbnails that we're
going to do
soon we can send along the id for the
movie and that id
we can grab that in our movie component
and grab data from the api
and you can name this to whatever you
want because this is a route param that
you decide what you want it to be named
so i want it to be named movie id
and then we specify the element on this
one and we give it
the movie component and we also close
the route component we haven't actually
import the movie components we can do
that
import movie from dot forward slash
components movie
and then we can also import not found
from dot forward slash components and
not found there you have it
so that's the route for the individual
movie we save it
and we can't actually click on the
thumbnails now because we haven't
created that one but what we can do is
go
up here create a forward slash and then
we type in some id
and you can see that it types out movie
here now and that is because it's
showing the movie component so we know
that it's working
so that's sweet and then if we remove
this one we'll show the homepage instead
all right we're going to create one last
route and that is for our not
found component so we create a route
with a path of
forward slash and an asterisk and this
will make sure that we show the not
found component on
any other route that don't exist and we
set the element
to the not found component
and we also self-close this route save
it go back to the application
we know that it works if we specify an
id
like this it shows the movie component
but what happens if we create another
route here
like this yeah then it shows that not
found and that's super sweet because
then we have a fallback component
if the user tries to go somewhere else
in our application
so that's the route setup in our app.js
file then if we move inside of our
header component
and the index.js file we're going to
create a link on the logo
up here we have to import curly brackets
and the component is called link from
react-router-dom
and this is actually quite simple it
works the similar way as the a-tag does
in html so we have a link component
we specified two and in this case it's
gonna lead to the home page so we have a
forward slash
and inside the link component we just
put our
logo like this so we wrap it inside of
the link component and this will make
sure
that we can link to the home page so go
back to the browser
for now we specify an id
so we're in the movie component and then
we click on this logo
and we go back to the home page so
really easy to make links with react
router
you can also make them programmatically
but we're not going to do that in this
course because it's kind of a little bit
more advanced and we don't really need
it
in this application but we have to add a
link to the thumbnail also so that we
know that we can click
on a thumbnail and that will lead to a
specific movie
so inside the thumb component the
index.js file
we'll do the same thing up here we
import curly brackets
link from react-router-dom
and we have this prop here that's called
clickable because we are going to use
this thumbnail
for the movie poster on each individual
page also
and that means that we won't be able to
click that one so we have to have this
boolean to check
if we should be able to click the
thumbnail or not
and the way i solve this is to create a
ternary operators
so here just below the div we check if
clickable is true
it's enough to type in clickable then we
have the question mark
and i have parentheses and i'm going to
use my link component and it's going to
link
to and in this case we want to use the
movie id because as i talked about
before
we are going to send along this id in
the route and we can grab it
later in the movie id param that we
create here
so we have backticks
i create a template literal here so i
have forward slash
then i have dollar sign curly brackets
and i'm going to give it the movie id
and this will give it a link
with a forward slash and the movie id
close the link component
and then we have our image and in this
case i'm going to copy this one
and paste it in so this is if the
thumbnail should be
clickable then in the turner operator be
very careful here it should be after
this parenthesis
i create a colon and then i create a new
pair of parentheses
and i move this image inside of that one
and i also have to end the turning
operator with a curly bracket
and then i do some order formatting
so what did i do here well i create a
turner operator
checking if the clickable is true and
then i show the link component
with the image wrapped inside it and
that means that we'll be able to click
on this thumbnail otherwise that's
what's right of the colon here i just
show the image as it is
i don't wrap it in a link component so
the user won't be able to click it
save the file go back to the application
and hopefully we should be able to click
our thumbnails you can see that we have
this nice little hand here that means
that we
created a link so if we click this one
you can also see that we have the movie
id
up here and that's the one that we're
going to grab in the param
in our movie component so it's working
great
and this is actually it for the routing
there's no more routing we need to do in
this application
and in the next video we're gonna start
creating the movie page
okay we're just gonna do a little bit of
scaffolding in our movie component
before we move on
so up here we're already importing react
we're gonna import some stuff from the
config also so import
we're going to need the image underscore
base
underscore url capital letters
and the poster underscore size and we're
going to import it from dot dot forward
slash
config then we're gonna have our
components we're gonna create
new ones for this one but two of them
we already created we're gonna import
the grid
from dot forward slash grid
then we're also going to need a spinner
so import spinner
from dot forward slash spinner
and then we're going to create the other
ones later we're going to create a hook
for this one and we also need an image
and that's the fallback image just as
before so import
no image from dot dot forward slash
images and no
underscore image dot jpg
and as always be very careful to
actually
add the extension here when it's an
image
all right and then we have our movie
component this one is actually not going
to have an
implicit return we create curly brackets
because we're going to have some logic
in this one
so we create a return statement
parenthesis
and then i'm going to create a react
fragment like this
and inside for now we can just have a
div that says
movie do some order formatting
and save it and i think this should be
it go back to the browser
try something out here or we could
actually just have clicked on one of
these
yeah and it shows the movie so that's
great we know that it works
and then we can move on and we're going
to start by fetching the data from the
api so that we have something to work
with
all right we're going to create our
second custom hook now
i'm not going to create it first in the
movie component and then move it to a
custom hook because now
we know how we can create a custom hook
so that's why i'm doing it
instantly in that one instead so in the
hooks folder let's create a new file
that's called
use movie fetch capital m
capital f and dot j s
and as i told you before it's important
to name your hooks
with use before the name this is the
actual file name so it doesn't matter
here but
it's important that you name your actual
hooked with use before
so for this hook we're going to import
curly brackets we're going to need use
state and use effect
from react just as before we don't
really need a
main react library for this one because
we're not doing any jsx and stuff like
that
so that's why we're not importing it
we're going to import the api object
from dot dot forward slash api
and that will give us access to all
these nice functions that are created
for us
then we create the actual hooked so
export const
use movie fetch equals and this one is
actually going to have a parameter
because it's going to be the movie id
and i'm going to talk more about that in
a second
so that's the arrow function and up here
i create three states
the state and setter for that state
i call the use state hooked
and i'm going to give it an empty object
as default value
then i create a loading state and set
loading
use state i'm going to set this one to
true initially because this component is
going to
start by fetching the data for the movie
so we can set that one to
true and then we're going to have the
error and the set error
just as before and this one we set the
false so use state and give it an
initial value of false
right so that's the state we're going to
need for this one
and then we're just going to need one
use effect
for this one because we're only fetching
data one time and that is when the
component mounts and then we're not
going to fetch anything more
because then we have all the data from
the movie that we need
so we have the inline arrow function
and we have the dependency array and
this one is going to change if the movie
id changes it actually not going to
change now because we just do it
initially as i told you
but as i also told you we need to
specify all the dependencies
for our use effect so that's fine in
this case to have it there
it only going to fetch it one time and
then as the use effect can't have an
async function here we create another
function that's async
fetch data equals
async and in this case i place it inside
of the use effect and i'm going to show
you
why in a second also so we have an async
error function
and then we can do our fetching logic
inside of this one and it's going to be
quite similar to the other one that we
did
so we have a try block and we're going
to catch the error if there is one
and if there is an error we set error
to true like this
and in our try block the first thing we
do is to set the loading to true
and we also set error to false
yes that's we did before and then we can
fetch our data but i have a typo here
you just say error
yeah i guess i misspelled it up here
yeah
there you have it all right yeah this
one too
ah something like that
right so first we're going to grab the
movie data from one resource from the
endpoint
and then we also have to grab the
credits that we get from another
resource from the endpoint
so we have const movie equals
a weight and from the api i created a
function that's called
fetch movie without an s at the end
now we're going to give it the movie id
all right so that's the movie then we
also want to fetch
the credits so we create a const with
that we that we name credits
we await again from the api dot
fetch credits and we also give it a
movie id
so hopefully we got all the data that we
need here
in those const but we want to do some
stuff here and that is we only want to
show the directors only because if we
look at the finished application
and we go back and we click whoa
yeah there you have it encountered two
children with the same key
and this is what happens sometimes with
this api and i really don't know why
so if you get this warning you can
create your own unique key
somehow by maybe have a random number
and the movie id i don't know
you can do it in many different ways but
for now it doesn't really matter
so we have the movie here and as you can
see here we are showing the director so
we need to get the directors somehow
from the api because from the api and
the credits we get something back
that's called crew and the crew contains
more than the directors
so we have to filter out the directors
to just get the director's name
so i mark it with get
directors only and then i create the new
const
i call it directors equals and from the
credits
that's the one up here we have the crew
property and i'm going to filter this
one
filter is a built-in method in
javascript we have a member
a crew member
so i'm going to check if the member dot
job this is also a property
that we get back from the movie database
api i'm going to check if that one
is equal to director with a capital d
and that will filter out all the
directors and put them in this const
or format it and then we have all the
data that we need so that we can set our
state
so we call set state that's the setter
for our state
in this case we don't need to use a
previous value so i'm just
returning an object here i spread out
the movie
that's the data that we got back here so
we spread out everything from that one
and then we have a property that's
called actors
and i'm going to give it the credits dot
cast
so from the credits we have the cast and
we also got the the
directors from the crew so that the
actress is a property that i create
myself
that i want to have in my state and i'm
going to have all the cast inside of the
actors property
and the last one is going to be the
directors
there can be more than one director so
that's why it's called directors with an
s
and as this is es6 syntax we just need
to type out this it will
create it like this automatically
all right then
we're going to set loading
the false like this
auto format it and this should be it for
this use effect
actually i think for now
we need to return something from our
hook also
i return an object with a state loading
and error
save it go back to the movie.js file
and we can see if it works so down here
i marked it with hook
i'm going to import use moviefetch
from dot dot
forward slash hooks and use movie fetch
and then we can try out our hook and see
if we get some data back
so at the top of our component we can
destructure out the properties that we
exported from the hooked
i also want to show you how you can
rename something when you destructure it
so we have the state that we destructor
then we have a colon
and i want to call it movie instead so
that's how you rename it
and then we just structure out the
loading and the error
and we call or use movie fetch hook and
we also want to give it the movie id
but we haven't really got the movie id
so how do we get it
yeah and this is from the route that we
have up here as i told you
about before we have the id up here in
the route so we can get that one
from the router so we have to import
something
up here so we import curly brackets it's
a hook that's called use params
from react-router-dom
so with this hook we can grab that param
that we have in the url
so we do that before with the structure
out the state and everything here from
our use movie fetch hook
to make sure that we have the id to send
into that hook
the const and then we just structure out
the movie id
equals and we call the use params that's
everything you have to do
and this one is named movieid because we
named it that in the app.js file
we call it movieid if we call it
something else here
we have to destructure it with that name
but this will give us
that id that we have up in the road here
in our application
so hopefully this will work we can we
try to console logout
the movie and this is actually the state
but i renamed it to movie so that's why
i can console log it out as a movie save
it
so we try it out click a movie and ah
nothing shows up and i think
i know why we go inside a used movie
fetch hook
we also need to actually invoke this
function here
so we do that at the bottom of our use
effect hook
fetch movie
yeah did i name it fetch data we can
rename it to fetch
movie instead like this
and make sure to invoke it at the bottom
of the hook
save it go back to the application and
now you can see that we have the data
here
so we have all the actors and we also
have the directors that we filtered out
here so that's great
all the data that we need is here
i want to show you one more thing here
and that is if we were to remove this
patch movie function outside of the use
effect
like this
it tells us here that we need to specify
the fetch movie and that's okay because
it's outside the use effect now
so we do that and then it gives us
another warning here and this is because
this function will get recreated on each
render
and this use effect will think that it's
a new function it gets on each render
and it will create an infinity loop
so that's no good so if we want to have
it placed outside of the use effect
we need to wrap it in something that's
called a use pullback hook
so we can import that one up here and
then we wrap this one
in the used callback hook like this and
then at the end of it
we need to have a dependency array in
this case it's empty
and then it gives us another warning and
then it says that it needs to specify
the movie id
because the movie id is something that's
outside of this one here
we also need to specify this one we
specify the move id
like this and now it won't complain and
this one
will not get recreated unless the movie
id
changes so this will stop the infinity
loop
and we can see that it won't go into an
infinity loop here
if you want to do it like this instead
you can do that in this case we don't
need to call this function from
anywhere outside of the use effect so
i'm just going to revert it back and not
use to use callback hook
so i'm going to have it inside of my use
effect instead
like we had it before save it make sure
that it works again and it does
so that's how you use the used callback
hook to stop infinity loops in react
but in this case we won't need it so
it's better to have this function
directly in the use effect hook instead
all right let's move on and create some
nice components for our movie page
all right we're gonna create this nice
little breadcrumb navigation up here
on each individual movie so go back
inside of the code editor
and inside the components folder create
a new folder that's called breadcrumb
capital b capital c and you create
another file inside of that one that's
called
index.js and you create a file that's
called
breadcrumb.styles.js
a bit repetitive now but it's good
because that means that we're probably
learning something here
so inside the breadcrumb.styles file
we're going to scaffold our two style
components but first we import styled
from style components
then we export the const that's called
wrapper
and it equals a style.dir double back
ticks
and then we export the const that's
called
content
and it equals a style dot div
or format it and save it go back inside
of the index.js file in the breadcrumb
folder
first we import react from
react we're going to import the link
from react-router-dom
because we want to be able to link back
to the home page then we have our styles
import wrapper
and content from
dot forward slash breadcrumb dot styles
and then we create our component const
breadcrumb
equals then we're gonna destructure out
the prop that's called
movie title
and we create an arrow function and we
can make an implicit return so we have
parenthesis
we're going to have the wrapper and then
we have the content
then we're going to use the link from
the react router dom
it's going to link to and where do we
think it's going to link
probably guess it it's going to be
forward slash because we want to link to
the home page
this is the first element in the
breadcrumb menu
so we're going to have a regular span
here and it's going to say
home so that's the first one
then after the link
we create another span and we're going
to have a pipe
like this i think it's option seven on
mac
yeah option seven or you can have
whatever you want inside of there but i
like to have that as a divider
and then we have the last span and
that's it's gonna be the
movie title do some order formatting and
then we need to export default this one
also
export default breadcrumb
right so this is going to be a two level
breadcrumb we only have the home button
to click on to go back to the home page
and then we show the movie title save
the file and then go back to the
movie.js file
up here where we have the component
imports we import
breadcrumb from dot forward slash
breadcrumb all right
and then we can use it down here in our
jsx
one thing we can do first is that we can
return something here
if we're loading so if loading
return we're going to return the spinner
if we load in something which we are
going to do initially
and if we have an error we return
a div that says something
went wrong or something else if you want
that
so this will make sure that we show the
loading spinner initially when we're
loading all the data for the movie and
if we have an error we won't show that
jsx down here
i don't know why it's a spinner here now
i'm going to delete that
all right so instead of the movie here
i'm gonna remove this one and i'm gonna
use my breadcrumb
and it has a prop that's called movie
title
and for that one i'm gonna give it the
movie dot
original underscore
title and i close the component like
that
save it and go back to the browser
and click a movie and you can see that
we have our breadcrumb here
it looks like crap but we're gonna style
it in the next video so don't worry
and it seems to be working here with the
title and everything and we can click
the home button to get back to the home
page
that's nice so in the next video we're
going to give it some styling
all right time to give this little
breadcrumb some styles
and we do that inside of the breadcrumb
dot styles
file we have two components inside of
that one we have the wrapper and the
content so let's start by
styling the wrapper i'm gonna display it
as a flex
align items
it's going to be center and justify
content
it's also going to be center i set the
width
to 100 the height is going to be 70
pixels
and the background is going to be from
the variable that's called
mad gray and the color is going to be
also from a variable but that's the
white one
save it go back and see what we've got
so far you can see that we have it here
but it looks
not good now so we have to fix this also
and that's the one here that's the
content
so the content we set that one also to
flex display flex
the width is going to be 100 percent
the max width on this one is going to be
from the variable
max width
and the padding is going to be 0 and 20
pixels
then we have the span element inside our
breadcrumbs we're going to start at one
also
so span we set the font size
what do we have in the global style here
in the root
font me i think it's the font medium
so variable dash dash font med
and the color is going to be from the
variable it's going to be
white
the padding dash right is going to be 10
pixels
and then we're also going to have a
media query for this one so at media
screen and max
dash width it's going to be 768
pixels and i'm just going to change the
font size here font size
and i think yeah i forgot all of them
now
yeah font small that'll do
i think so from the variable
font small all right save it and go back
to our application
and there you have it and it should
change in font size
yeah so it's working and the link is
working
great there's some padding there
yeah i have it there also okay yeah it
doesn't matter you can adjust that one
if you want to do that
all right so that's the styles for the
breadcrumbs so let's move on and create
our movie info component
we're going to create the movie info
component so if we look at an individual
movie here we can look at anyone
it's this component here it's kind of a
hero component
so i think this will be the largest
individual component in this application
so we're going to do a little bit of jsx
and also it's going to be a little bit
of styling for this one
so we better get started with this move
back to your code editor
and inside the components folder create
a new folder that we call
movie info capital m capital i
and then we create a new file index.js
and then another file inside of that
folder that's called
movieinfo.styles.js
we scaffold out the styles so import
styled from style components
and for this one we're actually also
going to import some other stuff here
because we need the image base url and
the backdrop size
from the config and i'm going to talk
about that when we style this component
but we import them now to import
capital letters image underscore base
underscore url and also
the back drop underscore
size and we grab them from
dot dot forward slash dot dot forward
slash config
right then we scaffold out three
components here so export const
wrapper equals style div
double back ticks export const
content hopefully beginning to see my
pattern on styling in this
one i usually have a wrapper and a
content
this one is also going to be a style div
and then we're going to have a third one
that's going to be called export const
text
and it's also going to equal a style.div
double backticks
like so save the file go back to the
index.js file in the movie info folder
and we can start building this massive
component
now it's not really that massive i think
it's about 50 rows or something
all right import react from react
then we're going to have a component
so we're actually going to use the thumb
component for this one so import thumb
from dot dot forward slash
thumb all right so that's the component
that we need
we also need something from the config
so import
the image underscore based on the score
url
and also the poster
underscore size
from dot dot forward slash dot dot
forward slash
double dot dot forward slash config
then we have an image and it's going to
be the fallback image as we always use
so import no image from
dot dot forward slash dot dot forward
slash again
images no underscore image dot
jpg all right and then we have our
styles
the import curly brackets
wrapper content
and text from
dot forward slash movie info.styles
right so that's our imports then we're
going to create the component itself so
we have a const
movie info equals
i'm going to structure out a prop that's
called movie we're going to give it the
movie data as a prop
an arrow function and we can make an
implicit return on this one
first i actually going to export default
it export default
movie info like so then inside of here
we're first going to have a wrapper
and this one is actually going to take
in a prop
and that's going to be the backdrop
image so we have a prop that's called
backdrop
and from the movie we have a property
that's called backdrop
underscore path and we close the
component
and inside the wrapper we have our
content
like so then we're going to use our
thumb
component again and this is actually
great because you can see here how you
can reuse components in react
and this is kind of the fundamentals of
working with components you can reuse
them in your application
so you should always code with that in
mind if you want to reuse it somewhere
you should make the component flexible
so you don't need to create similar
components it's better to use one
component that you can modify with props
instead so we have our thumb and on that
one if you remember we have an image
prop
so we're going to give it the image and
this one just as before i'm going to
check if it has a movie poster
path i use a toner operator for this one
i have a question mark
and also note i created curly brackets
here because this is a javascript
expression
and as i like to do it with template
literals i'm going to have double back
ticks
and i have a dollar sign and then i'm
going to grab the image base url
then i have another dollar sign and
curly brackets i'm going to grab
the poster size and then lastly i'm
going to have a new dollar sign and
curly brackets
i'm going to grab the movie dot poster
underscore path
so that is if we have a poster path
otherwise
we have a colon and we show the no image
that we imported
so that's the image prop then we have
the clickable prop
and in this case we're going to give it
force because we don't want this one to
be clickable
we set an alt of movie thumb
and then we can close this component do
some order formatting
save it and we can actually go back to
our movie.js
component and import this one here where
we import the components
import movie info from dot forward slash
movie info and then below here below the
breadcrumb
or we can use our movie info component
like this we give it a prop of movie and
it's going to be the complete
movie state if you want you can specify
it even more in detail if you don't want
to give it the complete state but i
think for simplicity's sake
i give it a complete state here to work
with save the file go back to our
browser
and you can see that we have our image
here and we can't click it and that's
great
so you see so it works with some other
stuff here yeah
it does so that's great move back inside
of the index.js file in the movie info
folder
so we created our thumb and just below
the thumb we're going to have our text
so we use the text style component
and inside of that one we're going to
have an h1 tag
and we're going to grab the movie dot
title for that one
then we have an h3 tag and it's going to
say
plot or something else if you want that
next we have a p tag and we're going to
grab the movie dot overview
and that's the short text about the
movie
and inside of here i actually gonna
create some regular classes with class
name because i want to show that also
you could create style components also
if you want to do that
for for these that i'm going to create
now but i'm going to create the regular
div with a class name of
rating dash directors i'm going to have
both the rating and the directors in
this one
and inside of this one i'm going to nest
another div
and inside that div i'm going to nest an
h3 tag
that's going to say rating like that
and then i have another div with a class
name
that's gonna be that's gonna be score
and then i'm gonna grab from the movie
dot vote underscore average and that
will give us the score from the api
so that's the rating then below this
wrapping div
i'm going to create another wrapping div
and this one going to have a class name
of director and inside of that one
i'm gonna have another h3 tag
and it's gonna say director and i'm
gonna do a little trick here because if
there's more than one director we wanted
to say directors
so i create curly brackets and inside
here i
oops don't know why i did like that
okay and inside the curly brackets i can
have a javascript expression
and i can check if movie dot directors
dot length if that one is greater than
one
i'm going to add in an s like this
otherwise i just return an empty string
so if there's only one it will say
director otherwise it will say directors
then below that header we create another
pair of curly brackets because now we
have to loop through the directors and
display them
in our dom so from our movie we have
this property that's called directors
we're gonna map over that one
and we have a director
and we can make an implicit return in
this arrow function
so we have a p tag with a key it's
always important to
include a key as you know otherwise
react will complain react uses the key
internally
to diff stuff so it knows what to
changed in the dom
okay so the key is going to be from from
the director
we're going to grab something that's
called credit underscore id
and this will be unique right and inside
the p tag we have another pair of curly
brackets
and i'm gonna grab the director
dot name auto format it
so that's the directors and this should
hopefully be it so we can save it go
back
to the application and see what we got
we probably won't see anything because
this text is
white i guess or and yeah if we check
here below
you can see that we have the plot it is
in white now so we can't see it the
rating is 5.1
and we have a director here also so we
know that it's working we just have to
give it some styling to make it look
nice and that's exactly what we're going
to do in the next video
we have finished the logic for our movie
info component so it's time to style
this one
go back inside of the code editor and
inside the movie info.styles.js
we start off with wrapper
for this one we set the background and
this one is going to be based on the
prop that we send in that is called
backdrop
so i'm going to create a ternary
operator here because if we don't have a
backdrop then we're going to set the
background to be just
black and if you remember when we grab a
prop
in a style component we can do that with
a dollar sign and curly brackets
because this is a template literal so
that's how you create a javascript
expression
and then i'm going to destructure out
from the props so i have a parenthesis
and curly brackets again so i'm going to
destructure out the backdrop
like this and then i create an inline
arrow function
and then i'm going to create a turner
operator here to check if the backdrop
exists so backdrop then i have a
question mark
and then i do another template literal
inside of here
we have the url and i have a regular
single quote i don't actually know if we
need this one
but i'm going to leave it in just to be
sure and then dollar sign curly brackets
and i grab the image base url and then i
have again
dollar sign and curly brackets and i
grab the backdrop size
and i have a third dollar sign and curly
brackets
and i'm gonna grab the backdrop that's
the one that we send into this component
so that is if we have a backdrop
otherwise to the right of the colon
i'm gonna show a black color
and then we have a semicolon to end this
with just after the last curly bracket
this can be a little bit uh nested here
and hard to read actually see if it does
something if i
yeah it order formatted it's on one row
okay yeah that's fine
so i'm going to remove this sidebar so
you can see this is maybe easier to read
so i check if the backdrop is true and
then to the right to the question mark
i'm going to parse in the image base url
and the backdrop size
and then we have the backdrop that we
send into this start component
if this exists we're going to show that
one as a background otherwise we set the
background to be black
right then we're going to set the
background
dash size
it's going to be cover and then we have
the background
dash position that one
is going to be sender and i'm going to
set a
little bit of padding on this one so 40
pixels and 20 pixels
and i have an animation also because i
want this one to fade up just as the
other ones
animate movie info camel casing
and one second and then i create the key
frames so add keyframes
like this and then we go from or if you
want to use zero percent instead
we set the opacity to zero and then two
or hundred percent if you use that
instead
opacity is gonna be one save it and see
what we got
okay i must have some typos somewhere
because we
we don't see the background yeah and
that's because i need to have
this single quote here also at the end
save it and go back and there you have
the backdrop
so that's sweet i can actually try also
to remove those
and see if it works without them yeah
and it seems to be working
so we don't actually need to have those
single quotes all right
sweet okay that's the wrapper move down
and then we're going to style the
content itself
we set the display to flex
the max dash width is going to be from a
variable
max width
then we set the margin to 0 and auto
the background i'm going to set a
transparent black on this one so rgb or
rgb a i don't think you need a actually
zero zero zero and 0.7
and that will make it a little bit
transparent
then we have a border radius
of 20 pixels and we have a media query
on this one also so at
media screen and
max width it's going to be 768 pixels on
this one
and then i'm going to display it as a
block
and set the max height to none
and that's it for the content save it go
back to the application
and you can see that we have the content
here but we need to do some more styling
here
on the text to get it to look exactly as
we want
so we have our text style component here
and for this one we set the width to 100
percent
i set the padding to 20 pixels and 40
pixels
set the color from the variables white
and the overflow is going to be hidden
on this one
then i'm going to grab a class that's
called rating
dash director so that's the one that i
created inside of here
rating dash director so you can grab
them just as a regular class in the
style component so that's why you don't
need to create a separate style
component for each and every element if
you don't want to do that
some elements are really small and maybe
it's not justified to have
its own style component so we're going
to display it as a flex
and justify content is going to be flex
dash start
then we have the score class
this one is also going to be displayed
as a flex
align dash items is going to be center
and justify content
is going to be standard so these three
will center stuff for us and you could
also create
a separate class if you don't want to
type them in all the time
the width is going to be 35 pixels
the height is also going to be 35 pixels
the background is going to be white
so fff and the color
is going to be black and you could also
of course create variables for these
ones if you want to do that and place
them in the global style
where we have the other css variables
the font dash weight is going be
800 the border dash radius
is gonna be 25 pixels
or you can actually set it to 50 if you
want that instead because this is a
circle and the margin
is going to be zero that's the score
and then we have our director so dot
director
the margin is going to be 0 0
0 and 40 pixels on that one and inside
of that one we have a p
tag and we set the margin to zero on
that
and below we have the last one that's
the h1 tag
and that one is gonna have a media
screen
and max dash width
768 pixels
and we set the font dash size
to variable dash
font big right save it
go back to yeah the application
something here that doesn't look right
and i think i know what it is
yeah this one is called directors and
probably
i misspelled this one yeah rating
directors we should have an s
zeros on that class make sure that you
add an s and save it
go back to the application and now it
should look right
yeah and it does we can see if it looks
great on another movie also
and it does
so that's the movie for component in the
next video we're going to check out this
little movie info bar
that's below here we can see the running
time the budget and the revenue let's
create the movie
infobar and that's the one here with the
running time budget and revenue
we're gonna start as always by creating
the component first and then we create
the styles in the next video
so we start off in the components folder
by creating a new folder
that we call movie info bar capital m
capital i capital b and inside of that
folder we're going to create a new file
that's called
index.js and then we're going to create
another file that's called
boring stuff no i'm just kidding
of course not but it's getting a little
bit repetitive here
it's going to be called movie info
bar.styles.js of course
and we start off by scaffolding out
those star components
import styled chrome
style components
then we export constant we have our
wrapper
style.div double backticks
and then we're going to have our content
export const content
equals styled dot div
and double back ticks save the file and
go back to the index.js file
we import react from react
and then we're going to use some helper
functions that are provided for us
so if we take a look in the helpers.js
file you can see that i have one
function for calculating the time
and one for converting the money so this
one for example to convert money
javascript has something built in that
we can use for for converting into a
currency
and this one i set this one for
converting it into us dollars
so you can change this one if you want
to have another currency
and this one is going to give us the
time in hours and minutes
so these are the ones that we're going
to import in the component so move back
to the index.js file
and i mark it with helpers
import calc time
camel casing and convert money also
camera casing
from dot dot forward slash and dot dot
forward slash again
help us right
then we have our styles so we import
curly brackets and wrapper and content
from dot forward slash movie info bar
styles
all right and then we can create our
component
so we have our const of movie info bar
equals this one is going to get some
props
so the structure of the time the budget
and the revenue
and i have an error function and i make
an implicit return
and i think i'm also going to export
default it before we start creating our
jsx so export default
movie info bar all right
we start off with our wrapper
then we have our content
and the first div we're gonna have is a
div we have a class name of
column on that one
so we have a p tag and running time
colon then i have a curly bracket and we
invoke the function that's called calc
time that we imported
and we give it the value of time and we
end it with a curly bracket
so that would give us the correct time
and actually the other two divs are
going to look almost exactly the same so
i'm going to copy this one and paste
them in two more times
the class name is going to be column
also on these ones but this one we can
change it to budget
and instead of calc time we're going to
invoke
convert money instead and we're going to
give it
budget and the last one
is going to be revenue
and we also invoke convert money
and give it the revenue
all right save it and this is our movie
info bar we just need to
make sure that we use it in the movie
component so move back to the movie.js
import it up here import movie info bar
from dot forward slash
movie info bar and then
below just below the movie info
we use that component movie info bar and
we also had to give it some props
time is going to equal movie dot run
time
budget it's going to equal
movie dot budget
and the revenue
is going to be the movie dot revenue
and then we close the component like
this do some order formatting and we get
them
on each row so that's much nicer we can
see it here now so we have these props
here now
and this should be it for the movie info
bar if we save this one
go back to the browser
and nothing shows and that's because we
haven't styled it yet i thought we
should see something at least
but i guess it's because yeah the text
is white now so that's why so you can
see down here
that we have the running time we have
the budget but the budget is actually
zero so that's no good or
is it zeroed out on that particular
movie
yeah it was it didn't have any budget
all right
so in the next video we're gonna style
it
alright we're going to create the styles
for the movie infoboard so make sure
that you're inside the movie
infoboard.styles
file and we start as always with the
wrapper
we displaced as flicks
align the items
to center i'm going to set a min height
on this one
to 100 pixels and the background
is going to be from the variables and
i'm going to grab the dark gray
i set the padding to 0 and 20 pixels
save it go back and see what we got so
far
here we can see it down here so go back
to the code
then we're going to style the content we
display it as a flex
i set the max width of a variable
from the variable max width
i set the width to 100 percent
and the morgan is going to be zero and
auto
then we have that class that's called
column so dot column
that's the one if you remember that we
have here the class name column
and i'm also going to display that one
as a flex flexbox is a really handy tool
in css align items is gonna be sender
and justify content is gonna be sender
i set the background from our variable
i'm going to grab met gray
i set the border dash radius
to 20 pixels the morgan
is going to be 0 20 pixels and the flex
is going to be set to 1. then
i'm going to style the first child we
have we have three of them so i want to
style the first
shot a little bit differently i want to
set the margin dash
left to zero and then i also want to
style the last
child the colon last child
i set the margin right to zero
all right then we just have a media
query left
at the bottom here at media
screen and
max dash width 768 pixels
i display it as a block below that
pixel size and the column
dot column is gonna have a margin of 20
pixels on zero
all right this should be it save it
go back to the application see if it
works
yeah there you have it it works on
mobile devices also
so that's super great that's the movie
info bar and now we just have the grid
with the actors left to do
and then we've finished the basic stuff
with this
application
all right let's create the last
component for our application and that's
going to be the actor
so inside the components folder create a
new folder that the name
actor and then you create a new file
inside of that folder that we're going
to call
index.js
and we create another file that's called
actor.styles.js
and inside actor.styles.js we import
styled
rom style components
and then we export the const that we
call wrapper
equals style.div double backticks
and then we're going to have another one
export const
is going to be called image capital i of
course
equals styled dot imd we're going to
style
this image tag save it
go back to the index.js file and we can
create our
actor component so we import react
from react then we have our styles
and we import the wrapper and the image
from dot forward slash actor styles
then we create the component const actor
equals
parenthesis and i'm not going to
structure out inside of the curly
brackets
the name the character
and the image url
now we have an arrow function we make an
implicit return
we have the wrapper then we're going to
display our image
we have the source of image
url and alt
is going to equal actor
dash thumb and then we close it
and then we have an h3 tag
that's going to display the names the
curly brackets and name
that's the prop name and then we have a
p
tag and we have curly brackets and we're
going to grab the character
that's going to be the name of the
character
right then we just need to export
default
actor and our component is good to go
so go back to the movie.js file import
it up here
import actor
from dot forward slash
actor all right and then move down to
our jsx and just below the movie info
bar
we're going to show these actors and
we're going to show them inside of our
grid
so we first display our grid the header
for this one
is going to be actors if you remember we
have this prop
that's called header where we can set a
title of our grid
and inside the grid we're going to map
through all the actors
so we have curly brackets and from the
movie dot actors
we're gonna map through each actor so we
have an actor
and an inline arrow function parenthesis
we make an implicit return
then we display an actor it needs to
have a key
as always when we map through stuff in
our jsx in react
so the key is going to be from the actor
dot
credit underscore id
that's the key then we have a prop
that's called name so we're going to
give it the actor.name
i'm going to scroll up a little bit here
and then we have a prop that's called
character and for that one we give it
the actor.character
like so and then we have the image url
and it's going to equal and this one is
also going to be
that turner operator that we used before
because we want to display a fallback
image if we don't have that one
so we check if we have an actor dot
profile
underscore path and then we have a
question mark and we're going to return
our nice little url so i have double
back ticks
dollar sign and i have curly brackets
and i grab the image base url
and then directly after that i have
another dollar sign curly brackets
and i grab my poster size
and then i have a third dollar sign and
curly brackets
and i'm going to grab actor dot profile
underscore path be very careful with the
spelling here
it's very easy to get a typo when you do
stuff like this
then we have our colon and if we don't
have a profile path we give it a no
image and then
below here we need to close that
component also do some order formatting
so this should be it my friend we have
hopefully finished the
base of the application and then i'm
going to teach you some other stuff
that's useful in react
so this should be it i hope save it and
go back
to the browser you can see that we have
the actors here but it doesn't look good
we have
because we haven't styled them yet but
at least it's working
and these are in white there you can see
the character they play in the movie
so we're going to style them in the next
video and then we have this nice actors
grid
all right let's give those actors some
styling
so inside our code in the
actor.styles.js file we have two style
components
so let's start with the wrapper as usual
i'm gonna set the color from our
variables
we have white i set the background
and also from our variables we have the
dark
gray i set the border dash
radius to 20 pixels
the padding is going to be 5 pixels and
the text line
is going to be center then i'm going to
have an h3 tag nested here
i set the morgan to 10 pixels 0 0
0 on that one and then we have the p tag
it's going to have a margin of 5 pixels
and 0.
all right so that's everything for the
wrapper
then we have the image just a few lines
of code left
we display it as a block
the width is going to be 100 percent
the height is going to be 200 pixels
and object dash fit is going to be cover
and the border radius
is going to be 15 pixels and this should
be it
save it go back to the application and
hopefully we have a nice grid yeah
almost there's something wrong here with
the background
yeah and that's because i have a typo it
should say
border radius like that
not radius save it go back
and there you have it let's make sure
that it works
on all devices and it does
sweet sweet sweet and that concludes the
basic stuff for this application
in the next video we're going to talk
about prop types and how you can type
check the props that you send in to your
components
i'm going to talk about something that's
called prop types and prop types is
something you can use on your components
in react
to type check the props that you send
into your component
so you have this special property on
your components you create
that's called prop types i'm on the
official react page now react js.org
and just as they say here react has some
built-in type checking
abilities i'm going to show you how to
convert this application into typescript
later in a chapter so if you don't use
typescript you should use prop types
instead
that way you can at least type check
your props that you send in
so they tell you here to run type
checking on the props for a component
you can assign a special prop types
property
and they give you an example here so
they import the prop types that's from
the library that we installed earlier
prop types up here then they have the
component name and then assign
and then assigned to this property
that's called prop types
so this one has a lowercase letter to
start with and this one has an uppercase
letter
so this one is the actual property on
the component itself
and this one is the one that you import
from the library that's called prop
types
so it can be a little bit confusing but
we're gonna
practice this in our components so
hopefully you'll get a grasp of it quite
quickly
you have this special property on your
component that's called prop types
and that is an object and there you can
specify your props
and from the prop types that we import
up here you have different types you can
check against
so this one will get a warning if the
prop isn't the string
that this component receives and if we
scroll down here
they show you everything you can do here
and we are actually just going to do
those
simple checks if it's a string a number
or a boolean
but you can also check against an object
for example
you can check all the properties in an
object and then you use something that's
called
shape and then you specify your object
shape inside of that one
so you can do some more advanced prop
type validation here
instead of just check that it's an
object you can check
all the properties on the object by
using the dot shape
so i highly suggest that you read this
one on react.js.org
if you want to know more about prop
types i think a lot of people now are
starting to use typescript with
react and with typescript we don't have
to do this we have it for free in
typescript so prop types is only good if
you don't use typescript
and that's why i won't go into super
detail about it either because i think
typescript
is actually great to use in combination
with react
but you should know at least that you
can do some deeper prop type
validation by using some of these
syntaxes here
and you can also check an object with a
with warnings on extra properties
then you can do an exact check here if
you want to do that and you can also
check
if you're sending an array that should
have only numbers you can check that
also
so that you make sure that the array
doesn't contain strings for example
well and you can do the same with an
object here so there's some really
useful stuff
inside of here that you can learn if you
want to get more advanced
into prop types but we are going to use
the most simple use cases and we're
going to check for strings
numbers and booleans and also for
functions i think
so in the next video we're going to
learn about the most simple forms on how
you can use prop types on your
components
okay let's start doing some prop type
validation
so we're going to do that with the prop
types library that we installed
in the beginning of this course so let's
begin at the top here with the actor in
the components folder and then we're
going to move our way down
and go through all of our components
so in the actor make sure that you
import
prop types capital p capital t
from prop dash
types all right
and then just below the component at the
bottom here just above the export
default
we have our actor component so we're
going to use the special property that's
called prop types on that
one so actor dot prop types
and this one is lowercase p not capital
p
as it is up here be very careful here it
can be
quite confusing actually so
prop types is going to equal and we have
an object
and then we can specify our different
props that we have here
so we have the name prop and the name
prop
we know that this one is a string so
from the prop types that we import
that's capital p
prop types with capital p prop types
we have something that's called string
so we're going to check against if it's
a string
all right then we have the character
and from prop types with capital t p
we're also going to check if that one is
a string and we have the third one
image url rob types
dot string all of these are going to be
strings
so we save this one go back to our
application
and we can see here we're going to need
to be
on an individual movie here so we have
this movie here nothing shows up here
but if we go inside or i'm just going to
close this
here so if we go inside our movie.js
component we have our actor here and we
know that this name for example is a
string so if we change this one to a
number for example 10
save it go back to our application you
can see that we instantly get a warning
here
failed prop type invalid prop name of
type number
applied to actor expected string
so this is a very handy way when you
develop your application to know that
you send in the correct props to your
components
and this is only available in
development mode it will not be in
production
so it's kind of a tool when you develop
this application
to actually validate your props that
you're sending in to your components
so we're going to change this back now
and hopefully get an idea on how it
works now
so that was our actor then we have our
breadcrumb
so just as before we import prop types
capital p capital t from prop dash
types and below
the component we have the component name
breadcrumb dot prop types
with a lowercase p it's going to equal
an object
and for this one we have a prop that's
called movie title
and from the prop types with a capital p
we're gonna check if it's a string all
right
so that's the breadcrumb then we have
the bottom
for that one we have two props so we
import
prop types capital p from
prop dash types
and below the component we have the
button
dot prop types lowercase p
equals an object we have our text prop
that one we're going to check prop types
capital p
getting a little bit repetitive here and
we check if it's a string
and then we have a coma and we have a
callback
and from the prop types
capital p this one is going to be a
function so we have that one also on the
prop types object
func so we can check if it's a function
save it go back to our application and
check yeah it seems to be right
that's our button then we have our grid
import prop types capital p
from prop dash types
below the component grid dot prop types
lowercase p then we have two props for
this one
header prop types dot
string we check if it's a string and we
actually don't need to check the
children because that is a built-in prop
so we don't
need to verify that one so that's the
grid
then we have the header and the header
don't have any props
we can skip that one we have the hero
image and this one have three of them
so we import prop types capital p
from prop dash types
below the component we type in hero
image
dot prop types lowercase p
we have our object and we have the image
we check against the prop types with
capital p
dot string all of these are going to be
strings also we have the title
prop types dot string and we have the
text
prop types dot string
all right image title and text
save the component we move inside a
movie info component
and for that one we have one prop
import prop types from
prop dash types and below
the component
movie info dot prop
types equals an object
and we call it movie i think yeah movie
and this one is an object so prop types
dot
object and this is what i talked about
before in the last video
if we go back here you can see if we
want we can shape this object
with dot shape but i think there's too
many
properties in this object now to
actually do this i don't think it's
worth it so i just check if it's an
object
but if you use dot shape you can shape
the complete object here
and check every property on the object
all right let's move on we have the
movie info bar
and for that one we have three of them
so import
prop types from prop dash types
below the component movie
info bar equals an object
and we have the time and prop types
dot this is going to be a number so we
have the number property
check against that's the time
then we have the budget prop types
dot number it's also going to be a
number we have the revenue
prop types dot number all three of them
are numbers
movie info bar yeah
of course i also have to have dot prop
types
like this right
just check the application everything
seems to be working
movie info is defined is it because i
typed in yeah
this one is auto generated when i typed
in movie info below
okay just remove it save it
then we have the search bar
import prop types from prop
dash types right
below the component we have the search
bar dot prop types equal
an object so we have the callback
function
so prop types dot
func we check if it's a function
save it the spinner will not have any
props for that one
we have the thumb and we have three of
them there
to import prop types from
prop types
and below the component we have thumb
dot
prop types lowercase p
equals an object and we have the image
i think image movie id and clickable the
image
prop types capital p dot
string that's the url for the image so
it's a string
then we have the movie id prop types
dot number the id is a number
and then clickable
prop types dot and this is a boolean
so we have something that's called bool
and this will check against
the boolean all right
that's actually our last component i
think we don't have anything in home and
movie and not found
that's the last one and i saved this
for last actually because we built the
whole application
so you should do this from start when
you build your component i didn't want
to confuse you too much
before we have learnt more about react
that's why i saved it the last
but you should have as a habit to always
do this when you create a component
that receives some props so that's why i
saved it for last
i think that sums it up about prop types
i'm not going to go
all crazy about prop types hopefully
you'll learn something here to get you
started with prop types
and actually i don't think in this
application we don't need to do any
deeper checks here actually
okay in the next section we're going to
see how we can persist our state in the
session storage
we have almost finished the replication
there are some things we can do to
optimize it
because now yeah it works but for
example here those movies here we always
reload those movies when we visit each
site here and also when we go back to
the start page
we always fetch from the api and that's
what we're going to talk about here
because
in your browser you have something
that's called local storage and session
storage
and we're going to utilize the session
storage to store the data that we
already retrieved
so if you open up the panel and you have
something that's called application
and inside application you have the
storage and there you can see the local
storage and the session storage
and these here are all the movies that
are stored from the application so you
can see it's the movie id here
and here we have the data for the movie
so that's stored here
and we also have the home state so this
is from the other application that is
finished
not ours i just wanted to keep them here
to show you how it's going to look when
we store this stuff
in the session storage local storage and
session storage are quite similar
the big difference is that the local
storage persists
until you decide to remove it the
session storage only persists
over a session so every time you create
a new session the session storage will
get wiped out
and you may wonder wouldn't it be better
to have the local storage for
application yeah it would probably
but this page here is based on all the
popular movies
so it changes a lot so that means if we
store it in the local storage and never
remove it we always get the same list of
movies here and that's no good
so that's why it's better to store it in
the session storage and also
each individual movie here also changes
because we have a rating
yeah that one has zero in rating okay
let's select another one that one has
7.6
so the rating will change depending on
the voting so there is stuff that can
change in each movie also so that's why
i choose the session storage for both of
them
but if you want you can use the local
storage instead the code is going to be
the same
except that you swap out session storage
for local storage when we write the code
in the next video we're going to learn
how to persist the state
in the session storage for the home page
okay we're going to learn how to persist
the state in the session storage
and we're going to start by creating a
little function that we can use to read
from the session storage
so go back inside of the code editor and
in the file that's called helpers.js
that's the one i provided for you
in the starter files we're going to add
in a little function at the bottom here
in this file
so we export the const is persisted
state like this equals
then we have a param that's called state
name
or name you can name it whatever you
want then i have an arrow function
and then we create a cost that we call
session state
equals and from the session storage
session storage we have a method that's
called get item
and this is what i talked about before
if you want to use the local storage
instead
you can just change this one to local
storage and it will work
you just swap this one out to local
storage
all right so we invoke the method that's
called get item
we give it the stay name and this will
return the state from the session
storage
if there's a state otherwise it will
return
null so it will get the item from the
session storage with the name that we
provide
then we need to return something from
this function that we create
so return and i'm going to do a short
circuit here
i check if session stayed
if we have something in this one here
then i have double ampersand and it will
return what's to the right of the
ampersands
otherwise it will return this one and
this will be null if it couldn't find
this one
in the session storage let's say that we
have something in the session state it
will run what's to the right
of the double ampersand so we can return
that state but we can just return it as
it is because
you can only write to the session
storage and to the local storage
as a string so we have to parse it back
from a string
into json so that's also what we're
going to do when we
write to the session storage we're going
to first convert it to a string but now
we have to parse it back
and forth we can do that with json
capital letters
parse and then we give it the session
state like this
and this will parse it back to json
object and we return it
save the file and this is it for this
little function
so let's move inside of the use home
fetch hook
so down below here our search and
initially use effect hook
in this one we can check if we have a
session state before we retrieve
anything from the api so there are a
couple of things we have to consider
here
because we want to check the session
storage on the initial render before we
fetch anything from the api
if we have something in the session
storage we retrieve that one instead
and later we're going to create a hook
that also writes to the session storage
and we're not going to write to the
session storage if we're in the search
and that means that we also don't want
to retrieve anything
if we're in a search so that's why we're
going to create an if statement here
just at the top in this use effect if
now we have an exclamation mark
and search terms so this means if not
search term
then we're going to check the session
storage so we create a new cost
call it session state equals and then we
also have to import our function that we
created in the helpers file so up here
at the top
we can mark it with helpers and import
is persisted state
from dot dot forward slash
helpers so that's our function that
we're going to use here
to the right of the equal sign we call
that function
is persistent state and for a home page
we're going to create a state that is
called the home state
so we are hard coding in the string here
for this one
you can make it a little bit more
elegant if you want to do that
but i have a string here that i call
home state so that's the property
that we're going to write to the session
storage and this one should actually be
called stayed
like this then i'm going to nest in
another if statement here you could do
this in in multiple ways
but i think this one is more readable
for this course
so that's why i have a nested if
statement here also so if
session stayed we check if we have
something here
then we're going to set the state and
give it the session state
and it's also important that we return
because we don't want to do anything
else here
because otherwise it will fetch it from
the api also
and this is all that we need to retrieve
something from the session state
we make sure that we don't check the
session storage if we're in a search
but if we're not in a search we check if
we have something here
and if we have something in the session
storage we set the state with that one
that we retrieved here
and then we return we return early from
this use effect
otherwise it will work as before here we
set the state first with the initial
state to wipe it out and then we fetch
the movies from the api
all right save it just make sure that
everything works and it does
so that's great i'm also going to wipe
out
the old session storage here this one is
from react devtools so when you delete
it it will create a new one
right but we don't actually have
something to retrieve yet
we also need to write something to the
session storage
so if we go down here below our load
more use effect we're going to create
another use effect
and i mark it with write to session
storage
and then i have my use effect
like this this one is going to have a
dependency array
and it's going to write to the session
storage when the search term changes
and also when the stage changes
and yet again i check if not search term
because if we're in a search we don't
want to write that one
to the session storage and this is of
course optional also if you want to
to save the search you can do that also
but i don't think that's a great way of
doing it
to have your last active search on the
home page so that's
why so if not in a search term
we can set on the session storage and
this is the same as before if you want
to store it in local storage you change
this one to local storage instead
dot we have a method that's called set
item just as we had the one that's
called get item
in this case we're going to set it the
first argument is going to be the name
that we wanted to have in the session
session storage and for this one i
choose the name
homestayed just as the one as i grabbed
up here
really important to have the same name
it's a hard-coded string there
then the second argument is going to be
what we want to write to the state
and if you remember i mentioned that we
can only write a string
to the session storage and to the local
storage so we have to stringify it and
we can do that with json capital letters
dot stringify and we give it the state
like this and even if we didn't specify
this once first
you can see that it complains that it
wants the search term and the state now
so this is the linting rules for hooks
that is included in create direct app
so it's really great to have that one
all right so that's how we write to the
session storage
save the file go back to the browser
and you can already see it when i save
the file it that it
that it wrote the home state here for us
so we have the results here
and we can actually go back to the code
and do some console logging
so up here in the search and initial
inside the if statement
where we grab from the session storage
we can console.log
grabbing from session storage
like this and down below here
we can console.log
grabbing from api
and save the file and then if we go back
to the console
you can see grabbing from session
storage and if we reload the page
it works it grabs from the session
storage all the time
and then go back to the application here
and we delete
the home state in the session storage go
back to the console
reload it and now you can see that we
grab from the api
so if we load some more movies here
a few of them
and then we reload the page you can see
that we have them here
instantly and that's because we saved it
to the session storage
in the next video we're going to persist
the state in the session storage
for each individual movie
okay one more thing to do with the
session storage and that is to store
each individual movie in the session
storage that's what we're gonna do
back in the code editor and we're gonna
be in the use movie fetch
and we only have one use effect in this
one
so down at the bottom of that one we run
that fetch movie function
and before we do that we're going to
check if we have something in the
session storage
just above that one just as before we
create a const that we call
session state equals but of course
first we also have to import that
function up here
so we mark it with helpers and import is
persisted stayed
from dot dot forward slash help us
yeah don't know why it did like this
okay to the right of the equal sign here
we're going to run this persisted state
and we're going to check for the movie
id
because each movie is going to be stored
in the session state with its own id
so that will give us null or the actual
state
so if session stayed
if we have a session state we're going
to set the state
and give it the session state and then
we're also going to set the loading
the false this one because we're setting
it to true up here
when we start that's why we have to set
it to false also otherwise
it will keep on showing the spinner okay
and then we make an early return just as
we did before
otherwise it will run this function here
that fetches the movies from the api
right or format it and save it
but we're going to create the use effect
also for writing to the session storage
right to session storage
then we create our use effect with an
inline error function
it's gonna have a dependency array and
it's gonna change on the movie ids
change and the state change
and these actually won't change because
we're just grabbing data one time
for each movie but as i told you many
times before you should specify all the
dependencies
for each use effect if there's something
that won't work because you specify them
here
you should handle it inside of the use
effect and that will make sure that you
have less errors in your application for
this one we don't need an if statement
so we can write to the session storage
dot set item and we're going to give it
a name
of the movie id each movie is going to
be stored in the session story with its
own id
that's how we separate them out then we
have a coma and we give it the state
but just as before we have to run json
stringify
state because we can only write the
string to the session storage
all right save this one and go back to
the application
and here you can see that it already
saved the movie here
so here's the movie for that one
so if we check this one out i think it's
down below here
you can see that it will instantly grab
that movie
and if we choose another one here you
can see that it writes to the session
storage and next time
it will instantly grab it because this
one here you can see we have the loading
spinner
on these ones but next time we don't
have to reload it
that's how you utilize the session
storage to persist the state in your
application
in the next section i'm going to show
you how to deploy this application
it's time to deploy the application and
for this course i'm going to show you
how to deploy it to netlify
i think netlify is a great and very easy
way
to deploy your react application so
that's why i'm not sponsored in any way
by netlify
i just like it and i know that there's a
lot of people that likes it also
so i think netlify is a good choice for
this
so the first thing you have to do is to
create an account at netlify it's free
so make sure that you create an
account and that will show you kind of a
dashboard here
i have a lot of sites here now so yours
will be empty if you don't have an
account already
so make sure to create an account at
netlify we will need it in the next
video so in this video i'm going to show
you how to create a production build of
the application
that we're going to deploy to netlify so
back into the terminal
and create react app it's really simple
to use
it has a built-in command that we can
use to build our site so make sure that
you're inside
your application folder and then you run
mpm
run build like this and this will build
the application for us
as it says here it will create an
optimized production build for us so
that's great
and it will place it in a folder that's
called build if we move inside our code
editor again
we can see that we now have this folder
that's called build
and this is our complete site in here
it's the it's the production build of
our site
we have to do one small thing here when
we're deploying to netlify if we want
our routing to work
correctly because for example i can show
you here
this is the side here if i go to this
site and
choose a movie i grab this url that's
the direct url to the movie
and then i paste it in here you can see
that it works now
and that is because i created that
little file that we're gonna do now
otherwise it won't work it will show an
error here and that's because we're
using in
with react router so that's why we have
to have that little file
so back inside of the code editor
and inside the build folder at the root
create a new file
the name is going to be underscore
redirects like this it's very important
that you name it exactly like this
underscore redirects
and then inside of that one we're going
to type in forward slash
asterisk forward slash index.html
space and 200
and this will make sure that the routing
will work in our application
so save the file and now we're ready to
deploy it on netlify
so that's what we're going to do in the
next video
i'm going to show you two ways in this
video how to deploy your site to netify
and the first one is going to be really
easy actually because if you log into
your account at netlify
and you're at this dashboard side down
below at the bottom you will have this
little
zone here where you can drop your site
want to deploy a new site without
connecting to git
drag and drop your site folder here and
this is really sweet with netlify
actually
so if we grab our folder that's the
folder here where the complete
application is your working folder with
the application
you have the folder inside of that one
that's called build
so make sure that you grab the build
folder that we built in the last video
and just drag and drop it here and you
can see that netlify starts to build
your site
and i actually didn't have time to
finish that sentence before
it published my site so you have the
link here it will create a randomly
generated name
you can change that if you want to do
that so click this link
and you can see that your application is
up and running
so that's how easy it is to deploy with
netlify
that's one way of doing it another way
is to
use something that's called the netlify
cli and that's what we're going to do
next
so make sure to be inside of your
terminal
so of course you're going to be in the
folder where your application is we've
already
built our application otherwise you have
to build it so mpm run build and also
add in that little file that i showed
you
in the last video for the routing to
work in nutlify
then we're going to install the netlife
cli i have already installed it but i
can show you again of course
mpm install netlify dash
cli dash d so that means that i install
it globally
all right that installed correctly i'm
going to clear my console
and then we can run netlify
deploy like this
and then you're faced with different
questions here in this case we're gonna
we're
gonna create and configure a new site so
make sure that you navigate down to that
one
and it's vape and fox team in this case
you will probably also just have one
team to choose from
so select that one and then you can
create a site name if you want to do
that
i won't do that now but you can also
change it later
so i will use the default i just pressed
enter here
and then it asks for the publish
directory down here
and if you remember the publish
directory is the build folder
so we type in dot forward slash build
and press enter
and there you have it but the site isn't
actually live yet because we now have
the
opportunity to see if our site works so
you have a website draft url
we can click that one and here we can
try our application to see that it works
before we actually
go live with it
all right it seems to be working back to
the terminal
and if we read here we can add the dash
dash prod flag if we want to go live
with it so we run
netlify deploy
dash dash prod and this will make it go
live
yeah of course i shouldn't have space it
should be dash dash prod
like this and the publish directory is
just as before dot forward slash build
and you are provided with a couple of
urls here
so this is the unique deploy url for
this deploy this isn't actually the live
site so this is the live site here
on this link you can click that one and
open it up but i want to go inside
of netlify and check that it's actually
here
you can see that it's here so we can
click this one
and see if it works
and it works and that's sweet so that
that is actually also quite simple to do
it in the terminal like this
so if you change something in your
application you can deploy it very
easily without
logging into netlify from the browser so
you just type in netlify
deploy and if you know that it works you
can flag it with prod
like this and you can do this every time
you change something on your site
all right in the next video i'm going to
show you how to deploy with continuous
deployment that means when you change
something and push it to github
i'm going to use github for that one
it's going to deploy it automatically
okay we're going to talk about
continuous deployment on netlife now
and that means that we can have for
example in this case i have a repository
on github that i'm going to use for this
one
i published my site here to get up and
i'm going to use this one for continuous
deployment
and that means that when i push
something to this repository here
netlify will automatically build my site
and publish it
so that's really really neat actually
just make sure that you add to git
ignore file
to not upload the dot and file and also
there's one other thing you have to do
and that is
the file that we created in the build
folder you have to move that one inside
of the public folder instead you can see
that i have
the underscore redirects in the public
folder and this will make sure that this
one is included
when netlife builds the side so that's
all you have to do
and push it to your repository i'm using
github you could use
bitbucket or some other service if you
want to do that
so this is the complete side then i'm
going to move inside of netlify
and i'm at my dashboard you have
something that's called news site from
git
i'm choosing github because that's what
i'm using so it authorized me here
so you have to log in then i can search
for my name is
rmdb version three so i select that
repository
and we're going to build from the master
that's correct the command is going to
be mpm ram build
and we the publish directory is the
build folder so that is correct
but we have one more thing to do because
we have an environmental variable
for our site so we have to set that one
up also
show advanced and here we can create a
variable
new variable so you can set the name
here and the name is going to be
react underscore app underscore api
underscore key
just as the one that we had in our
application
in the dot n file all right then we need
to give it some value and here we can
give it
the api key to the movie database api so
i'm obviously
not going to show that for you so i'm
going to paste that one in and then i'm
going to click
deploy site so make sure that you also
paste in your key here
and then click deploy site and now we
just wait for it
it's going to build a site so it will
take a little bit longer now and
hopefully this will work
and if we want to see the build log we
can also do that by clicking here
deploying a side
and it will show us the log
and there you have it the site is live
it says here so we're going to try that
out
go back to our dashboard and here's the
side
click the link we make sure that it
works
and it does and that is great just gonna
make sure
also that these unique links work if we
paste that one in yeah and it works
sweet sweet sweet this is how you
publish on netlify
and this also concludes the main part of
this course i hope you enjoyed it
there are some bonus parts in the next
part i'm going to show you how to use
class components instead of hooks
and then i'm going to show you how to
convert this application into typescript
and lastly i'm going to show you how to
use the login and vote system
for the movie database api
we're going to refactor our application
into using class components instead of
react hooks
i actually don't use class components
anymore and i think a lot of people
don't do it
but the chances are that if you get a
job as a react developer
you will work with a code base that at
least has some class components
so there's a lot of applications out
there that still has class components in
it
and it's actually not even deprecated
from the react libraries so it's a legit
way
of creating components in react so in
some sense it's
a matter of preference i don't think i
ever will use them again
actually because i love hooks and i
always use functional components with
hooks
but i want to show you how to do it with
class components also and there's
three components that we have to
refactor because we have three
components with state in them
and that's the search bar the home and
the movie and we're going to start with
the search bar
so make sure that you're inside the
index.js file in the search bar folder
and there will be a lot of errors and
warnings here when we remove stuff here
now
but we'll fix that as we go along in
this video
so first of all this one is a functional
component we want it to be a class
component
and then up here instead of importing
use state use effect and use
ref we can import something that's
called
component
like this and instead of the const here
we delete all of this here and we create
a class
that we call search bar just as before
the same name
and it extends component
so if we didn't import that one up here
we had to specify
extend react dot component so this is a
little shortcut you can do here
so we can remove these ones here
in a class component you have one class
property
that's called state and that's the only
state holder you have so that's one
so that's one downside with glasses if
you use use state and react hooks you
can have as many states as you want and
separate them out
here we only have one so we have the
class property
that's called state and now you can see
that i'm not using the constructor
like this because we don't need to do
that
babel and webpack will make sure that it
will be
transpiled down correctly so we have
this class property here
that's called state and it equals an
object
we're going to have a property that's
called value and it's an empty string so
that's the value for our input field
in the search bar and then we're also
going to have a class property that's
called
timeout and we set that one to null
right the use effect we can't use that
one anymore
but we can reuse this logic here for the
timer
so i'll remove these ones for now
and in a class component in react you
have something that's called
life cycle methods and there's three of
them that you should know
that's probably the most used ones you
have one that's called component
did mount and that's the one that's
gonna trigger initially in the component
then you have another one that's called
component did update
and that's the one that we're going to
use now and then you have the last one
that's called component
will unmount and that one is triggered
just before the component will unmount
and in that one you can do some cleanups
and stuff like that
but we're going to use the one that's
called component did update
and you could do this in several ways
you don't actually have to use
this lifecycle method to get this to
work but i want to use it here to show
you
how this lifecycle method works so
component
did update like this
this one is going to give us the
previous props and the previous state
so i make an underscore prev props we're
not going to use the props
because we don't need to check against
the previous props so i mark it with an
unscored just to tell
that we won't use that one and then we
have the pref state
the prev state we will use
all right so that's the component did
update lifecycle method
and this one will trigger on each update
on the component
so what do we want to do here now the
state here with the value is going to be
the text that the user types in in the
input field
because this is a control component so
we keep it in the state
so we want to check if this
dot state dot value it's the value here
and as this is a class we have to use
this so this dot state dot value
if that one isn't equal to the pref
state
dot value we want to do something
otherwise we will go into an
infinity loop here and that's no good we
check here if the value
in the state isn't the same as the
previous one then we know that we should
do
something all right and then we have one
prop that's sent in to this component
and we can destructure that one out
so const it's called set search term
equals this.props so we just structure
this one out from the props
because we send in this function here
that's going to trigger when we
do a search then we have our timeout
it's the one here so copy this one move
it inside of there
instead of cons timer we're going to set
this one to this timeout that we created
up here
so this dot timeout is going to equal
this one here
and the first thing we also have to do
is to clear this timer
so clear timeout
this.timeout and this is why i have this
up here so that we can access it here
and clear it before we do something else
all right and inside of this timeout
here
we're going to grab our state value and
we can also destructure that one out so
const
value equals
this dot state so we grab that property
from our state
and instead of the state here we give it
the value
like this so every time we type
something in we're going to set the
state
and that will update the component and
it will trigger this one
we clear the current timeout and then we
set a new one
and at every 500 milliseconds we will
trigger this search function
just as we did before then
in the class component we have a random
method
and inside a random method we can return
this logic here we can grab this one
cut it out and paste it inside a random
method
like this and
this one we have to change this one
to this dot state value
and also when we set the state this one
isn't correct here
we should specify this dot set state
and our state will look like this we
have an object
like this and we have a property that's
called value
and the value here is going to be the
same
and now you can see we don't have any
errors in this component and that's
great
if you want you can also destructure
this value out up here
just before the return statement
const value equals this dot state
like this and then we can use the value
like this
instead
save the component go back to our
application make sure that
you're running the application then we
can try if it works
and it's working
so it works exactly as before we're just
using a class instead now
so this is how you refactor the search
bar to a class component instead
in the next video we're going to
refactor the home page
we refactor the search bar into class
component and now we're going to
refactor the home component
so make sure that you're inside the
home.js file
and first we can remove this hook here
like this and up here we're going to
import the component
and the home function we create a class
called home
that extends component
like this and we use some fetch we're
not going to use that one we're going to
copy that logic
and use it inside of this component
instead
so we have our state
equals an object and i'm going to have a
property for this one that's called
movies that's going to hold the array
with all the movies
and i'm going to give it the initial
state
and this one we have that one inside of
our hook that's called use home fetch
so copy this one
and we can paste it in maybe here
initial
state
initial state
yeah it shouldn't be a semicolon because
this is an object so we have a comma
and then we're going to have the search
term because now we have everything in
the same state
we can't separate them out
then we have is loading more
is going to be set to false initially
and we have
loading it's also going to be set to
false
and we have the error false so this is
how the structure of a state is going to
be
yeah i said that this one is going to be
an array but it's going to be an object
and then we have the results that's
going to be an array that holds all the
movies
so you can structure it however you want
this is the way i choose to structure it
the movies is
the data that we get back from the api
and the other ones are the ones that
we create ourselves all right
then we're going to make some room here
and go back to the youth home fetch hook
we have our fetch movies function here
so grab that function
everything copy it go back to the
home.js file
and paste it in here below the state
we have to remove const fetch movies
it's the same here
here we have to do something else
because we don't have this state
as separate states now so we remove this
once
and this dot set state we have our
object
we set the error to false and we set
loading
the true like this and here you can see
we're only changing the properties that
we want to change
react will merge the other ones
automatically
and this is actually different from how
the state works in a functional
component with you state
with the you state hook it won't merge
the old stadium so you also have to make
sure that you also provide that one
if you want to keep it but in this case
we're changing the error and the loading
here
and other ones will stay the same so
this is how it works in class components
all right we have our movies this one is
going to be the same
the set state is going to be quite
different now
first i'm going to spread out the
previous state
and then i'm going to have my movies
property
because inside of this movie's property
that we created up here
we're going to place everything that's
returned from the movie database api
and that's the stuff that we have here
i'm actually going to remove the sidebar
also
so move this one up inside of the
movie's object here
so we spread out the previous movies and
now we have the results
and then we check if the page is greater
than one just as before
but here we have to change this one
because from the previous state
we also have to go inside the movies
property
like this so prep dot movies dot results
the movies dot results is going to be
the same here because this is the new
data that we grabbed from the api so we
merged that one
and this one is also going to be the
same so this is our set state for the
movies
and then below we have a coma and then
we set loading
to false
and then inside of the catch we don't
have the set error so this
set state
we set the error to true
and we also set the loading to false
like this we can remove this
set loading here so this is our fetch
movies
method that's called a method now
because we're in a class
then we don't have the use effect here
to trigger so we're going to have a few
functions here
we're going to have one that's called
handle search
equals we have the search term
i create an arrow function for this one
and when we search for something we're
going to
call this set state parenthesis and we
have our state object
movies we're going to set the movies to
the initial state just to reset it just
as before
and then we also give the state the
search term
and as this is es6 syntax we don't have
to specify it like this
it's enough to just specify search term
when the name is the same
okay so we set this date and when we
have set the search term and also reset
the movies to the initial state
we want to do something when that state
has updated
and in the react class on the set state
we have a callback function that we can
use
that will trigger when the new state is
set so we have a coma
and i create an inline arrow function
here
and go on another row here so then we
want to fetch the movies
this dot fetch movies
and we give it the one because we're
fetching from page one
this dot stayed and we give it the
search term like that
and we can actually remove those curly
brackets i don't think we need them
if we don't want to have them it's up to
you to decide
all right so that's the search then we
have the handle handle
load more function and it's also going
to be an arrow function like this
and i'm going to type it in on another
row this dot
fetch movies and from this dot stay dot
movies we have the page and we're going
to add one to the page because now we're
grabbing the next page
and then we give it this dot state the
search term
so we also provide the search term if
we're in a search
all right
we can't actually order format it yet
because there's some arrows down below
here
so we're going to create a render method
and then we're going to move this one
this logic here
inside of the render method like this
and then we have a few things to correct
here
so first i wanted to structure out some
stuff from the state
so up here as the first line in the
render method
i have a const i the structure of the
search term movies loading
and error equals this dot state
all right so that will fix a few things
here we have to change state because
it's going to be from the movies dot
results
and i do that on all three of these
movies
and instead of set search term on the
search bar here
for that prop we're going to give it
this dot handle
search and here
instead of state we're also going to map
through the movies.results
down below here we change state
to movies and this callback here
is going to be this dot handle load more
instead
and now we can order format it and
hopefully we won't have any errors but
there's one more thing that we have to
do
because it won't fetch anything yeah
yeah of course i have to have this
not set state
and i haven't imported the api either so
go back to the
use home fetch
grab this one up here copy and go to the
home
and we can paste it in here and this
will get rid of all the errors
but we're not actually fetching anything
now if we save this one
go back to the application you can see
that it it's empty here because we want
we don't trigger anything
we need to have a life cycle method to
trigger when these components mount
and we have a life cycle method built in
for that it's called component
did mount so we call that one and inside
we're simply going to invoke this dot
fetch movies and we give it
a one because we want to grab the first
page
order format it and save it go back to
the application
and now you can see we have our data and
our movies here
and hopefully everything works as it
should
yeah it works so that's how you do it
and yet again the app will look exactly
the same here
we have the same functionality in the
application itself
but we have refactored the home page to
use a class component instead and as you
can see
i think there's a lot more code here and
i think it's actually
not that easy to separate out things so
that's why i prefer to use functional
component and
use state hook and use effect instead
i don't really like this way of doing it
anymore
especially with the state because you
have to nest a lot of stuff here
as you only have one state it's much
easier when you can separate them out
into different states
as you can with a used state hook all
right just one more thing to do in this
section and that is to refactor the
movie component to use a class component
instead
and that's exactly what we're going to
do in the next video
we're almost finished with the
refactoring and the class components we
only have the movie page
left to do and we're going to do that
right
now so go back inside of the code editor
and inside the movie.js
file and for this one we're actually
going to do a little special
thing here and that's because we are
using this hook here use params that's
from react router version six
and there's actually no good way of
grabbing the params in a class component
with react router they have completely
removed that functionality
and they do not support that for class
components that's why i'm going to do a
little trick
down below here at the bottom just above
where we export this one
here we're going to create a functional
component for this one
const movie with params
like this and then it's going to take in
some props
we have an arrow function i'm actually
going to remove the sidebar again
and then we have our movie component
that we have up here
so this one is going to spread all the
props that this component receives that
way we can have
more props if we want to do that so we
just pass them along to the movie
component
then i'm going to create a prop that's
called params and inside here i
invoke use params like this
and then instead of exporting the movie
itself i'm going to export movie with
params so what i'm doing here is
creating a wrapper component
that will show the movie class component
and also provide it with the params for
us
so that's the best way i found of doing
this actually
there may be some other solutions also
but i think this is actually kind of
neat because you can do it
on one row like this before you have
something that's called with router that
you can wrap your component with
but that's actually not provided in
direct router dom
or in the react router library anymore
so that's why i have to do it like this
all right
so let's refactor this one we're gonna
remove this hook here
and we can also grab from the use movie
fetch hook
we can grab the api import and
i'm gonna paste that in the movie up
here somewhere
maybe there and we're not going to use
that hook anymore
and of course we have to rename this one
also
and up here we're gonna
import component just as before and we
rename this one we create a class class
movie extends
component and this one we can remove
that one also
and we can actually create a random
method right now
and move this logic inside of that one
something like this
all right and now we have some serious
refactoring to do here
so first we're going to create our state
so we have our class property state it's
an object
movie i'm going to set that one to an
empty object to
start with then we set loading
to true and error
to false like this
all right i did some water formatting
there also
then from the use movie fetch hook i'm
gonna copy this fetch movie function
like this and for this one i'm not going
to implement the session storage
so i'm just copying this one here and i
didn't do that in the home component
either
all right paste it in here in the movie
component we remove the const from fetch
movie
as just before we have to refactor this
one so this one becomes this set state
parenthesis and we have our object error
it's going to be false
and loading is going to be true like
this
and then we can also the structure out
or prop
because we're sending that in with that
special little component that i created
down here
so now we have access to a prop that's
called params
so the structure that one out because
we're going to need the movie id
like this equals this dot props
dot params and that will grab that one
for us
all right these ones are going to be the
same and this one also
set state we have to change this one
this one also this dot set state
and the state is gonna be
movie we have that property it's an
object
so we move these ones up inside of that
object
and then we have a coma and we set the
loading property to
false like that
and that should be it for that one we're
going to remove the set loading
and here change the set error to this
dot set state
parenthesis and object error
true and loading the
false all right
and i think that's it for that function
and then we're going to have a life
cycle method also for this one
the component did mount we're going to
do something when the component
mount and the only thing we're going to
do is to invoke this dot
fetch movie
and then down below in the render
function
we can destructure out from our state
const we have our movie
we have the loading we have the error
and that's it then we grab them from
this dot state
and hopefully it will work here now yeah
i think that's fine
do some more formatting and let's see if
it works we save the file
go back to the application
yeah it's grabbing from
the session storage now i think
yeah it works
so that's sweet we have successfully
refactored this application
into something that what i think is a
worse application because we're using
classes now
i wouldn't do it like this i would keep
the functional components
and the state with hooks and the use
effect and use state stuff that we use
in the application
but it's up to you to decide that but
hopefully this gave you an idea on how
class components works in react and to
keep stayed in class components
and the life cycle methods there's more
life cycle methods
but i won't go into them here because
i'm not using them in this application
so that's why all right in the next
bonus section i'm going to talk about
typescript and we're going to refactor
our application into typescript
welcome to this bonus section where
we're going to refactor application
into using typescript and typescript
itself is quite a large topic so we will
only scratch the surface actually
but hopefully that's going to be enough
to give you a basic understanding of how
typescript work
and especially with react so typescript
is
an extension of javascript and it adds
types to javascript
so that's great because javascript is
actually quite a loose
language where you can do whatever you
want and it still works so it can be
a little bit messy if you're in a large
application so typescript will transpile
down to javascript in the end
so that's why as they say here all valid
javascript code is also typescript code
so you can decide
how much you want the type stuff and how
strict you want to be with typescript
and typescript is gaining a lot more
ground and it's almost a standard today
when you create something from scratch a
lot of applications of course don't use
typescript
as they're old and there's a lot of code
base out there that hasn't been
refactored
and you probably shouldn't do it for all
of the applications either
but typescript is great if you have
quite a large application
and you want to keep track on types and
it's really great
also because it's kind of like i have a
second coder beside you that tells you
what you do wrong
meanwhile your code so it's a great way
to write
a lot more error less code i think
that's one of the great things with
typescript because you have
a really powerful intellisense with
typescript and it will tell you if you
do something wrong
all right that was a really short
introduction to typescript
in the next video we're going to set up
our project and start refactoring our
application into using typescript
all right let's start refactoring our
application into using typescript
and i'm actually going to create a
complete new application with create
react app
and that's because you can also create
an application with typescript support
and it gives you some defaults and setup
that we can use so we don't have to do
that ourselves
if we look here with create react app we
can flag it with
template and typescript and that will
create our application with typescript
support so that's what we're going to do
first
so make sure that you're inside a folder
where you can create a new
project and then go inside your terminal
i'm just going to
show you this also and then we type in
mpx
create dash react dash app
and then we name our application react
rmdb
dash ts and i think you also must have
only lowercase letters in your naming
then we flag it with template and
typescript like this and we press
enter and we wait for it
all right that's the bootstrapping of
the application itself
so let's navigate inside of that folder
cd react
dash rmdb ts and you can see that we
have some different
files here so that's great
we have one more thing that we need to
do before we can start coding and that
is to install our dependencies
in this typescript application also so
we have the style components and we also
have
the react router so let's start with the
style components
mpmi style dash components
and as this is a typescript project we
also need the types for style components
and if a library won't provide you with
types by default
you can usually find the types in ad
types
forward slash and then you can type in
the name of the library that you're
installing
so in this case it's going to be add
types forward slash style
dash components and we press
enter all right so that installed
correctly and then we also need to
install
the react router the next version the
version 6 and the types for that one
so mpmi if you remember we also
installed a library that's called
history that one is used for react
router
so history space and then we have the
react
dash router dash dom at next
just as before we're grabbing the next
version and that is the version six
then we have a space and we're going to
grab the types for this one also
so add types forward slash
react dash router
dom and we press enter
all right so that's the dependencies we
need for this project but there's one
more thing we have to do because now we
have bootstrap this new typescript
application
but we want our old files inside of that
one
so if we look here here's the file for
this project
i'm also showing the hidden files here
so we have the git and git
ignore so now inside of this src
folder here we have all the typescript
files
but we want our files instead
and therefore we can actually remove
some of those files here
we don't need to set up tests we don't
need a service worker
we don't need a logo index css app
we can still keep the index actually
because that one is already set up for
us
the other ones we can delete so just
keep the index tsx
and the react app and the dot ts
and remove the other files
like this and then from our finished
application i'm using the hooked version
now
so not the class based one use the hook
based one
and we're going to grab from the src
folder the
api app components config global style
helpers hooks images
everything except the index.js file copy
this once
and go inside the src folder of the
newly bootstrapped
typescript project and paste them in and
the application won't work now because
we have to
do a lot of stuff here to get it to work
but that's fine
there's one more thing we have to do
also and that is to copy your
dot n file
like this or if it says that you can't
copy it because it's hidden you can
create a new dot n file
and set up your environmental variable
for the movie database api there again
so just copy so just copy that code from
your other end file and create a new one
and paste it in because it's really
important
because we need that one to be able to
fetch data from the movie database api
we have copied all the files that we
need for our typescript project
and that means that we can close the
other project and we're going to be in
the new project from here on
in the next video we're going to convert
these base files here
the api app config global style helpers
and stuff like that into typescript
and then we'll move on with the
components and the home and the movie
page
okay before we do anything i have to
correct the mistake i did in the last
video and that is the
dot n file it shouldn't be in the src
folder it should be in the root folder
so move this one out to the root folder
of your project
and make sure that it's outside the src
folder otherwise it won't work
we can go inside of our terminal and try
to start the project up we will get an
error or
probably a lot of them as you can see
because we haven't actually converted
anything into typescript yet so that's
why so first in the index.tsx file we
have to do some cleanup
we're going to remove the index.css
we're going to remove the service worker
like this and save the file
and then we have something that's called
react app dash m
dot ts and this is the references for
the types for react scripts so
we leave this alone and also we have
something here that you can see that's
called
tsconfig.json and this is the the config
you can set up
for typescript so this is why i wanted
the bootstrap application with create
drag that because they already set this
one up for us so they have a lot of
great defaults here that's set up for us
and if there's something special you
want to configure for typescript you can
do it in this file
so you can add them here there's
actually a lot you can do to set it up
just as you like it but we're not going
to do that we're going to use the
defaults that
create react app provides for us so we
cleaned up the index.tsx file
and we're going to refactor all of the
other files here
in this video so we can start with the
api.js file we have to rename it so
we're actually going to rename
all of these files because they
they should be called dot ts so that it
indicates that it's a typescript file so
we rename them
to dot ts
instead
all of these files is going to be dot ts
the app is actually going to be dot tsx
and that's because we're using jsx
inside of that one otherwise it won't
work
so every time you use jsx make sure that
you have the file extension.tsx
otherwise typescript will fail
all right so that's the renaming of the
files and then we can start in the
dot ts file and for this one we're
actually going to create some types
because we're returning data
from the api and we need to type that
data
but first we can start to actually type
the functions themselves
so here you can see the complaints now
parameter search term implicitly has an
annotype and that's because we haven't
set any type
this one if we want to specify a type on
this parameter
we use a colon and then we specify it as
a string
and you can see that it stops
complaining now and that's great
and the page this one is actually going
to be a number so we specify it as a
number
so that's how you specify parameters you
have a lot of types you can specify for
them
and then if you want to specify the
return type on the function you can see
that
typescript actually won't complain now
because the default setup
don't force us to specify a return type
but i want to show you how we can do
that and in this case
it's a promise that we return because
we're fetching from the api and we get
back a promise
so if we want to type the return type to
be a promise
we have a colon here
and then we specify it as a promise but
the promise needs something else you can
see here
represents the completion of another
yeah blah blah blah generic type promise
requires one type argument and when
you're sending a type argument to a type
like this you do it inside
of angle brackets and we're going to
specify
that this is going to be the type of a
new type that we're going to create
that's called movies we haven't created
this one yet so
of course it complains so we're going to
do that in
a second we're only going to specify
this const here also
the endpoint that we create here we have
a colon and then i type it as a string
so that's how we type this function and
now we're going to create a type
that's called movies and the actual data
that we get back from the api
it's it has a lot of properties so i'm
only going to type the properties that
i'm actually using inside of the
application
so we can mark it with types here
and then i'm going to export this type
because i'm going to use it in another
file so that's great
you can also export the types you don't
have to specify them all over the place
you can specify them in one file and you
can export them and
import them wherever you need them
so export type
movies
like this and from the api we get the
page
and that one is going to be a number you
could also create something that's
called an interface
and then you do like this
they are almost the same today in the
new versions of typescript
before there was some major differences
actually the recommendation is to use
type in a react application so we're
going to do that
so export type movies and then equals
and the object
then we have the results and the results
is actually going to be all the movies
we're going to specify another type
that's called a movie that's a singular
movie
and this one is going to be an array so
it's going to be
an array of the movie type so this is
how you specify that array so if you had
an array for example with only numbers
you could specify it like this but we
are going to create
another type object that's called movie
and we're going to do that in a second
but first we're also going to type the
total
pages it's going to be number a number
and then we have the total results that
one is also going to be a number
do some more formatting
and you can see in the type object here
that it uses semicolon and not coma as
in a regular javascript object
i actually think it will work with coma
also
but the formatting is set up so that it
uses c my column but you can see that it
it seems to be working but when i want
to format it
yeah it will return to the semicolons
okay
right so we need to specify each
specific movie here so we create another
type that i export
export type movie
equals an object and here we have a few
more of
the different properties so we have the
backdrop underscore path
it's going to be a string the id is
going to be a number
the original underscore title
is going to be a string
the over view
is going to be a string it's easy to
have a typo here so be careful
popularity is going to be a number
poster underscore path is going to be a
string
the title is going to be a string
the vote underscore average
is going to be a number and the vote
underscore count is going to be a number
the budget is also going to be a number
and then we have the runtime it's the
number also and
and the last one is the revenue
and it's also going to be a number so
that's the type object for
a singular movie and now you can see
that it won't complain here because
we're using that one and telling
that the results is an array of the type
movie so each element in the array is
going to be an object
of this type so that's how we specified
it now
all right and you can see that it won't
complain here now
because we're using this type here the
movies so that's fine
then we move on to the fetch movie the
singular fetch
for each movie we have this param here
so we have to use parenthesis when we
type this
the movie id is going to be a number and
the return type is going to be a promise
again and this time it's the movie we
already created this one because it's a
single movie so we have this object here
so that's great and we can also specify
the endpoint you can see that it won't
complain
because the default setup won't force us
to specify everything but it's always a
great idea
to specify what type you return in the
const
all right so that's the fetch movie
and you can see here also bonus material
for login we're not going to type this
once i'm going to stop here
for the basic fetch functions here so
fetch credits
we have the movie id that one is going
to be a number
like so and it will also return a
promise
and we create a type that's called
credits
but before we do that we can also
specify the credits endpoint
as a string all right then we go up here
again
just below the type movies we're going
to export the type that's called
credits it's always a great idea to
export the types because you never know
when you need them
that way you make sure that you can
access them from anywhere in your
application
the id is going to be a number the cast
we're actually going to create a new
cast object for that one so it's going
to be an array
with an object that we specify as a cast
and we're going to do that in a second
we have the crew and it's also going to
be a new type object so an
array of crew
like this up here
we export the type cast
equals we have the character
it's going to be a string the credit
underscore id is going to be a string
the name is going to be a string
and the profile underscore path is also
going to be a string
if you want to type this in one row
instead of typing them out when all of
them going to be a string
you can do it like this
you have a square bracket and then you
have the property
the property is going to be a string
and then the type is gonna be a string
like this
and this will also work
but i think it's better to be more
explicit and type all of them like this
then we have the crew so export type
crew equals an object job
is going to be a string name
is also going to be a string and the
credit
underscore id is going to be a number
order format it and save it and
hopefully
this will work you can see that it will
it will give us some errors here now
because i won't type this one here
or is it only yeah i can actually just
type this one so we don't have an error
the request token
is going to be a string the username
is also going to be a string and the
password
is also going to be a string some order
formatting and we have them on their own
row
so that will get rid of the arrows but
we won't focus on this
below the bonus material only these ones
here
so that's what we're doing all right
save the file so that's the api dot ts
then we have our app.tsx file
and you can see here now that it
complains because we don't have the
types for this one and that's because
we're using the next version
so in this case i'm just going to ignore
it
because i know it will work so when you
ignore something with typescript you can
do that by
command and then at ts dash ignore
and that will get rid of that error so
we have to do this for now
before it is officially released then
they will provide the types for it and
then we don't have to do it like this
and the only thing we have to do more is
to specify or react component
so this is a functional component and if
we do a colon and react
dot fc we have that built into react
so we have that type for a functional
component so this is everything we have
to do
to specify this as a react functional
component
all right save the file then we have the
config.ts file
uh the only thing we have to do here if
we want is to specify those
as strings because all of them is
strings this one can be undefined also
so yeah
well we can do it api url colon string
this one colon string and if it
can have more than one value we can have
this pipe
and we specify it as undefined also
because you can see if i remove this one
here
it complains because it tells us that
type string
undefined is not assignable to type
string because we're saying that it can
only be a string
but it can actually also be undefined so
typescript tells us that
yeah you're doing something wrong here
so this one could also be undefined so
you should do something about it
so that's what we're doing here pipe
undefined
like this and it will be happy and all
of the other ones will be strings here
so i'm just going to do it quite fast
string
string string
string and this one here
string and this string
and the last one a string
right save the file that's the config
and then we have the global style we
don't need to do anything inside of here
this is a star component so it's fine
like it is now
the helpers.ts here we're going to type
this once up also
so here we have this time parameter
so we create parenthesis and this one is
going to be a number
but the return type of the function
itself is going to be a string
so we type it like this and ours
is going to be a number
and the means is also going to be a
number
so that's it for that function then we
have to convert money
parenthesis
it's going to be a number and it's also
going to return a string
and this one is a special one so you can
see that this formatter here
the type is actually this one here into
intel
dot number format international number
format
so copy this one and we can actually
specify this as a type also for it
like so
then the last one inside of this file is
the state name
this one is going to be a string
json.pos
has an any type as a return type we can
specify any
it shouldn't actually complain here yeah
and that's because this is
named the wrong way here it should be
session stayed
so that's why so json.purse
has an antitype so that's why we have to
specify it as annie
you should avoid specify anything as any
because you remove all the type checking
here when you specify it as any because
you're saying that it can be
of any type so always make it a habit to
not use
any if you can you only use it in
specific case
like this one because this one will
return any that's why we have to specify
it as any
and that's it for these files here we
can start up our application to see that
it works
mpm start
and it seems to be working so that's
sweet
in the next video we're going to
refactor the home page to use typescript
and also the components
that we use on the home page itself
all right let's continue to refactor the
application into typescript
and move inside of the component home.js
we're going to rename this file to ts
and also i can tell you
as if we look here in the terminal i
don't run my dev environment because
when you change the file names it will
break
so you have to restart it again so
that's why i'm going to start it up
later
but if some stuff don't work because
have changed some file name or things
like that
try to break it and start up your dev
environment again
rights are renamed the home ts
like this and then inside of that
file the only thing we have to do here
is to specify this
as a react dot functional component
react.fc
and you can see that i actually made a
mistake here this one shouldn't be ts
then it won't work because we have jsx
here so this one should be
dot tsx so change that one to home.tsx
and then it will work hopefully
here we have some stuff that it
complains about and that is because we
haven't typed anything yet
in our hook that fetches that data so if
we move
inside of the hooks and use home fetch
first we rename this file to dot ts here
we're not using any jsx
so we can name it to dot ts okay the
first thing we have to do here is to
import the type
movie and we do this inside of curly
brackets because this is not the default
export
and then it complains here on the page
this one is going to be
a number and a search term
it actually interprets this one as a
string because we set it as a default
string here so we don't have to specify
anything more here
but it complains about the state and
that is because if we hover over this
use state you can see that results is
set to never
it doesn't know what type this will be
that's why we can specify it as
movie and an array so we're telling it
that we're setting this to an empty
array
but it should interpret it as a movie
array so that's why we imported it up
here
and that's why we also get the types on
the state correctly here
so in the home you can see that the
warnings has disappeared because now it
knows
all these types because it interprets
from this hook here as we're telling it
that this state is going to be of this
type
and then it follows along inside of this
file so that's super great
save the home also then we're going to
refactor the components that we're using
for the home component so we have the
button so in the index.js file
that one is going to be renamed to index
dot tsx and the style file is going to
be renamed to
dot ts because we're not using any jsx
inside of that one
and for a style file we don't need to do
anything there
but in the index.tsx file we have to do
some stuff because now we have some
props here
and we're also going to remove prop
types we don't need that one
when we're in typescript so remove
everything that has to do with the prop
types
then here are going to specify
types and i create a type that i call
props you can call it whatever you want
it doesn't need to be called props
so we have the text prop here text
that's gonna be a string and then we
have the callback
and i'm going to type this very loosely
it's going to be a
function that returns nothing so then we
specify it to void because void means
that it won't return anything
so this is a click callback all right
but it still complains we have created a
prop object
so we have to specify the button as a
react dot functional component
react.fc and if we want to specify our
props we can do that inside of angle
brackets
and then we use our props object
and then you can see that it works it
knows the types now of these props you
can see if we hover over them
you can see the types
all right so that's it for the bottom
then we have the grid the grid styles
we're going to rename that one to grid
styles dot
ts and the index is going to be renamed
to dot tsx
yet again for the styles we don't have
to do anything here because we're not
sending in any props to the style
components
in the index.tsx file we have to do some
stuff though
so we remove the prop types and also
make sure to remove them at the bottom
here
like this then i specify types
and i create a type props an object
and we have the header said that one as
a string
the children we don't need to type that
one because that's built into react
so we specify the grid to react dot fc
we have angle brackets and we give it a
props object and this is it for a grid
move on to the header header.header
styles is going to be
dot ts like this
and index is going to be dot tsx
nothing to do in the styles file but in
the index.tsx
we can do some stuff
and we only have to specify this as a
react
dot fc that's everything for the header
all right then we have the hero image
hero image dot styles
it's gonna be renamed to dot ts
and this index dot js is gonna be
renamed to
tsx instead in this style component we
actually have to do something because
we have this prop here and we haven't
typed that one
up here i mark it as
types and i create a type
props equals we have the image and this
is going to be the url so it's a string
and when you type a style component you
do it here
just after the component you choose to
create
we have the angle brackets again and
we're sending the props
like this and there you have it that's
the styles
then we have the index.tsx remove the
prop types
just as before
we specify our types type props
equals an object image is going to be a
string
title is going to be a string
and the text is also going to be a
string
and we specify it as a react dot fc
we have the angle brackets and send in
the props
and this should be it for this component
save it move on
movie and for movie and football these
are for the movie page we have the
search bar
the index.js is going to be renamed to
index.tsx
the search bar styles is going to be
ts we don't have to do anything in the
styles file
but in the index.tsx we remove the prop
types
everything that has to do with prop
types
then we have the types i create a type
props equals an object
and then we have the set search term and
this one is going to be a callback and
how do we type this one well this has
implicitly an
anatype but if we go back to the home
and see where we have the search bar you
can see here
and here we actually get that type so
when you hover over stuff
we get that type and that's really good
because we can actually just copy this
one
copy and move back to the index.tsx file
in the search bar
and then we paste it in here so this is
a react.dispatch
and inside here we have the
react.setstate actions so this is the
type for the setup for the used state
and it's a string in this case if it was
a boolean it would have said boolean
here instead or something
first we have a react.dispatch and we
specify the type that is that it is a
state action
and we specify that one that it's a
string that we're going to set this
state with
so the search bar is going to be a react
dot fc
component we have the angle brackets and
we give it the props
and that's it for the search bar
move on to the spinner the spinner
styles is going to be renamed.ts
and the index is going to be renamed to
dot tsx
the spinner we don't have any props for
that one and this one is actually
nothing to do because
it just exports the star component
and the last one is going to be the
thumb so we rename the index to dot
tsx and the thumb styles
is going to be dot ts
so nothing to do with the styles but in
the index.tsx
remove the prop types
like this and then we specify types
type props equals
the image is going to be a string
because it's the url to the image
and we have the movie id that one is
going to be a number
and the clickable is going to be a
boolean
and then specify this as react.fc
and we give it the props
and this should be it save the component
and i think we should be able to start
up our application so we run mpm stored
let's see if we have any errors
it actually seems to be working
all right that's great i didn't have any
typos or stuff like that
that always makes me happy when it works
the first time
okay so that's the home component in the
next video we're going to convert the
movie page and all the components for
that page
into typescript
so we're going to refactor the movie
component and also
actually the not found component so
we're going to start with the not found
this one is a small component so we just
specify this as a react.fc and that will
be
that one and we also have to rename it
to dot tsx
and save the file
and now if you look in the console you
can see that it gives an error that's
because we renamed that one
and that's what i meant before break it
and you have to restart it
otherwise it won't work usually okay so
let's move
inside of the movie.js file rename it to
movie.tsx
and then we're going to refactor some
stuff here so we specify it as
a react dot fc we don't have any props
for this one
and you can see that it complains now
because it can't interpret the types
here
so we're going to fix that in the hook
so go inside the hooks and
use moviefetch we rename this one to dot
ts
and we also need to import some stuff
here we need the movie
type object we need a cast and the crew
that's the one that we created all
errors we import them here also
then i'm going to specify some types
export type movie state
and the movie state is going to be the
movie
but as i'm also creating these
properties myself the actress and the
directors
i have to add these one ins so we can
actually merge them together to one type
so we use the ampersand
and then we have the object the actors
is going to be an array of cast
like this and the directors
it's going to be an array of crew
and that will create a type object with
the movie and then we merge in the
actress
and type them as a an array of cast and
then we have the directors and we type
them as an array
of crew right
the movie id it complains here we have
to specify the types
and we specify it as a number
and the use state here it doesn't know
what status is actually so
we're going to specify the state we have
the angle brackets
and then we can give it the movie state
and then it will know that this state
will have this type
but it complains now and that is because
we're setting it to an empty object and
it doesn't like that because we say that
it can only be
a movie state so we could do it like
this if we want we tell it that
it can also be an empty object
or we can do as we did before we say as
movie state like so and it won't
complain
anymore so that's everything we have to
do i think the movie id
okay yeah we also have to
make this a string because this
persistent state function is taking in a
string and this is actually a number now
so you can see how great it is with
typescript because it's telling us
when we're doing something wrong so we
convert this one to a string with a
built-in function
like this and then i bet it's the same
here yeah
dot tostring
like so and this will hopefully be it
we're back inside the movie.tsx file
and this is because we get a string back
from the api and now it wants a number
so we can convert this to a number
and there are smoother ways of doing
this so you don't have to convert it
like this but
i think it's a great practice in
typescript so that's why i did it this
way
so we can convert it because typescript
will complain if we send in the wrong
type
but of course we could be more
consistent and and refactor some stuff
in the used movie fetch and also in the
api
file to specify the correct type from
the beginning
because in the api here you can see that
the movie id is a number we could
specify this as a string
instead we can actually do that so we
make this a string and we specify this
as a number
this one should be a string and we save
it go back to the movie
and now it should work yeah
so that's probably the way to do it
instead so you don't have to do all this
converting
and now we have to refactor the
components that we use for the movie
page also
so let's begin with actors
director.styles is going to be
actor.stars.ts
and index is going to be dot tsx we
don't have any props in the styles
so we're only going to be in the
index.tsx remove the prop types just as
before
and then we have the types
types i create a type props equals an
object
we have the name it's going to be a
string
the character is going to be a string
the image url is going to be a string
also
and we specify this as a react
dot fc and i give it a props
just as before save the file
then we're going to be in the
breadcrumbs so rename this one also
to dot ts and the index is going to be
dot tsx
same goes with the styles we don't have
to do anything but in the index.tsx
remove the prop types
a lot of repetitive stuff here but
that's great when you learn things
as i told you before i specify the types
type
props equals an object we have the movie
that's the url so it's a string
and then this one is going to be a
react.fc
and we have the angle brackets and give
it the props
yeah i actually name it movie title
that's what it should say
right that's the breadcrumb then we have
the movie info
rename the index.js to index.tsx
and the movie in for styles is going to
be renamed to dotius
and let's start in the styles because
this one we're sending in some props too
up here i mark it with types create a
type
props equals
we have the backdrop and it's going to
be a string
just as before we have the angle
brackets here on the component that we
create
and we send in the props don't know why
it's still red
yeah that's because this one should be
named animated
movie info like this
so yet again you see typescript is great
because
it will warn us if we don't do stuff the
right way
it will warn us save it
because i didn't see this actually when
i created it before in the course
i forgot to name this one and i didn't
see a warning but now typescript warns
me about this
save the file and go inside the
index.tsx file
like this we remove the prop types
and we're going to have some types for
this one
and for this one i'm going to import the
movie state
from dot dot forward slash dot dot
forward slash
hooks and use movie fetch
like so and then i also gonna specify a
type
props equal an object and we have the
movie
and the movie is going to be the movie
state type
so you can see here i import the types i
don't have to specify them again
i mean if you really love structure you
can create specific files for your types
and have them inside of those files
all right movie info it's going to be a
react.fc
i'm going to give it to props like so
all right then it complains here this
one shouldn't be here
and it complains again i did a mistake
here and you see typescript it is great
it tells me
that i did this mistake yeah and that's
because i'm not providing a movie idea
for this one because we shouldn't be
able to click it
so go back inside of the thumb and this
one
movie id should be set to optional and
you can set an optional prop
with a question mark like this save the
file
go back and you can see that the warning
disappeared from the movie in full
all right save that file and we only
have one more component to go
that's the movie infobar rename this to
tsx
and the styles to dot ts we don't have
to do anything with the styles
and inside the index we remove the prop
types
like this and then we specify the types
so i have a type props
an object time is going to be a number
the budget is also going to be a number
and
the revenue is going to be a number
and then we specify this as a react fc
we have the angle brackets and give it
the props we order format it
and it should hopefully work save the
file and this my friend should be
it actually we have successfully
hopefully
refactored this one into typescript so
let's make sure that it works go inside
the terminal and run
mpm stored
and it works super great
there you have it you have a typescript
application now
and everything works as it should
no arrows anywhere sweet
that is the typescript part and in the
next part i'm going to show you some
extra stuff that the movie database can
do
and that is a neat little login system
and then you can vote on the movies
we've reached the last section of this
course so first congrats
to you because you come a long way in
this course and i hope you've learned
something about react
in this part of the course i'm going to
show you how to create a login for the
movie database api from our application
and you will be able to vote on the
different movies
so first i just want to show you on
developers.themoviedb.org
what we're going to use to make the
login work so down here where it says
movies i clicked on this one you can see
the complete api for the movies
and they have one here that's a post
that's called rate movies so this is the
one
that i clicked on here and by posting to
this url here
we can rate the movies and we have to
provide
our api key and we also have to provide
a session id so that's where we do the
login and the login
is i think somewhere
people search where do they have it
authentication they have a lot of stuff
here and first you have to create a
request token
and then we create a session so we get a
session id so there's two steps you have
to do to be able to log in
and they also recommend you to actually
reroute to the movie database
for making the login but i also provide
you with a solution here
that i don't actually recommend where
you can log in from your own site
without
leaving that application or the site so
that's the one i'm gonna use here
and the reason for this bonus chapter in
the course is actually that i want to
show you how to create
a global context and store the user the
logged in user
in that global context that's the main
part that i want to show you
and also i got a lot of requests to show
how to make a login form
and be able to vote on the movies there
is one thing though
that's not going to work with this
solution because it's not a fully
solution really
in this case you have to use your login
from the movie database
to be able to log in so we won't be able
to create any new users
and stuff like that and the best thing
would probably be to build your
own api your own backend somehow to have
your
users log in there and save data so that
you can save
all the stuff about the user so there's
a lot of different approaches and this
is
absolutely not a fully login system and
voting system
i just want to show you some small tips
and tricks here to get you started if
you want to create
your own fully functional login system
and stuff like that
okay so let's get to it i'm just going
to show you the code
shortly here before we move on in the
api.js file
i have created these functions for us
here down below this comment here bonus
material below for login
i have a function that's called get
request token so that's
that will obviously get the request
token from the api
and then i have this one that's called
authenticate
and i i did some comments here also so
first we have to
authenticate the request token that we
get from this one
and then we have to get the session id
with the request token so there's
actually
three steps and not two of them because
we have to get the request token first
and then we authenticate that request
token and then we get the session id
and then we are logged in and then i
have this function down below here
that's called
rate movie and this one will send a
rating score to the movie database api
and hopefully
return an object that says that we were
successful
so that's what we're going to be using
in this part of the tutorial
so let's get started in the next video
we're going to create a global context
and a global state
that we can use to store the user in
all right let's start by creating a
context for our application and
we are touching on kind of advanced
stuff now in react
so don't feel bad if you don't
understand all of this stuff the first
time
all right inside the src folder we're
going to create a new file that we call
context.js
all lowercase letters
so it should be in the root of the src
not in the components or anything like
that in the root of the src
i can close this once here so we have
the context.js file and inside of that
one we're going to import react
comma and the use state
and we import it from react
then i'm going to create something
that's called a context in react
and when we create a context we are
creating something that will make it
possible for us to provide our
application
with something in this context that we
want to use down in the component tree
in the application in this case it's
going to be a state value and a setter
that we're going to use
so the context can be any value that you
want to provide down to your application
but it's really really handy if we want
to have a state and a setter
that we want to be able to access from
anywhere in the application
so i'm going to export this one because
we have to import the context
in the component where we want to use it
so export const
i call it context with capital c
you can call it whatever you want it
doesn't need to be named context
and from react dot we have something
that's called create context
and i call this one you could also of
course import it up here
like this we can do that instead if you
feel that that is better i don't know
really
all right then i'm going to create
something that's called a provider
the provider is going to wrap our
application and make sure that we
provide this value to our application so
we can decide where we want to wrap this
provider in our application in our case
we're going to wrap it
in the app component later so that we
give the value
to our complete application so we wrap
it high up in the hierarchy
so that the complete application and all
the components will have access to this
value
so i create a const i call this
component user provider
either structure out the children's
because we're going to use this
component to wrap our application so
that means that the children
is going to be the app in this case i
have a fat arrow
and then i'm going to create a state
const state
set state just as we did before
i call the use state hook and i can give
it the value of undefined
as initial value right
that's our states we're creating this
one in the user provider
then we want to provide this one to our
application
so i'm going to return from
the context we created up here context
that's a component we have something
that's called a provider
the context dot provider capital c
capital p
and then we have a prop that's called
value and inside the value prop
we can provide this value that we want
our application
to have access to so we have curly
brackets
and i want to provide an array with a
state and a set state
that will make sure that we get the
exact same structure as we do here with
the state
we have the state itself and now we have
the setter in an array
so that's what i'm doing here i'm giving
it the exact same structured array
all right so inside this one we're going
to return the children
and this makes sure that we can use this
provider to wrap any component
in our react application and it will
provide it with these values
then we have to export default user
provider
like this save this file
we've finished here this is how you set
up a global context and a state that you
want your application to be able to
access globally now we're going to move
inside of the app.js file
and inside this file up here somewhere
we can mark it with context and we
import
user provider that's the one we created
from dot forward slash context
all right so that's our provider
component
and we want to place it high up in the
hierarchy so we can just place it here
inside of the router
use the provider
like this and i'm going to take this one
here and move it down
and i do some order formatting so we're
wrapping our complete application inside
of the user provider and this make sure
that our complete application will have
access to this state that we created
so we're going to use this one later but
first we're going to create our login
page
so that's what we're going to start
doing in the next video
we're gonna start creating our login
component and
i didn't say that i'm using the version
of the application
without typescript so you shouldn't use
the one with typescript
use the original one that we finished
before we did anything
with typescript and also before we
refactor it to classes because i'm using
the functional component
version just to be super clear so that
you know what product you're using for
this one
all right let's move on inside of the
components folder
we're going to create a new com
component that's called
login.js capital l
and we import react and we're also going
to need
ustade and use context
that's a new hook that we're going to
use to grab our context
i'm going to show you that in a second
and we import this one from react
then we're going to import something
that's called use navigate
from react dash
router dash dom and this one is used if
you want to navigate programmatically
in your application then we're going to
need the functions that i showed you in
the api
file so import api from dot dot forward
slash
api
and for this one we're going to reduce
the button component so i mark it with
components
import button from dot forward slash
button all right
and then we're also going to create some
styles for this one
so we can actually do that now and
scaffold them out first
so we create a new file in the
components folder that's called
login.styles.js
we're going to create the actual styles
in the next video but for now we import
styled
from style components
and we export const wrapper and it
equals
a styled.div and double backticks
save the file go back to the login.js we
mark it with styles and import
wrapper from dot forward slash
login styles login dot styles
like this and then we need our context
so i mark it with context
and we import context from
dot dot forward slash context and that's
of course the one that we created before
all right then we can create our
component
const login equals
we don't have any props for this one we
make an explicit return and we have a
return statement
and we can create the jsx first
i'm just going to export default it
first also so i don't forget that one
export default
login in the return statement we're
first going to return our wrapper
and inside the wrapper i'm going to
create the label
i'm going to type in username colon
and then below that one i create an
input field input
the type is going to be
text the value
we're going to grab the value later from
the state so i'll just mark it with
state value for now
and the name is going to be username
the ons change
is going to be handle input
and that's a function that we're going
to create so we can scaffold this one
out here
first const handle input
equals on our function we're going to
take in the event
i can skip the parentheses as it's only
one parameter
and we just create an empty function
from now like this
then we're also going to have a function
that's called handle submit
and we leave it empty for now also
right so let's continue here with the
input
we can close this one here and then we
create another input field
the type for this one is going to be
password
we don't want to show the characters
that the user type in this one because
it's the password
input box the value
is also going to be a state value that
we're going to add
the name for this one is password
and on change
is also going to be handle input so we
have the same function
to both of these input fields and we
close it here
then we're going to have a submit button
and we use our component
the button component the text is going
to be
login and also we don't have to provide
this with a prop
that's called text and we send in the
text we could also wrap the text with
this component if we want to do that
instead and then we grab the text
with the children prop
we have a callback and that's going to
be the handle submit for this one
do some order formatting save it so
that's the basic structure
of our component we want to be able to
use this component so we have to create
a new route for it
and we can do that in the app.js file
first up here with where we have the
components we're going to import
login from dot forward slash components
forward slash login
there we have the component and then we
can create it somewhere here
we create a new route with a path
this one is going to be shown when we go
to the path
login the forward slash login and
element
is going to be our component
login and then we close the route
component
do some water formatting save it go back
to our application make sure that it's
running
i'm actually not running mine so i'm
going to type in mpem start
whoa i had it really zoomed in here
i'm going to bring up the console for
later
so if we go up here in the route and
type in forward slash login
you can see that we show our component
here so that is working great
go back to the application and the login
component
we're going to create a few states for
this one
so at the top of the login component we
create a state that we call
user name and set user name
equals use state are going to create an
empty string as
initial state for this one we create
another state
that's called password and the setter is
called
set password equals a used state
with an empty string as the initial
value also for this one
something like that
and then i also want another state
that's called error and set error
and we have a use state call and we set
it to false initially so these are the
three states that we have you could also
have one combined states for the input
fields if you want to have that i
choose to create them separately like
this
then we're going to grab our context
we're importing it up here and we can
grab the context
with a hook that's called use context
and our context is going to be the state
that we created so we create a new const
and we can destructure it out just as
before
we have the state this state is actually
going to be the user so we can be more
specific we call it the user
and the set user and it equals
we call the use context hook and this
works as simple as we just give it the
context
and this one is going to bring in the
context for us
and the user we're not going to use this
one we're only going to use the set user
so we can mark it with an underscore if
we want to do that
this is also very subjective on how you
like to do stuff like this
then we have a hook that we also
imported for our navigation
so we create a cons that we call
navigate
and we call that hook use navigate and
this will make it possible for us to use
this navigate const to navigate
programmatically in our application
all right so first we're going to make
these input fields controlled by this
component
so we have to hook them up with state
just as we did with the search bar
and we have this handle input here
where we get the event from the input
field so the input fields
the value for this one we can change
this one now
it's going to be the state that's called
username
no not a capital n all lowercase letters
and this one is going to have the value
from the password state
all right so this will make sure that it
is connected to the state
so now when these input fields change we
can make that change
in the handle input because we have an
unchanged handler on them
and we can set the different states in
the handle input and you can see here
that i give them a name
so first we want to grab the name so i
create a const name equals e dot
dot currenttarget.net and this one is
going to grab the name that i said here
on the name prop
then we have another const with the
value
and we get that one from e dot current
target dot
value so we need the name and the value
and actually
you could do this in a one-liner if we
use just one state for our input fields
we could set the name of the properties
in an object
dynamically with the name that we get
from the input field
and then we set the value so that will
create new values in the object
depending on how many input fields we
add to our application
but in this case i have a separate state
for each input field
so i do it like this instead in a small
application like this i think this is
more readable
actually but this means that we have to
check now
what input box that we type in so we
have an if statement if
name equals
username then we're going to set the
username state
with the set user name state setter
and we have the value so we check the
name of the input box and then we get
the value
if the name is username we know that we
should set the state for the username so
that's what we're doing here
and if the name equals password
we're going to set the password state
and we give this one the value also
this one maybe should have a lowercase n
instead
not an uppercase so we change this one
just to be consistent
order format it save it and we can see
if it works go back to the application
and we can type something in here and
yeah it works so we know that we have
our control components
so that's great so our inputs fields are
working
then we have to submit something and
actually grab something from the api
to make the login and we do that in the
handle submit function
the first thing we're going to do is to
set the error to false
just when we did when we fetched our
movies then i have a try block
and then a catch block and we have the
error
and for this catch we can set that or to
true
that's the only thing we're going to do
inside of the catch block
so we're going to be in the try block
now and first we need to get the request
token
so i create a new const i actually
noticed now also that i forgot to bump
up the font size
so i'm going to do that now and from now
on it's going to be bigger
okay so i have a const with the request
token
we're going to wait from the api i have
this function
get request token
and of course this one has to be an
async function because we are
waiting here so mark this one with async
so that will hopefully get us the
request token if something goes wrong
here
the catch block will set the error auto
true and we're going to handle that just
in a second down in the jsx
the const we're going to grab the
session id
we await again from the api
i have a function that's called
authenticate
and for this one we're going to give it
the request token
first
and then we give it the username and
then the password
all right so that will hopefully get us
our session id
and then we can set the user
and this one the set user is actually
the context that we created because we
are grabbing the context here
and the setter for the user so we're
setting this one in the context
i'm going to set it with an object first
i want to set the session id
so i give it from the session id that's
the one that we get back from the api
we have a property that's called session
underscore id
all lowercase letters and then i'm going
to set the username
and as this is also es6 syntax i don't
have to type out this twice because it
will interpret this
automatically
all right and then we just have one more
thing to do and that is
we have to navigate somewhere when we
successfully logged in
so we can navigate programmatically with
react router
we use the navigate that we got here
from that hook use navigate
replace that one we place what we get
back here in the navigate const
so navigate parenthesis and we just
specify the url and in this case we want
to go to the home page
so we specify it like this and
i want to do some console logging here
console.log
the session id just to see that we get
something here
save the file go back to our application
and now we haven't styled this one we're
going to do that in the next video
but we can use the input fields here
anyways
so my login is vaben then i have my
password that i'm
not going to tell you something like
this and i try to log in
and you can see that we get this object
back from the api we get the session id
and
the success is telling us true so that's
really really
neat we know that our login system is
working and it redirected us to the home
page
so go back to the login page i want to
do one more thing here before we finish
with the logic for this component
down below here just above the first
label i have a curly bracket
and i'm going to create a short circuit
i'm going to check if the error is true
double ampersand if the error is true
i'm going to have a div with a class
name of
error and then i'm just going to say
there was an error something like this
and then i will format it and then i'm
going to save this file
so you can of course type in whatever
you want to save the file go back to the
application so just try to type
something in here
and click login and you can see that we
show this one here instead there was an
error
and we also get an error in our console
so we know that the try
and catch block is working so this is
our login component and the logic and in
the next video we're going to create the
styles for this component
we have our login component and the
functionality for that one
and now we're going to create the styles
for it so go back inside of the code
editor and the login.styles.js file
we have our wrapper that's the only
style component that we're using for
this one
first we're going to display it as a
flex
we align dash items to sender
and we justify the content the sender
also just the center stuff
then we set the flex direction on this
one it's going to be
column
and we can save it to see what we've got
so far you can see that we're centering
it
here in the middle of the screen so
that's great
go back to the code i'm going to set a
max width
to 300 320 pixels the padding is going
to be 20 pixels
and the color is going to be from the
variables we have a color that's named
dark gray so double dash
dark gray save it go back
just to see what we've got all right
when i set the max width to
320 pixels it's showing it to the left
but if we set the margin to zero and
auto
and save it that will place it in the
center again so that's great
all right so that's everything for the
wrapper
then we have the input we nest this one
inside of the wrapper component
we set the width to 100 on the input
fields
the height is going to be 30 pixels the
border is going to be one
pixel solid now we have a variable
for the color and we also use dark gray
for that one
then we set the border dash radius
to 20 pixels the margin is going to be
10 pixels
and 0 and the padding is going to be
10 pixels save the file go back to the
application and you can see that we
created this
nice little input fields here sweet
with rounded corners and it matches the
over
the overall look of the application
then we just want to style
or error class also dot error
and for that one i'm just gonna set the
color to red you can style this a little
bit better if you want to do that
so if we type something in here and
click login you can see that this is the
error
all right and that's actually it for
this login component i'm not going to do
any heavy styling as this is the bonus
section of this course
so if you want to do it nicer you can do
that yourself
in the next video we're going to be in
the header and show the login user and
also have a login button
okay let's create the login system from
the header we're going to show a button
to log in
and i'm just going to place it in the
middle actually here it maybe should be
to the right but
yeah as i told you i'm not doing any
heavy styling for this section
so you can style it to your own likings
later so let's go back inside of the
application
and inside the header component so the
header folder and the index.js file
the one thing we need to add to the
imports here is to actually import
the context
so we import context
from dot dot forward slash and dot dot
forward slash again
we have the context file like this
and this one is making an implicit
return now we need to have some
functionality inside of it so we have to
change this one
into an explicit return
like this and we add the return
statement here order format it just to
make it a little bit nicer
some people also have the formatting to
activate when you save the file i like
i actually don't like that because
sometimes when i save it and i'm not
finished
it starts to format stuff and i don't
like that so that's why i do it manually
instead all right
const user we're going to grab the user
from the context we don't need to set
anything here we just need the user
and we call the use context hooked we
actually need to import that one also up
here
so import react comma curly brackets
use context
so we give this use context hook the
context
and this will bring us the user so we
don't need to structure out the setter
for this state
we just need a user so that's why we're
not destructing out that one
and we can do a console.log user like
this
save the file go back to our application
i'm going to try to log in again
i click login
and you can see that we get this console
log here so we have the session id and
the username of vaben
and that's of course for weben falch
all right so we know that our context is
working great
and that's sweet so go back to the
index.js file in the header folder
and now we can use this one here so just
between
the two logos here
i'm going to create curly brackets and
the first thing i'm going to do is to
check if we have a user
and then i created turner operators i
have a question mark
parenthesis and the first thing i'm
going to do if we have a user
i'm going to show a span with a class
name of
logged in like this
and i'm going to type out logged in as
colon
and then i have new curly brackets and i
grab the user dot
username and that's from the object that
we get back from the context of course
so when we are logged in we're going to
show the text logged in as
and we're also showing the username
otherwise if we're not loading
we have a colon here and we have a new
pair of parentheses
are going to use the link component and
it's going to link two
if you remember this one the link
component is the one that we use from
react router
to navigate inside of our application
this one is going to link to the login
page
like this and inside the link i'm going
to have a span
that has a class name of
login and it says login
and then do some nice order formatting
and i'm going to move this one up and
save the file and see if it works
go back to the application we can't
hardly see it here we're going to style
this in a second
but we have a login button so it takes
us to the login page
so yet again i'm going to log in
and this is something that you also can
do if you want you can store the user
information
in the session storage or in the local
storage there's a lot of discussion
going on
on what is the best practices to use in
this case we have a session id so we
have to request a new session id on each
session from the movie database api so
i'm just storing it in the application
itself so that means that it will get
wiped
out every time you reload the
application and you have to log in again
if this was in the real world we
probably would have a login system that
will also
save this token somewhere so you don't
have to log in every time
and i actually have a youtube video
where i show how to create a backend
and set up json web tokens and how to
create a login system in a react
application
so this is a very simple use case on how
you can create a login system here
all right that was a side note i'm going
to click the login button
and hopefully up here yeah you can see
that we're showing logged in
as baben so it's working we have to give
it some styling also
and this is just going to be a couple of
rows so i'll do it in this video
so inside the header.styles.js inside
here we actually don't need the class
names that are set we can just set the
color
to a variable of white like this
and then we have the a tag
i set the color to the same varial var
double dash white
and the text decoration
is going to be set to none
order format let's save it and also if
we want we can remove these classes we
don't need them we can just have a span
on these ones
something like this save the file go
back to the application you can see that
now we see it and
yeah this is probably not the the most
beautiful
way it doesn't look that good because
i'm just placing it in the middle now
we would have some dedicated space for
our login button and stuff like that
but this is just to show the
functionality so i'm not going to style
it
any better than this so i click the
login
and i log in again click the login
button
oops something i guess i typed the
password wrong here
i log in again and that works and now
you can see that we have this white text
instead and it tells us that i'm logged
in so that's great
in the next video we're going to create
the rate component that we're going to
show
somewhere here i think
we're almost finished with the voting
system but we need a rating component
that we can place here in the movie info
component
so we're going to create that one now
move back inside of the code editor and
inside the components create a new
folder that we call rate
capital r and inside of that folder
we create a new file that's called
index.js and i'm actually not going to
have any styling for this one
i'm going to use the components as they
are so first i'm going to import react
and i'm also going to need the use state
for this one
because it is going to be a control
component i
import it from react
then i create my component rate equals
and i'm going to destructure out the
callback for this one because when we
vote
we need to have a callback function that
will do something
and in this case it's going to send a
request to the api
that's our component i'm also going to
export default
rate like this and the first thing we do
in this component is to create a state
with a value and the set value equals
u state and we're going to start with
the value
5 the rating is going to be between 1
and 10.
and then we have the return statement
and we return our jsx
so i'm going to make it simple here i
create a wrapping div
and then i create an input and the type
is going to be
range so we create a range slider
the min value is going to be 1
the max is going to be 10
and the value
is going to be our state value
and then on change we have to change
this state value
so i want to show you also that you can
create an inline function instead of
creating a function up here
so we have the event e and i create an
inline arrow function
and then we set the value e dot current
target dot value and this is enough
and we close this component all right
so that's a range slider after the range
slider we want to show of
our value like this
and then i create a p tag just to get it
on a new row
and i create a button i have an on click
handler on this button
and in this case we have an inline arrow
function because we are going to call
our callback with a value
and we give it the value if we don't
have this inline arrow function here and
we just type it out like this
then it's going to instantly run this
and it won't work so we have to have an
inline function here as we're providing
an argument to this callback function
right close it and inside of the button
we type out rate
do some order formatting save it we're
going to move inside a movie info
component in the index.js file
and up here where we import the thumb
we're also going to import our rate
component
dot forward slash raid and then
we're going to show the rate component
somewhere below
i think we're going to place it yeah
maybe here
just above the end tag for the text so i
create a new div
and inside that div i have a p
tag rate movie
and below that one we use our rate
component
and for now we don't have the function
that we're going to send into this one
the callback function
so we're just showing the component just
to see that it works and shows up
save the file go back to the application
and you can see that we have the rate
slider here
and we have our rate button it doesn't
work now as you can see because we're
not sending in
the callback function to it but this one
will work
in the next video because we're going to
tie all this together
and make it work so that when we press
this rate button we will send along this
rating number
to the api and we will rate this movie
all right we are almost finished and
this is actually the last video
in this course so hope you enjoy the
course
we're gonna tie this together so let's
move inside
of the code and inside the movie info
component in the index.js file the first
thing we have to do is to grab the
context
the context i import
context from
dot dot forward slash and dot dot
forward slash again
and context so we're going to use the
context and that means that we also need
to import
from up here the use context hooked
right and now you hopefully can see how
handy it is to have this global state
because we can access it from any
component
in the application and in this case
we're going to grab the user and the
session id
so we can send along the session id to
the api when the user rate the movie
and now we're making this implicit
return we're going to change this one
to an explicit return so return
and i create the curly bracket and then
we need to have one below also
there do some order formatting and go
back
up give it some space
and first we're going to grab the user
from our context
just that we did before so const user
use context
and we're giving it the context so this
will give us the user here
and then we are going to send in a
callback function to our rate component
here
so we're creating this function here in
this component and send it along to the
rate component
we're going to call this function const
handle rating
this is going to be an async function
because we're making an api call
we have the value
and then we can do some stuff inside of
here
so this value is going to be the value
from the range slider
so i create a new const rate equals
then i wait and from the api dot
didn't i import it up here no i also
need to import the api
we do that up here import api from
dot dot forward slash dot dot forward
slash api
like this then i go back down here and
change this one
api dot i'm gonna grab the function
that's called
rate movie and if you want to know more
about these functions you can always
check them out in the api.js file
because i told you probably too many
times now
that i pre-made these functions for you
so you don't have to do that in this
course
all right move back to the movie m4 and
the index.js file
so the rate movie function is going to
take in three arguments
so we have the user dot session id
and we have the movie dot id because we
need to know the movie id of the movie
that we want to rate
and we also want to give it the value so
that's the radium value
all right and that's actually everything
we need to do in this case i just want
to console log out the rate
to see that we get something back and
that the rating was working
so we can use this handle rating now
down below here we can give it to the
rate component we have a prop
that's called callback and we give it
the handle rating
and save the file and hopefully this
should be it
go back to the application yeah we have
one more thing to do
because i don't want to show this rate
slider
when we're not logged in so we can do
that also
so just here when we have the rating
outside of the wrapping div
i'm going to create a turner operator
i'm going to check if user
and i have double ampersand and i move
my
end curly bracket down here order format
it
and it will also order generate this
parenthesis
so if the user exists if we are logged
in we're going to show the rating
otherwise we don't show
anything save the file go back to our
application you can see that we're not
showing the rate slider now we have to
log in so we click the login button
and i log in and now we're logged in
we're going to go to a movie here and
now you can see that we see the rating
slider
so i don't actually know if this movie
is any good but i'm going to give it a
rating of
8 and i click the rate button
and here you can see in the console that
we got a success of true
and status code 1 and status message
success
and if we click raid again you can see
that we get another message because it
says that
the item record was updated successfully
so you can update your rating score if
you want to do that
there's also a resource in the endpoint
if you want to remove the score
also so there are some neat stuff that
you can do with the movie database api
and i hope this inspired you to actually
build more stuff into this application
because now you have a good foundation
and for example the next step you can do
is to create a logout button
for the user and the way i would do it
in this case is that i can just wipe out
the global context the state here
and remove the user from the global
state and that will log out the user we
don't have to do anything else
with the movie database api or something
like that
all right that's it for this course i
hope you enjoy this i sure
enjoy this this is the third iteration
of the course so this is the third time
that i actually update it
and re-record it from scratch and if you
want free tutorials you can always
visit my youtube channel search for babe
and [ __ ]
or you can go to webenfart.com if you
want
more courses from me